sinking
in quicksand i'd reach my hand out to
anyone with a stick or a rope
and say please give me a hand i made a
big mistake and i need some help
now american perspectives continues with
dr whitehurst remarks last month at the
community church of boston he discusses
his role as a whistleblower in reporting
alleged mishandling of evidence by the
fbi crime lab
good evening
i want to welcome you to our
community meeting here at the community
church of boston
with frederick whitehurst
fbi
crime lab whistleblower
here at community church of boston
since the inception of our church at the
end of world war one there's certain
values we've
raised up
some of them include things like reason
science
truth
these are things that
we're vitally interested in
as we examine how it is
our society functions and how we as a
religious body interface with our
society
come on in
democracy is also a central question
to what we're up to
and for those of us from many
political perspectives
the struggle for
the completion and fulfillment
of the promise of democracy
is a central reason that we
keep struggling
keep being
resistant
keep asking questions
we have some questions to ask
historically about the fbi
and
i think it's been easiest for us
especially for those of us who are
political to think about the way the fbi
has been used in
as a weapon against certain political
movements
but there's also a question of what how
does the fbi function in society in
general and
in this
criminal
process in the justice system what does
it mean
when the fbi is used against
drug lords or
mafia
these are some questions that um we
might have some interface with
uh the the place where we we can examine
and see
uh the fbi used as a tool against the
political movement
but if we're talking about science if
we're talking about truth if we're
talking about democracy if the
fbi has a lab
that is creating false
information
false
science false truth
then i would be happy
to see someone blow a whistle hear
someone blow a whistle
challenge
the fbi as an institution but also the
results that proceed from
fallacious science
frederick whitehurst
has a bachelor of science in chemistry
from east carolina university
his phd in chemistry is from duke
did postdoctoral work at texas a m
university
uh received his jd at georgetown
he was
a
combat veteran from vietnam did three
combat tours
worked for the fbi from 1982 until
two
weeks ago
part of the lab
from 1986
until two weeks ago
he originally blew the whistle on the
lab in 1989 and helped launch an inquiry
that finally resulted in a blistering
1997 report from the justice
department's inspector general charging
sloppy and biased forensic operations
at first managers dismissed white house
whitehurst's complaints excuse me then
he was suspended
after notifying defense lawyers of lab
errors in a case
and not until 1994 were his claims taken
seriously enough to be investigated
five hundred page study
by questioning the labs credibility
has undermined thousands of cases
the lab does as many as six hundred
thousand examinations a year including
prominently the cases of the oklahoma
city bombing
the world trade center bombing the una
bomber and the oj simpson case
currently fred whitehurst is executive
director
of the forensic justice project in
washington dc
a non-profit organization that is
examining
who
and how
people have been hurt
by bad forensic science it's a people's
review if you will
of forensic science and it is our great
privilege to hear tonight fred
whitehurst
whistleblower speaking on tainted
evidence the fbi's crime lab
[Applause]
more cameras
the fbi crime laboratory
is manned by people
they're not
any different from any of us here
they're really not
they make mistakes
if they don't have oversight
those mistakes go undiscovered
and they don't have oversight
and they haven't forever
we build ourselves as the best forensic
laboratory in the world
and never allowed anyone
to judge whether we were the best or not
i began to realize that
if you're the best football team in the
world you've played in the super bowl
if you're the best tennis player you
probably played at wimbledon
and you competed
there are no forensic olympics
but we accepted what we heard
i did too
it's comfortable to know that we're
protected
i was comforted knowing that i was
protected
i'm a professional scientist and a law
enforcement officer i was a law
enforcement officer
and i went to work for the fbi lab and
things didn't seem quite right
i spent a few years trying to
raise these issues from within the
organization
and found that i was unsuccessful
i knew that the further up the chain i
went that
the load would get heavier
but along the way
we all had to think
the load was already pretty heavy for
those people falsely accused
falsely convicted
with our mistake in science
i recognize that one of these days going
along the line i'd read something like
this
out of a boston globe article on 227 98
from the inspector general of the
u.s department of justice
but he also said whitehurst had made
overstated and incendiary allegations of
intentional misconduct that his
investigation did not find
i knew that the end of this
trail
or we might see as the beginning
at this inspector general would have to
do the same thing everybody else did
everybody else
we've all got homes we've all got
mortgages we've all got children we're
all terrified of losing our security
an associate of mine supervisory special
agent william tobin told the senate
hearing committee
last fall
the inspector general ran a good race
but he didn't get to the finish line he
ran a damn good race
he did
that 500 page report
gave us the first
view inside the first look inside
one of the reasons he ran a good race
is because a lot of people in the fbi
were willing once
someone went through the gate
to stand behind that someone
now you should get a little comfort back
the people in the fbi are again just
like we are
we have some bad apples
what i know is we've got some pretty
good apples
it's difficult for those good apples if
you will to control those guys that get
out of line
no one wants to read this sort of thing
no one wants to see at the end of that
500 pages
that along with discovering all of the
problems wrong with the fbi
that the
u s department of justice considers that
person
who blew the whistle if you will or
reported the findings
as lacking common sense
in good judgment
oh darn
my feelings are heard
you know we've gone further than that
report though
i believe in you as jurors
one of my colleagues told me one time
when he was trying to get me to change
my reporting format
about the jurors of a particular city in
the northeastern part of the united
states those people are stupid
you're going to confuse them you're
going to hurt the prosecutor's case
you're no different than i am
i don't believe that people are stupid
and if we are that's something we have
to work on but our justice system hands
over to us as citizens
the decision
when we're jurors and when you make that
decision i think that the justice system
works best when the most truth is before
it
i would be incensed if i had been
manipulated
by some well-meaning or politically
motivated individual to decide that
another human being should face the
death penalty
or should be locked in a cage like an
animal
i would be furious so you know what
i became furious
i was incendiary
i was angry
did i overstate things you can decide
for yourself
as a scientist
i have to show you my data
i have to show you where
i got that data from and i have to
explain to you why the scientific
community that understands that data
stands behind my understanding of it
fred whitehurst and a lot of good people
at the fbi
made that 500-page study success
a lot of soul-searching
some careers went down the tubes mine in
particular
oh well
but we've also won a freedom information
privacy act request
and the work product
of the inspector general is there for
you
we have it
so you can decide for yourself
as jurors as triers of fact not as
manipulated citizens
some fbi agent or some manager who
was in big trouble because of this tried
to spend it
or maybe didn't spend it that stuff's
there for you
it's been released
you can read that
at times
my concerns were not validated
one spin on that is to say hundreds of
allegations were not valid
that's a play on words because the
concerns or the allegations were not
validated
does not mean they were not valid
you can imagine that in a building full
of terrified scientists who none none
came forth before
that it would be difficult to validate
anything
that's why this mess got to be so much
of a problem for us
so sometimes when the inspector general
went forward he couldn't get people to
say what they'd said to me in the
hallways
okay you know sometimes i arrived at
conclusions that were flat out wrong
okay
but you can decide
because everything we said under oath
is on paper and it's a stack of paper
that any american citizen has access to
and i'd suggest before you listen to me
before you listen to mr bromwich
before you decide to accept one or the
other
and act
as a result of the information that
you've accepted to be true that you look
at those documents
if i draw from those documents i may
very well draw
examples that prove my position
and you will be manipulated
well you know that's what i was
complaining about at the fbi
we're manipulating juries
we're manipulating prosecutors
we're manipulating judges
we're supposed to be your eyes and ears
instead we're closing it
when we see something
at times
that would prove innocence
we're terrified to admit our mistakes
the implications of that are horrible
for some people's careers
i can draw from examples
of where
my fellow agents
admitted openly they had altered my
reports for years
why
because
they were too scientific they would
confuse jurors
or they might hurt the prosecutor's case
that's
open admission in those documents
i can tell you about a gentleman who
when asked where he got
his training in a particular field of
expertise
he said i got it
on the job
the man had an undergraduate degree in
english
he wasn't a scientist that never
practiced as a scientist but he was
testifying
in a court of law to some very complex
scientific
information data
they asked him ojt
well what on job training well at the
crime scene of course
there was a scientist there and he told
me this stuff
and you know you're an expert if you
know more than the average man on the
street and once he told me that
i knew more than the average man on the
street and therefore i felt i was an
expert
you know what that means it means that
you and i can watch dr kildare
perform an operation
on television two or three times and we
can perform that operation
that's really what it means
in this country in order to practice law
you have to take the bar exam
i think
pretty sure i went to law school i'm
taking the bar exam i can't practice law
if you want to be a doctor you need to
go to school to be a doctor
i'm not going to have
the maintenance foreman
that cleans the surgical room
after the operation and watches the
surgery a few times cut my head open or
my heart open and nobody else here would
either
but this gentleman arbitrarily decided
that he had an expertise in areas that
he didn't
a lot of examples like that there and
therefore
you to read
it's open
we want some people i know want to cast
this dark veil of culpability over the
whole fbi
let's just cast it
over all of us
when we have a major crime scene the
pressure's tremendous
in this country we want to know who did
it
and we put some ordinary people into
extraordinary situations and expect them
to perform
perfectly
that pressure can make anyone fold the
political pressures
the public pressures the pressures from
the media
can make any administrator fold
the administrator folds the next guy
down and the next guy down and finally
the buck stops here i'm looking through
a microscope at evidence
and i can't prove a hypothesis
and when i can't
the kinds of pressures that i see are
anywhere from being threatened with my
job security
to
not being included when the guys go out
for beer
well that sounds selfish doesn't it but
we don't want to be alone we want to be
in a group
all of those kinds of pressures
those kinds of pressures all add up
and if i had 25 hours i could give you
one example after another
but those pressures add up to mean
people human beings not extraordinary
human beings none of us came from mount
olympus we're guys just like you who
picked up a gun in a badge
and sat in the fbi laboratory
sometimes we fold
there's a solution for this
it's outside oversight
it's
sharing of information
the forensic justice project
is
coming into being
to gather
all the information that we can gather
about
expert witness testimony in courts of
law
in work product
to find out who got hurt and who's going
to be hurt
when these pressures come along you get
something that we call the answer of the
hour
folks will have the same data in the
same situation
and over in this
state over here they'll testify to one
thing
and over in this they'll testify to
something else with the same data in the
same situation
they'll testify to the answer the hour
we need to be able to determine
we need to be able to determine what the
scientific community believes about a
particular thing
so i'm
hopeful that we'll collect a data
warehouse that'll be available
right now the fbi's got a data warehouse
the department of justice got a data
warehouse what i want to know is what is
the final product put out in courts of
law
a data warehouse
that's available
in an open forum for discussion
if anybody here has a
client colleague brother sister
relative
facing a legal action where forensic
evidence is involved
you might want to help them
we might want to help them too you know
i'm not interested in freeing guilty
people
or imprisoning
innocent people i don't want to do that
what i want to do is see that triers of
fact have the most information before
them
that's that's important i trust you
i trust you
if i don't trust you you shouldn't trust
me
let me let you in on a secret
the fbi doesn't trust his own experts
if my reports were being rewritten for
five years
means they don't trust me
i've already found
six other people who were rewriting
reports besides the three the ig found
that means the fbi didn't trust its own
experts isn't that a valuable piece of
information for you as a trier factor
when you go on a court of law and you're
sitting there listening to a man who is
called by his organization publicly as
one of the best in the world and yet
in reality they don't trust him enough
to let him re his reports say what he
believes they are supposed to say
you need that kind of information
and i think the forensic justice project
i hope can provide that
this is not a fred
whitehurst's operation
it's
it has to be
a community operation a people's data
bank
and
you know
i guess about 10 years ago somebody told
me don't take on this thing fred
well here i am today and i took it on
and i got a little hurt my family got a
little hurt but
here i am today and i took it on i hope
10 years from now we've got a data
warehouse
i'm going to try i have to
i know people have been hurt
i have to find out who got hurt
what i like to do now is answer any
questions if there are any
yes ma'am
it validated
yes it validated it corroborated the
most
um
the most significant problems and those
were the rewriting of reports the
management failure the testifying
defaults and misleading testimony in
courts of law and those sorts of things
i wrote 237 letters
to the inspector general some of them
were hundreds of pages long
i bared my whole soul to him because i
wanted to know exactly
this is what i'm thinking i could be
wrong and i said that a time and time
again please tell me if i'm wrong one
time i said to the to the investigator i
said well make great pen pals i wish
you'd write me back
do you know
some of the things that i suspect
well yes even when you work for the
government some of the things that i
suspected
some of the inferences i made from the
data were wrong
they were wrong some of them people
would come to me and tell me things but
when faced with
my going forward with those allegations
or indications of misconduct
they would not
stand and i understand i'm sorry for
those people
so
at the end of it
the ig
has to say
overstating and in
incendiary allegations of intentional
misconduct did his investigation did not
find
okay
do you know partially corroborated you
and then they they ended it with a
little bit of
they backed off is that the idea i think
that they didn't
as my friend bill tobin told senator
grassley at that hearing
he ran a real good race but he didn't
make it to the finish line
well we're going to make it to the
finish line the door's open the race is
still on
and folks are not going into court of
law just taking for granted what fbi
um
you know folk
experts have said
we really accomplished something there
doesn't make them wrong
but it means they better have their
ducks in order as a colleague of mine
told me the other day cross-examination
is becoming brutal
that's the way it's supposed to be
defense attorneys are getting the point
where they're not so willing to just say
well if i start talking to this guy i'm
going to look silly
so
you know it goes both ways
yes sir
anthony kennedy assassination
and did they agree with the warren
commission
you know i wasn't there then in fact i'm
not sure i was old enough to wear knee
pants back then
um that was actually in 63 64 65 and
there was work
that i've been told was work done by
that lab but i don't know i mean i
really can't comment
on that i haven't the data to comment on
that yes sir
i admire your convictions thank you to
begin with
but it raises a question in my mind
about how
ordinary people like myself
might have an open door to what happens
in
cases like this
and other cases for example i have
friends who are held
before the mccarthy
hearings yes
i know friends who lived before the
coast guard
for intensive hearings
just a little right to sail on the great
lakes
they did not even have legal
representation
is what you have done you have opened a
box
asking for the right of people to be
represented to the story
can present it be presented in a logical
rational fashion
it's not just not the case
and secondly
what
do you
your opinion
what do you suggest
that would open up the
fbi
to further public uh
insights
unlike
in the soviet union
or in nazi germany
or fascist italy
but how can the
fbi be a servant of the people
we're behind stone walls and you're not
allowed in
you know what you built those stone
walls
i cannot write with a government pin
i cannot drive a government car down the
street
i can't
use a government radio without your
taxpayers dollars i know that sounds
frustrating but i started my
journey
expecting to go
as long as
some north vietnamese mothers i found
out long time ago during the vietnam war
i determined from interviewing
interrogating north vietnamese that
north vietnamese mothers intended they
were giving birth to children with the
intention of those children fighting us
when they came of age
i have that level
of
intensity also
we have the tools
the freedom of information act
we have the
desire
we can open that
my
feeling is that a lot of material that
we've got is raw material
if you came to me with an allegation
about someone
or someone came to me with an allegation
about you that's raw material that needs
to be corroborated
validated looked at worked on
rather than me telling the whole world
you have a certain right to privacy we
have to balance that
now we hide sometimes behind this
right to privacy and national security
some things that i don't personally
think we should i don't see how the
science that we do
fits behind national security generally
or privacy at all science doesn't deal
with individuals it deals with the
evidence and what have you
i think that when defendants go on a
court of law they should have the right
to what where are our protocols where
our validation studies where is the
literature that we use
where is the data
all of those things
in too many instances they don't
we can just write one-liner laboratory
reports so that defense counsel can't
delve into them and then hide behind
those stone walls
i know as an american citizen you know
i'm just old boy from north carolina
rides a pickup truck with crank up
windows
look at this
they just gave
put out two million dollars of your
taxpayers dollars because no matter what
they did unless a truck ran over me i
got an accident or whatever no matter
what happened to me i was going to keep
on going and i intend to keep on going
and everybody here can keep on going
you know this business of eternal
vigilance
it sure doesn't get it today but it says
that our children our grandchildren our
great-grandchildren will have something
to learn from some history
i know the 237 letters i wrote are there
in one day somebody is going to
persevere and they're going to get hold
of them they're going to find out a lot
of things they're going to find out i
get angry with sometimes when i write
they're going to find out i have a
six-year-old daughter
that i love very much in a wife that i
am really sorry that she was treated so
badly
they're going to read about
the sort of probe that got inside the
fbi and started talking through the
proper channels
you know
and i hear people
just being
stubborn about it until
the whole generation that's trying to
save themselves retires and the next
generation
doesn't care and they feed the stuff out
do you know
i think we have the tools
personally i would hope that
the freedom of information act
staff that we've got in government
agencies that take four and five years
to give us the information
will be quadrupled
we're paying very little for our freedom
and for justice next to the billions
we're spending in the drug wars
quadruple those staffs but we've got to
have to have citizens say
it's taken five years for me to get this
it's taken four years i wanted it 30
days later
man goes to prison based upon false
information he has to sit there while a
bureaucrat
goes through 2500 other requests before
they get to his i'd like to see it open
we have the tool
we should put that information in there
we can keep the same
protections in place for people's rights
to privacy
while opening the flow of information
faster
a lot of that information is already out
in the public sector
but people just don't know what they're
looking at or where it's at or how to
gather it
i hope that we can do that
i want any transcript any work product
from anybody
please send it do you know
please send it
and i may not look it at all but i can
catalog it and somebody else can look at
it this is empowering us
to take care of ourselves
so that when the mistakes are made again
maybe we can find them and help our
government be better right
you know i think
i'm probably going on too long answering
your question sir but
i believe that's the way we need to do
it
yes sir
an institution like the church this
church do to help you
in your battle
you know
i want that information but more than
that i'm getting people come to me right
now that believe they've been mistreated
and i'm saying well i've only got so
many assets i'm fred whitehurst
i'm a lawyer a phd chemist
but i'm a phd chemist in a little area
you you i don't know what you do but
suppose you're a plastics chemist
the people at the fbi laboratory that do
plastics we don't have any plastics
chemists we learn as much as we can in
that one or two weeks that we study it
then we go out and we qualify as experts
but a real plastics chemist
who could say well you know i don't
think they're right
who could provide the assets a real
explosives chemist a real dna person do
you know
so that it becomes
a real national asset
that the fbi laboratory the atf
laboratory whatever whether they want to
or not
they're going to face the national
knowledge
database
right now i've got a
a
email address
if there's anybody here i will give it
to you
if uh
maybe when this is over with i can write
it down
if you're willing
you say this is what i do
i know on this internet i know this is
new thing and some people don't use it
some people even afraid of it this is
what i do and
in the future if you got any need for
this level of expertise and whatever it
is and folks come to us or wherever they
go
we're now able to pass the knowledge
very quickly
i see this as um self-help type thing
not
a bloody revolution but a revolution of
knowledge a democratic revolution
lofty terms aren't they
yes ma'am well
i certainly
um i'm interested to hear what you have
to say but i i really feel that the the
fbi
particularly the fbi has such contempt
for the constitution and the bill of
rights that i i can't see how
any little
you know
oh
attempts to change their their ways of
doing things are going to do anything
unless they decide that they really are
going to treat the people of the united
states
um
the way the constitution and the bill of
rights
understand and i share your concerns and
if you're eight they really do they
treat people with contempt yes and
there's something
something that um senator senator
grassley from iowa spoke of and he calls
it supreme arrogance yes
yes sure
what we've done is we've placed people
in positions and too many of us have
held them up too high
boy you know i'm proud to carry that
badge i'm proud to carry those
credentials and i come to your door and
i'm proud that you let me in your home
and some people can't just be proud
they've got to think you've got to let
them in their home and i understand that
one way to take pride that arrogance out
from underneath people is just to pull
their feet out from underneath them
the work product of the fbi is a public
product
in many ways
is testimony in court
there's
public reports
there's
requests for appropriation
all of that is is a public information
by reviewing that stuff
and by commenting on that stuff and i
know you feel as an individual citizen
very often powerless
at times i did
but i said so
let's just keep on going because i can't
do anything but and you know in watching
you there ma'am i'll bet you probably i
would say the same thing in that
laboratory
let me give you my email address can i
give you my email address write it down
there
it's c
in as in charles f
w
h i t e
h
at
e r o l s
dot
c o m
com
if you know
of a mistreatment oh i do okay
i'm a scientist and the way i can
address
if you see that there's some mis
there's some misinformation from
forensics well we can get together and
talk about that and we can empower each
other to get beyond that wall
in front of the hoover building made of
that nice granite we can empower
ourselves well so you know that about
that well your experience is limited
what we're going to have
is a national a national knowledge base
and we've got it we've just got to be
able to pass it around so the triers
effective got access to it through the
government
if the government chooses to join
the people
yes
to be of the people and by the people
instead of too often
somewhat arrogant
you know or
by counsel hired
to protect his defense counsel whatever
i don't care how the job gets done i'd
love to have the us government on my
side
but if not
you know
okay
i've kind of had them not on my side for
a while didn't work
and i don't think it's gonna work in the
future
may but i don't think they're going to
win in the future because folks like you
are out there
if you could
you know if you've got
i can't deal with the the political
issues but i'm sure
try to point you in the right way
for the scientific issues
yes sir
mr whitehurst let me clarify you're
asking us to believe
that your project or any outside
group of investigators
can completely remove themselves
from
any ideological
notions around
you know whether or not people are
guilty or not i keep thinking
could these outside groups say
for instance that mumia abu jamal who
was convicted of killing a police
officer in pennsylvania deserves
the sort of treatment that you're
talking about
could you clarify that
you know
what i see from the position i've been
in
is we're hiding and suppressing
information that triers of fact
need
to arrive
at real conclusions
we're manipulating triers of fact
because we don't trust you
you pay me my wages
and we don't trust you
and you know i'm really kind of angry
about that well if you don't trust me i
don't trust you
now nobody trusts anybody and we fall
apart
i think that this is not me
that i'm talking about it's not a group
of investigators i'm talking about it's
this is not some wild hairy scheme this
is america anything's possible it's
information brokering
it's being there
as
a million mosquitoes can kill a lion do
you know what i'm saying
it's
if that gentleman you're talking about
is has been treated unfairly
and you can point to specific issues
that you believe
the forensic evidence
i'm forensic scientist now i don't do
say gunshot
but
there are people that do and they're
people that can express those kinds of
opinions
that might support you and it gives you
the ammunition
to to move forward more effectively with
the agenda that you've got with the
agenda of truth i hope sir do you know
where do you get that from is there a
phd chemist in the room
do you see but i am
what do you want to know do you want to
know about explosives i help you do you
want to know about plastic i help you
paint i'll help you
firearms well i'm not sure i can do that
but i bet i know somebody that can
and you know the web
creates that force and the willingness
to share
not to build these empires of knowledge
like we've done and these record
databases that everybody's terrified of
oh my goodness
you know no
what i'm talking about is the knowledge
you need finally all of this hocus pocus
we keep behind walls that's just fine
okay you do that but what we present in
the court of law in order to prove guilt
is going to be public
and it's not that mess behind the walls
it's stuff that i've been an fbi agent
for 16 years i know where we go get it
we get it from you
and then we hold it in our pocket
it might make you more effective sir
with that particular issue that you're
talking about do you know so it's not
investigative group like me
it's investigative group like us
really sounds kind of idealistic doesn't
it
prosecutors defense attorneys for the
most part judges
are not um
are not elected so we don't have a
direct say in
how they how they do their jobs i'll bet
you that
if that gentleman's got himself an
attorney that attorney would love all
the help he can get
down yes well how do you want to help
him you want the body of knowledge that
we can provide you want forensic justice
if that's the justice and so often
forensic science is a tool that's used
now by law enforcement that is not
understood
you know i have written a paper i don't
know are you here aware of the
scottsboro boys
nine young african-american men in
alabama in the 1930s that were treated
cruelly
and those
gentlemen did not have the knowledge
that they needed to overcome
an extremely powerful government
that sent them away for something they
didn't do
you know the whole nation is facing that
against science right now law
enforcement is using science
and you don't understand it and you feel
powerless by golly there's people out
there can help you and we're all
connected
why don't we disarm that
not talking about
sending guilty on the streets
and all that kind of mess i'm talking
about putting information before triers
are fact
i'll tell you one
thing one man with a lot of people that
stood up with him put a lot of
information before triers of fact in
this country one guy
and a wife that should have left him a
long time ago because this has been one
crazy ride
we can all do that
here i'm standing i'm healthy
i'm 50 years old
i'm healthy
it's possible
it's not a dream
i'm going to do it
i don't care if i have to do it like i
did this thing
i'm going to do it it's going to happen
i refuse to fail
what i'm asking then is
as idealistic as it may sound
this was too
you can't fight city hall and the fbi
runs all the city halls
nah
people wanted to know this that's why it
was successful
i know three paragraphs for a one
sentence answer
any more questions yes sir
um i just want to respond to
some of the comments made by
several of the people
i'm involved with some other people in
bringing dr whitehurst to boston
ten years ago i created maine citizens
to defend the bill of rights
where i'm from in maine
to educate my community
about fbi abuses and every year we've
been doing a conference
bringing in speakers of the caliber of
dr whitehorse
to empower people
to become active participants in the
criminal justice system
and not just victims
and
there's a tendency in our society to get
caught up in our victimhood
and to hold on to it
and get the benefits that being a victim
provides but i think we need to move
beyond
being victims of fbi repression
and start empowering ourselves
to stop the kinds of behaviors that we
know go on
with the bureau
and it's the easiest thing in the world
for you to pick the phone up and
contact dr whitehurst
or ross kelp span who's a former
reporter for the boston globe
or uh
you know there's an infinite number of
people i've brought three former fbi
agents over the last 10 years
suzanne doucette who is a year veteran
who was sexually assaulted by her
supervisor
i brought wesley swearingen who just
helped get geronimo pratt out of prison
a black panther
who
was wrongly convicted on false fbi
evidence
and i'm what i'm trying to say is that
you could be having a conference going
on here
in the heart of boston at least once a
year
i have enough material i've covered
uncovered over the last 10 years to
i'm planning for like five or six
reincarnations now to continue this work
because it's just unbelievable
so
when i hear people whining
uh it sort of triggers
you know some anger in me because
i don't see you as
any
less capable than i am
i know how to dial a phone i know how to
call
students up that have student activities
money who will help bring someone to a
college
so i would just suggest that uh
there are things you can do and you have
choices uh all of us have been victims
we've all been victimizers at some point
in our life we've played both roles
i think it's time to move beyond that
and and
take charge
yes ma'am it doesn't um and really in
real life you know really boiled down to
a
challenging fbi results
involves having access
to the evidence that they're examining
isn't that you know that's what a lot of
of their decisions and in a court of law
boils down to what they say about the
gun
or
the blood
and you know it's i don't know how you i
think your your group is wonderful that
that you're talking about how you would
have access
to the evidence that would allow you to
challenge
fbi results you know when you do an
analysis
you take measurements
the measurements are data
whatever the evidence is the
measurements are data
that data i want
i can interpret that data as well as the
fbi
give me that data
let me ask the nation
of real experts
i have a friend that's been a paint
expert for 25 30 years she's one of the
top pain experts in the world
she knows paint in the fbi in six months
you go to a few paint courses you go to
maybe a pink company you're an expert
i don't think so
the opinion that's rendered
can be reviewed
i don't need the evidence
there's a certain manipulation of which
evidence you're going to take
that gets in the way and i agree with
you
and the government has control of that
but the evidence that you can look at
can be reviewed if we can just get the
evidence
the data excuse me not the evidence but
the data
there's one way to do that and that's to
look at the job the work product
of the people who have
the privilege of
testifying in courts of law
and i'll tell you when you look at it
i've spent thousands of dollars for
transcripts out of my pocket and when
you look at it
sometimes it's obvious
i would have to be severely mentally
deranged not to see the issues
yes ma'am is it usually possible to
separate the evidence from the the
political circumstances of the the crime
so an objective scientist could look at
the pain the the fingerprints the blood
or whatever it is
a presidential assassination if
someone's looking over your shoulder if
someone's looking over your shoulder
but i i mean in in your institute
a scientist no
the the the case comes to you and you
know what the case is about
yes yes that's correct
haven't got a clue about that sir not a
clue
yes sir you had a question in the back
do you have any ideas of okay have
specific uh abuse well are there
specific abuses that you are aware of or
that you've uncovered that you can share
with us give us some examples i think
that
generally the best message to get
is how to help ourselves
the abuses of
the examples can go on and on
but it's really how to help ourselves
okay
that sort of stuff is tabloid
and um
what i want to do is empower not to not
to go to particular examples
also a lot of cases are still in
litigation
and we do the service
to bring that information out
too early you had a question sir
it was really got to this point but i
was thinking back to the oj trial
and i just think that they the the way
they took the evidence and screwed it up
was would have been impossible had they
not taken
a blood sample from mr simpson until
after all the data had been
made and locked up and sealed yes then
there would have been no question as to
yes
and i'm surprised they didn't hold that
kind of a timeline of creating their
evidence and then getting the blood
sample you know
in the rush of the situation
things happen and we make mistakes
when we go back and look at it we should
admit our mistakes
this business of covering up our
mistakes doesn't help any of us
eventually they can come out so i think
you know i've been to the world trade
center and i saw what happened there and
that was traumatic if we made mistakes
let's admit it if we can't prove guilt
because we made mistakes well we've made
mistakes
yes what kind of response have you had
from your colleagues
how much opposition they're overjoyed
yes
they're overjoyed
there are so many good people at the fbi
i really do love those people
i was sad to have to leave them they
were overjoyed that this thing was going
to move forward we knew we were sitting
on a powder keg
and they were overjoyed
and when i went back for two days at the
fbi before i i you know voluntarily
resigned
i had more people hug me and shake my
hand in that two days you cannot imagine
maintenance staff all the way to
managers
that just people were just so glad and
so proud
that
we
had said yep we made a mistake boy did
it look bad and man is this embarrassing
now there are some sore heads
and one sore head can ruin your day
oh darn
you know okay well my day's ruined but
no you would you would have been proud
my wife also works at the fbi
and she gets
you know on the on the
daily basis people that you she gets
those that come by and give her a
you know a cold stare but people are so
supportive
so now your operation is operating it's
happening i get up and get on that uh
computer at 4 30 in the morning
and i get off about 9 o'clock at night
and i stay on the computer i'm also
writing a book right now i'm in my 17th
chapter
and as i'm moving
yes as i'm moving along
um
i'm also being contacted on the internet
by people i've got cases coming into the
law office that i'm working with uh it's
it's just flowing along in fact i expect
to be overwhelmed
no there are other people what i did was
we've been putting this together for a
while and as soon as i walked out of the
fbi building got on the phone i hired an
assistant um there are people on the
advisory board uh there are people that
are on their advisory boards so it's
it's just done this
you know
we um we come at night my house we sit
down we watch wheeled fortune in
jeopardy
you know
and
i kind of like the idea of going in
there and working on something i don't
mind wheel of fortune in jeopardy my
wife likes it okay but that time just
that amount of time every day
with the knowledge that you've got
is um
it's so powerful
millions of man-hours if you want
i expect that um
some people have said to me well you
need a laboratory i don't need a
laboratory
the government already did what i needed
they already they already
looked at the work product
and they've given me their data
they may not have interpreted that data
according to what the rest of the
company the country will believe and you
know and we're moving on that we've got
a number of kids
oh no um telephone
fedex
me getting on the on the
pickup truck and driving down the road
whatever it takes whatever it takes you
know it may sound overwhelming
i don't care
it doesn't matter
i've got 25 years at least i got to do
something with it
and i don't think it's unrealistic
because this says it's not unrealistic
this says
if you want justice in this country you
can you can do that people will support
you
yes ma'am
you know it's on the internet
no it is but it's also in a book form
you can order it from the department of
justice you call um you can call
washington dc
and ask for department of justice main
operator and tell them that you want the
the inspector general's report
it's the yes it's the investigation of
the explosives
[Music]
the investigation of explosives and
other cases in the fbi laboratory the
u.s department of justice inspector
general's report issued
april of 1997.
you can also request that from your
congress person yes that that's a good
idea too because they will become
educated the more people that ask for
that report then they're going to start
wondering why
i mean to tell you you are going to if
you haven't read it yet
it's gonna bowl you over
it's gonna bolt you over yes sir
um
taking for the moment your statement
that the science community in the fbi
was overjoyed with what you did by and
large yes the two days that you were in
there and that by and large those are
good people who are interested in doing
good science yes
they can only work with what the field
agents supply them that's correct
so a crime happens and a paint sample
comes in yes is the person who takes
that pain sample
and
how is that
person controlled by the good scientists
in the fbi crime lab that you say exists
you may in fact get
a pain sample to analyze which has
nothing to do with the crime but is
being supplied to you by an agent who's
interested in convicting
that individual yes and so you may come
up with great honest data sure on this
piece of evidence
but the evidence may really have nothing
to do with
the crime other than as a tool to
convict you mean the eight the agency
yeah you mean
the agent's a liar is what you're saying
yeah suppose the asians
as i understand it you believe that
oversight is one oversight of the
science lab someone looking over the
scientific shoulder is one thing that is
important yes i'm sure we know in the
boston area that
manufactured data happens at
universities it's happened at some of
the world's greatest universities in the
boston area yes um it doesn't surprise
me that that could happen you you guard
against that by oversight
but what kind of oversight are you
suggesting that the fbi provide to make
sure that the evidence that's collected
for you to invest for you to
look at
is appropriate evidence and not
manufacturing suppose we carry that
further this may not satisfy you who
oversees the overseers who are
overseeing the overseers of the yes
no and i don't mean to be flip about
that lloyd
but
what i can control
what i can control is
judge anthony griffin says
lawyer
me
and what i can do
okay
and what i found is forensic science in
this country is unregulated
it is there's no regulation there's very
little accreditation
and
that's something i can address and
because it's a very powerful tool that's
being used then i can address that
i would imagine that you know we know
historically that there are
times in history where
more than we'd like law enforcement gets
out of line
i can't i can't do that
now you know i mean let's we'll be
realistic i can't do that we can't be at
those crime scenes
i was
you know to address to address one
particular crime scene i was in a
gymnasium one morning doing my lifting
weights and i looked up on the
television
and saw the pictures of a crime scene
and saw a bunch of people walking all
over the evidence that a few days later
came into our laboratory well
boy i'll tell you i wrote something
about that
but generally i can't do that
i think
when i studied
chemical analysis in college
one of the first things they told us is
the most important part of this step is
collecting the right evidence
well you're right we don't have people
collecting
out there
that are necessarily trained we need
evidence response teams to go to crime
scenes and that's the only people that
should be collecting evidence and we can
ask that question just by everybody i'm
sure in this room i would imagine
watched some of the oklahoma city
bombing matter
and saw those people running all over
that thing well
did evidence response teams go there yes
they did
did they follow a collection of uh
evidence collection protocol well
uh kinda okay
you could watch what they did in trial
it determined it was determined that one
young man had picked up evidence put in
a bag then put it back in place to
photograph it had mislabeled his logs
and a good attorney caught that
he wouldn't have caught it if he hadn't
got a heads up from just the whole
circumstance of the situation but you
know i'll have to give that up
i can't um
i've seen crime scenes devastated by a
lack of discipline and i'll admit that
to you
where
the important part
for the law enforcement officers over
with he made the entrance he's done the
arrest
what about all the rest of the stuff
here well
do you okay
i can't uh you know i i can't stop
that i i think we can fix this crime lab
situation
okay
now if you let let me be uh the attorney
general or something like that maybe we
can address that boy it ain't going to
happen
yeah yes sir
i grew up
with a picture of my mind of j ed dover
uh who i regard as andrew jolovian
put in plain simple language i think is
a pig
i do that on the basis of the experience
and my understanding of history
i want to know now
your feelings regarding the openness of
the leadership of the fbi to your
criticism of the practices that have
been going on
what
goes to a chance do you have
of getting your case heard
to allow
citizens like myself and others to have
their voices heard
what do you think the leadership is now
with america entering another period
of world congress
are you asking me do i think i have a
snowball's chance in hell with the
management of the fbi listening to my
concerns and mine too
no sir
i think i spent 12 solid years of my
life trying to reach the appropriate
authority
under executive order one two six seven
four i was required as a employee of the
executive branch of our government to
report fraud waste abuse and corruption
to the appropriate authority that left
it up to me to decide who is the
appropriate authority
no one listen
i didn't stab anybody in the back
i went to my supervisor and his
supervisor and his supervisor all the
way up the line
and i met
unbelievable resistance all the way up
part of that might have been my fault i
got angry sometimes
that wasn't very productive i think had
good reason to get angry
as one of the inspectors of the
inspector general told me
it's understandable but fred it's
getting in the way well
i still got angry i got angry at the way
my family was treated i get angry at
these people that should have known
better that we're paying a heck of a
salary to
turning their heads on civil rights
violations or what i considered civil
rights violation people were being
denied due process a law and i went the
whole way and that's why finally i
carried this matter to the people
you're my boss when i got a badge sir
you're my boss
and finally i want to say boss
something's wrong here and these other
guys you hired that are supposed to be
directing this thing are not listening
and it's really wrong
do you know so snowball's chance in hell
he comes from oversight
and right now we're a little bit too
close tight up there
was that real frank
yes
the only thing i want to add to this is
under chad
yes you might have seen the bottom of
the east river
yeah i think that mr hoover might have
not listened to me a lot faster than
other people didn't listen to me
yes sir
uh when you officially left i mean a lot
of people like victor marchetti had
sections of their books written out and
stuff like that were you uh
told that you couldn't speak freely
when i left the fbi yeah there are
certain things that i can't speak about
and it has to do it now it has to do
with my employment agreement with the
fbi
i know information that deals with
privacy issues of people
and i don't think that people should be
embarrassed in public why am i going out
and spouting that stuff i also know
information that if i go running around
talking about that it will hurt cases
that are being tried and defendants
deserve a right for me not to be out
there doing this outside the justice but
science information
um i'll tell you the the pre-publication
clearance
process at the fbi there for a while
with me was almost near to possibly
impossible
i almost had a threat in legal action
just to get a scientific paper out
they cleared that up
you know i put in a paper
oh back a little while ago the title of
it is addressing racism in law
enforcement a case study
and it specifically addressed racism in
a case study in the fbi it came out in
30 days
and there's nothing crossed out of that
at all
and i think it's a gollywhopper of a
paper i think it's got some real good
solid put together information
that i felt like needed to be said
because the president of the united
states said let's enter into a national
conversation about race do you remember
that well he was my boss
okay well you can see if i could do that
i put out a paper the other day that
talks about how to arm attorneys to
question some of these bogus experts
went right through 30 days i'll be
giving that speech in california in in
next month
so
when i put my book out there might be a
lot of black marks
you know
i'm writing a book and there may be a
lot of things that are redacted out you
know what that means
people that read that book if they read
that book go sit around wait for the
second edition
when we fight those black marks off
those pieces of paper in a federal court
of law
do you know and you know we're treated
pretty well in court
and if the first court doesn't like us
we have the right to appeal and if they
don't like us we can
you know the further we go the media
picks up one and then they say i wonder
what's behind those black marks
and pretty soon everybody's reading
everything in that book because they got
to get there for it's almost gets to be
the point of who shot jr
you know in dallas
what's there
well you may see the black marks though
and that's that's fine
somebody may consider what i've said is
inappropriate at the time
and
that's their opinion
you know i coined the phrase when i was
at the fbi
we too often forget
the truth is discovered
it's not dictated
and men that dictate truth very seldom
if ever discover it
you know because they don't discover it
they lose
the rest of us
100 miles ahead of them they're chills
still trying to figure out how to get
out of the starting block
do you know that's that's true
any other questions
yes sir
i just wanted to respond to uh lloyd's
concerns about who's guiding the
guardians
and
i'm involved with the national coalition
on police accountability based in
chicago
and they deal with police torture police
violence police corruption
and recently janet reno
has suggested i think they have created
a temporary
quasi-citizens review board for the fbi
and i'm not real clear on this so
uh i'm not either but it's been in the
news and
the organization i
work with this is called ancopa is
pushing hard all over the country to
deal at the local level with your local
law enforcement to create citizen review
boards
that will be responsible for the hiring
and firing of police officers who will
document document
the citizens complaints about brutality
or corruption
who will set standards for the hiring
and firing of police officers so if
lloyd was concerned about the officer or
the federal agent at the crime scene
collecting evidence then this citizen
review board could set some standards as
to how that
data information evidence would be
collected so i would urge you to
examine that as a model that could start
to bring back
control in your hands
as to the kind of law enforcement people
that you hire
and that's on the federal level as well
has your laboratory have been
by the french british governments to
contribute any of your expertise and the
allegations of
dodi payet's father who's alleging a
conspiracy
that very
that took his sons and prospective
daughter-in-law's lives in that tunnel
accident with the finding of some white
paint
there indicating that a card
whitening i'm acquainted with that eight
segments
you know all of that took place
after i was dismissed in 1997
so whether those things happened or not
i i don't know
i know that very often
we work with foreign forensic
laboratories and they work with us
uh but whether in that particular
situation there was any such um
um
working together if you will i i
couldn't tell you that i don't know that
yes yeah i'm sorry i missed the
beginning so i don't know i don't know
if you addressed this already but i
wondered if you had any either
experience or knowledge of um
abuses in the military
uh
crime investigation system because
you know i know there's certainly a lot
of abuse in the fbi and crime lab but
there's also i was working with the
gi rights network with people who are
accused of crimes within the military
and
i don't know if you've had any
experience within that but or if you
have another you know i've probably read
a lot of the same material that you have
um
just as i read this and take it for what
it's worth i read those sorts of things
i have some associates that are in crime
labs that have a lot of respect for
their work
if there are abuses they're not those
that i know about
if i find abuses
then i will target those abusers
and this is not some mccarthyism type
thing it's
well there appears to be a little
problem with this well i'll collect all
the product from this person that he's
ever done since somebody let him use a
microscope and write a report and every
bit of it and let's look and see
what his transcripts say what his work
product is
you know
i got a lot of allegations from fellow
fellow employees that when i looked at
him closer didn't pan out sometimes
there are political agendas attached to
those there's jealousies there's human
failings
i i
came up with this uh
sort of rule of thumb that i try
i wanted to see it four times from four
different sources and i couldn't always
hold of that but if somebody came to me
and said you know something about a work
product i'd want to look at it from
someplace else
it was a result of that that i waited
five years
five years before i came forward with
information about the abuse in forensic
evidence in the alcy hastings matter the
federal judge from florida where the fbi
had put out false misleading testimony
in his trial and in the impeachment
proceeding
five years i waited
and it wasn't because of who it was it
was because it was this is bizarre i
know that guy you know he's a
professional
you know he had me fooled too
but fooled well enough where do you know
what i'm saying
uh to answer your question i don't have
any specific
information
well i guess we'll wrap this up
okay
thank you
[Applause]
jesus
[Music]
all books all weekend
every weekend
now john kelly discusses the book he's
co-written called tainting evidence
inside the scandals at the fbi crime lab
the book examines the way the fbi
investigated several cases including
ruby ridge and the bombings of the world
trade center and the federal building in
oklahoma city
john kelly is an investigative
journalist he spoke at writers
scientific and professional books in
washington dc
before we start i want to encourage
people to to jump in at any point as i'm
talking and just you know
ask questions or
ask me to elaborate because
i don't like the idea of giving lectures
so
uh
yeah
i wanted him to have that chair
all right we'll save a chair well
there's no chair here for him
it's all right we can get it
okay i guess i guess we'll start
uh last last summer when i was actually
uh
working on on the book
my five-year-old daughter hernandez came
to me
and
she said dad
you have to stop writing about the fbi
so i was kind of taken aback and i said
well why and she said dad
because you can't
walk away from them and go home
they follow you
so i i want to
i want to dedicate my talk today to the
to the day when the
fbi stops following people especially
innocent people
in alabama
on
[Music]
death row in alabama is there there's a
man called walter leroy moody
known as roy moody
and he's going to be executed this year
or next
um
for the bombing of a federal judge in
1989 judge robert vance
um
roy moody was convicted
prosecuted by
fbi director
louis free
back in 1991
and there was absolutely no evidence
uh against mr moody
so i i would like to open with an appeal
to
fbi director lewis free's conscience
that he come forth with the truth in the
case of roy moody before he's executed
what happened in that case
was a classic example of how the fbi
misuses the laboratory
there was no evidence against roy moody
and
what happened was was 1989
1990
and the bombing of the federal judge and
a civil rights attorney in the south
was considered at that time the largest
domestic terrorism case
in this country
and george bush referred to it in his
state of the union speech
so there was tremendous pressure to
convict somebody for the bombing
um
in 1991
lewis free who was a prosecutor in new
york at the time was assigned a special
prosecutor
and what he did
was
um
he constructed a case against moody
despite the lack of evidence despite an
11 month investigation of moody
wherein they procured no evidence at all
in fact they found contrary evidence his
dna did not match
there were no fingerprints
there were no witnesses
there was absolutely no forensic
evidence
even his wife who louis free turned
against
roy moody had no
information to indict moody even though
she was supposedly his partner in these
bombings
uh
they found no
uh bomb materials in moody's residence
even though they searched it i don't
know 20 times they even searched a
cistern
what they did do is uh
they used louis free
as a prosecutor came up with a special
arrangement to allow
a bomb technician in the fbi lab tom
thurman
to testify
for
the other
lab people at the fbi lab even though
tom thurman is not a scientist um
he's uh not qualified
and
he was he was involved in the law
enforcement end of uh
the moody investigation for example he
led
the searches of moody's residents and so
forth
but
uh louis for free arranged to have tom
thurman testify at moody's trial
and
what moody did i mean i'm sorry what
thurman did he testified
to the effect that a bomb
that was found in moody's possession
17 years before
um
was identical to the bomb
that killed
uh judge robert vance
and that
was the
evidence that convicted roy moody and
for which he's sitting in death row
right now
lewis free the prosecutor
knew that testimony was false
lewis free had two
scientific reports on the bomb
saying that they were not identical at
all these two bombs
were highly dissimilar
and they just were not identical he
allowed that testimony
um
and
and the rest is history
uh so so
again i appeal
to louis free not to sit by
and watch uh roy moody be executed
on the basis
of his wrongful conviction
what happened after
the moody trial
most people
tribute
the elevation of uh
louis free to the directorship of the
fbi in large part because of his
successful conviction of of moody
um
what uh free also did
after he became director is uh
people like tom thurman
who gave false testimony that's put
somebody on death row
promoted tom thurman to
to the head of the explosives unit
tom thurman operated in the explosives
units for many years
and he's a story
again that capsule and captures the
serious problems with the fbi laboratory
for example
tom thurman secretly altered
the lab reports of dr frederick
whitehurst
um
these were
scientific lab reports most of which
thurman did not even understand
but he he altered these reports before
they were given to the prosecution
and of course in each case
he skewed them towards the conviction
and tom
thurman uh
continued like this for
actually i don't know how many years
maybe 15 years
and he worked on approximately a
thousand cases and he was protected by
uh and promoted and
awarded and so forth for many years
uh particularly under uh director free
in this situation has not changed at the
fbi laboratory despite
the investigation last year by the
inspector general
uh specifically
in the explosives unit when tom thurman
worked he of course has
he was
pretty much discredited by the inspector
general's report last year
and was eventually phased out
i mean personally i think he should have
been arrested and prosecuted
but of course you know that doesn't
happen at the fbi
he was allowed to retire
and
but the inspector general did strongly
recommend that they revamp the explosive
unit
and bring in qualified scientists
that was a year ago more than a year ago
and of course
director free at the time
said that of course we agree with these
recommendations
and we will move quickly to bring in
qualified scientists
okay the inspector general did a
follow-up about a month ago you know
what happened to the recommendations
they
they discovered that tom jordan the new
head of the explosive unit
hired consciously hired
only special agents in the in the
explosives unit
no qualified scientist
and they asked him well why did you do
this you know
and he said
because he wanted his examiners to be
able to execute
search warrants and forcibly enter homes
and buildings to carry out these search
warrants and to you know capture
suspects
i mean this
is his understanding of a lab scientist
and this is what uh the same thing that
thurman did for years so my point is
that
things have not changed at the fbi lab
this
they're basically sticking their thumb
at the inspector general's
recommendations
and then they asked well they asked the
new the new head of the laboratory uh
richard kerr
you know what is this you know
we gave you the recommendation to hire
qualified scientists
you have money allotted for that it
actually costs less to employ
a scientist
than a special agent
and the new much belly-hood uh head of
the lab said he didn't know what was
going on you know
right under his nose for a year and a
year and a half almost
um
so that's
that's where
that's where it was a year ago at the
fbi laboratory that's where it is today
a second major recommendation of the
inspector general was to bring
contamination under control
especially in the explosives unit
again
in the follow-up recently the inspector
general asked tom jordan
the head of the explosives unit
you know
what has happened with contamination
he said that
oh i think the
chemistry unit has been monitoring
contamination and doing testing testing
of course he didn't know whether they
had or not and obviously hadn't checked
any reports
but that's what he said
so the inspector general asked steve
burmeister
the head of the chemistry unit you know
if they had been doing
contamination testing and he said he
didn't know what jordan was talking
about they had done no testing
in more than a year since the ig report
so
again
you know
things things are maybe even worse now
at the laboratory i mean they they don't
even go through the motions there's
there have been no scientists hired in
the uh
explosives unit there's absolutely
uh there's been no contamination which
is a which is a major concern with you
know with examination of explosive
devices
and
that's where it is
then on the other hand uh
steve burmeister who is the new head of
the chemistry unit
at the uh at the at the fbi laboratory
is is another problem
um
he
and this is where i'll try to illustrate
uh my points by going through cases
um
he was the
uh main
expert witness for the fbi at the
timothy mcveigh trial
um
as a scientist
and our investigation showed that there
was absolutely no valid forensic
evidence in the timothy mcveigh case
this is aside from whether or not
timothy mcveigh was guilty or not
the fbi had no forensic evidence at all
yet steve burmeister
testified
that
an ammonium nitrate bomb
blew up
the uh
the murray federal building in oklahoma
city
well how did this happen
and bear in mind now he's testifying as
a scientist
he claimed that they
found ammonium nitrate crystals on a
piece of the truck that blew up across
the street in a parking lot
this
this piece of the truck was sitting in a
torrential rain for 24 hours
ammonium nitrate
is water soluble
the second thing was the heat of the
explosion
under most conditions would have
destroyed would have splinted the
ammonium nitrate
but somehow
steve burmeister and the fbi were able
to procure
ammonium nitrate crystals no less
from this piece of the truck
okay
well they asked
burmeister
understand how did the ammonium nitrate
crystals get on the piece of truck
again keep in mind he's saying this as a
scientist he said that the piece of the
panel truck blew away
at the rate of 5000 feet per second
and the ammonium nitrate crystals which
were of course behind it
caught up with this piece of truck in
mid-air
and embedded themselves in the panel
okay you know
he granted that that was kind of
phantasmagorical but
you know
he's the expert he's the scientist
all right fine
um
but the real clincher came when
the defense experts
asked to examine the ammonium nitrate
crystals
well shucks steve burmeister a scientist
didn't preserve him
you know
god damn you know
and they said well
what did you have to do to preserve them
he said well
i just had to put them in a plastic bag
put a discipline in there and seal it
you know one of these sandwich bags and
it would have been preserved
indefinitely
but what the scary part of that is
um
aside from the fact that it you know
it's probably going to send mcveigh to
the chair
is that he under the law
he is not he was not required to
preserve that evidence
i mean that's that should be changed
yesterday you know
and he he hid behind that too he said
you know i'm not again bear in mind he's
supposed to be a scientist i'm not in
the habit of preserving evidence in
cases
you know it's like well great steve
that's that's really assuring
so that's steve burmeister and i would
also like to appeal to his integrity and
his conscience to come clean
on you know the timothy mcveigh
situation
i mean
when you've been into this i guess as
much as i have i mean you just think you
think
well there's this place about 16 blocks
away
you know
and it's it's just so bizarre and
frightening you know and you know i mean
i mean
this guy this guy burmeister
i mean and this is the this isn't the
only case where he's been
engaged in this type of behavior
uh
you know and then i find out the other
day he's been he's been given a big
award you know and he keeps going up and
he was made permanent chief of the
chemistry unit
and and it's just down the street you
know and it's going on and it's just uh
i don't know
it's just amazing
you know i suppose it's a bit fetched
but i feel like people were sitting in
germany in 1938
and were aware of you know this the
stuff that was going on and like
you know how come nobody's doing
anything about it you know
um yeah fred go ahead sure jump right in
anytime it's a pretty shocking charge
you're basically accusing the director
of the fbi of murdering innocent people
what i'm trying to figure out is
in the old days when j edgar cooper was
accused of that his motive was
uh political and he was trying to you
know take out the panthers or attack the
left and he was willing to stop with
nothing to do so
in this case
what are these people's do you have any
insights into their motives is it pure
careerism are they just trying to get
ahead they're willing to murder people
to do it or what what is exactly is
their motivation yeah um
my sense from looking at it for two
years now it's largely career careerism
and it's also careerism after they leave
the fbi
um
the fbi people if we come now like like
like cia people
in terms of they're after employment
they really get these incredibly high
paying jobs you know so for example
um
um
you know
you know if if you're
seeing like tom thurman okay he was seen
and he was on national television as the
person who solved the pan am 103 bombing
you know
of course he didn't and it was all false
and so forth but he was made person of
the week on abc
so that that's just a tremendous calling
card for employment afterwards so a lot
of it is careerism and in the question
of free
you know at the time he was a prosecutor
and literally it's just not me but it's
been published many places that that
he was nominated to be fbi director
because of his conviction of this guy
roy moody his successful conviction
so
you know
it's just uh
and then then i think they just get
caught up in it you know this this this
uh convicting and convicting and
convicted you know and uh
but
what's interesting too is like
you know i i interviewed uh
dr edward blake
he's probably one of the world's leading
dna specialists
and he's worked both for the prosecution
and in the defense you know it's not
like he's
anti-fbi
but he told me
and he was referring to the lab
he said in his opinion the lab the
present time
is a gestapo
you know
we're not we're not talking about you
know the fbi undercover people who go
around and
beat up people and so forth
he's talking about the lab
you know he says because
they're they have imposed a monolithic
perspective on how to
uh do forensic examinations
and it's resulting in you know
thousands of wrongful convictions you
know
and so
but again
you know it's just so weird being right
here 16 blocks away from this and um
but i'm going astray here so let me let
me get back to
more directly on the lab
okay so the the same thing
was found okay so
essentially our conclusion
of our investigations of the
the conviction of timothy mcveigh was
that there was there was no
forensic evidence in that case
uh
we uncovered two that the same was true
with the world trade center case
there was absolutely no forensic
evidence in that case
yet
the fbi
and the person of david williams
testified falsely
that an ammonium nitrate bomb blew up
the world trade center
six or seven people were convicted and
given 240
years of peace
subsequently it was documented
that
uh david williams who was also from the
explosives unit
testified falsely this wasn't
just our assertion was documented by the
inspector general general
and yet
these uh defendants have been not have
not been granted a new trial
and my guess is they won't be
they won't even be given a new trial
despite the fact
that it's been documented that the fbi
falsified
testified falsely
um
similarly with the with the unabomber
case
um
in that situation um
we uncovered
as did the inspector general that the
fbi in particular an agent
named terry rudolph
lab agent
for i don't know how long 10 years at
least
failed to
examine the evidence properly or
adequately
so the suggestion there is that
um
they may have stopped the unembalmer a
lot sooner
if they had done proper examinations
but of course they didn't
and of course they they
you know chances are more than
likely that the unobama would still be
out there if his brother hadn't turned
them in
so they they totally
uh botched the
investigation
the forensic
investigation of the the unabomber
topping that off
was the fact that after ted kaczynski
was arrested
they totally botched the dna analysis
i mean this is supposed to be their like
top scientific unit
okay
and
and i discovered like
they didn't even carry out you know
general science high school
elementary course you know uh procedures
first of all
uh
and this was done by the head of the
unit a woman called dr jennifer smith
okay
she's the head of the dna unit at the
fbi and she was in charge of
the dna analysis of ted kaczynski
number one
i mean i just didn't believe this at
first and i called around i called the
defense attorneys she did not
procure a sample of ted kozinski's dna
all she had to do
was you know
she didn't have to do it as hell but
have somebody swab the inside of his
mouth
and that was it
you know i called the defense attorney
uh bob blazier
and he said they never even asked you
know i mean because nancy could have
refused
but they they could have quickly got a
court order saying hey you know
open your mouth and it would have been
done okay so again uh she's supposed to
be a scientist you know
so what
what she did do was um
they examined for dna letters that
unobama had sent
to
his victims and to other places
and they took samples from the envelope
and the idea being that the dna on that
the dna profile would be the unibombers
well you know it sounds kind of logical
but they found three or four different
profiles
so they arbitrarily picked one
and said this is the this is the
unabombers okay
all right
okay so concede to them
okay maybe okay so you got the unobama's
profile okay then they took
letters that
the envelopes of letters that kaczynski
had sent to his brother david okay
and they tested those for dna
on the assumption that the dna on those
envelopes would be ted kaczynski's
dna
again that sounds logical
again they found three or four dna
profiles
you know the obvious reason being that
you know the post person's profile can
be on there from sweat from his hands
on and on and on
okay
so they have you know three or four dna
profiles
potentially for the unabomber three or
four
for ted kaczynski
so how do they determine whether or not
there's a match between ted kaczynski's
dna and the unibombers
they arbitrarily pick one
from the letters he sent to his brother
and say this is his
they arbitrarily pick
one which happened to match that one
from the unabomber letters letters
and they and they go to court and say
there's a match
there's a match
between the unabomber suspect and ted
gazinski
and
and then they lie
they lie in the affidavit that's
required for a search warrant they lied
and i challenged them to you know do
whatever they want to me
it's right there in black and white they
said that
there were two tests two dna tests done
and they both confirmed a match between
ted kaczynski's
dna
and
the unabombers
in fact they did only one test
and jennifer smith
knew this
and she reviewed the affidavit jennifer
smith the head of the dna analysis unit
and she never corrected it and she never
informed the court
so on the basis
of a
uh
i don't how to describe it but
illegitimate
affidavit the fbi
got the right to search kaczynski's
cabin
you know and that that
you know that that was the end of him
but still it's important
that they lied
in in that affidavit
and it's like the head of the dna unit
and this is supposed to be the the best
scientific
dna unit that they have a unit that they
have at the lab and in fact
the inspector general's
report held up the dna unit as a model
for the rest of the lab to follow
well we discovered that
that was curious too
because
on paper and in their report the
inspector general did not investigate
the dna unit
of the fbi lab
well we discovered long after the fact
that
their investigators had investigated the
dna unit
and found it terribly deficient
and so
the inspector general's report just
covered up their own investigation of
the dna unit
and what we found
and
we'll end at this point
what we found was that
for example there were three
three scientists
three actual legitimate scientists in
the dna unit
including
greg parsons and martin l levy
who refused to testify for the fbi on
dna testimony
you know these are their own people in
the dna unit
because they considered the fbi's
techniques invalid and unreliable
and in fact two of them maybe three of
them but two of them
finally got so fed up
dr greg parsons and dr martin levy
that they they left the lab went back to
the street as agents with a cut and pay
in a demotion
i mean they felt it was so bad at the
dna the dna unit
um
and now we'll we'll end here
recently the fbi dna unit came up with
two new policies
one is the identification policy
this is where under certain conditions
arbitrary conditions decided by them
they will go to court and say
this is your dna
this is your semen or your blood no
statistics no
no longer will they say well you know
there's there's one in a million chance
that it's somebody else's
it's yours
okay
i mean
as soon as they come out with that
policy i surveyed
all the top dna specialists in the in
the country
and they were horrified you know
first of all there was no validation
study done before they introduced the
next the the new technique zip nothing
and there's no scientific basis for it
at all
i mean this is what i'm told
by you know
legitimate dna specialists
um the one thing that the fbi did
announce when they announced this new
policies they said that dr bruce bedoli
who was the originator of this new
identification policy he would be
publishing a study
in a journal in a scientific journal
that would
validate this procedure
of course that isn't the way science
works you're supposed to validate it
first before you apply it but okay at
least there can at least they're doing
something okay
okay that was in november of last year
uh 97.
okay i called up this journal about a
month ago in may
you know saying you know had you
published dr budoli's article
well gosh they hadn't even received
anything they didn't know what i was
talking about you know
so so they lied
and this is in a published you know
uh statement from the fbi and it's about
a very serious matter i mean this guy
bruce berdoli who's head of
dna research
at the fbi laboratory is making policy
that's affecting
the lives of thousands of people in this
country i mean they i don't know how
many
dna exams they do a year but it's in
it's in this
i don't know tens of thousands
okay so that's
that's one of their latest policies
again it's no validation at all in
science and they could kill us
and they've convicted people using this
this policy
the second one and we'll end here is
they're now using what's called
mitochondrial dna analysis
the same situation
um
there's been no
well there's been a little
uh inadequate attempt at validating this
technique but it wasn't it didn't
doesn't qualify as a validation there's
been no validation of this technique
there are a lot of problems with using
mitochondrial dna
specifically
mitochondrial dna within the same person
the profile can differ okay
that's one serious problem
uh mitochondrial dna just comes from
your mother's side
so
everybody on your mother's side back
through i don't know how many
generations will have the same profile
you know
a another problem was a recent study in
britain showed that
uh
four out of 100 people tested
unrelated had the exact same
mitochondrial dna profile
so how can you possibly use
mitochondrial dna
to identify somebody as the source of
dna evidence at a crime scene
you know
so
we'll we'll end there
and
and take questions
sure go ahead john
yeah um
those of us that have watched the cia
over the years and know a little bit
about the history of the cia uh we are
not really surprised
with your research i mean we can go back
to pretty boy floyd back in the 30s
leonard peltier in the 1970s it would be
an example of of exactly the kind of
tainted evidence you're talking about
here and and i guess my
my my question would be well one of two
questions is one is what's new is there
anything new here uh the the question of
incompetence that you talked about
before i think that's that's pretty
interesting uh and then the other
question john is uh
referring to your daughter's comment
about the fbi following you home and so
on we all know the fbi is very very good
at pr work uh when whitehurst came
public they trashed him other people
that have come out public against the
fbi there's a long history of the fbi
going going public getting op-ed pieces
and so on and so forth um
how is
how is the uh media receiving this book
and have you seen any efforts on the
part of the fbi to try to discredit your
work
i'll start with the second question
um
it's fascinating to me that
out there in the countryside i've been
on uh invited on to at least 40 radio
shows and this is there's a tremendous
positive reception
you know
uh
here in town
it's a different story of course
and i i think for now i i should point
out that the fbi hasn't challenged
anything that we've written i think that
says a lot
you know anybody over the age of 10
would realize if they if they found one
little thing in there you know
i mean uh certain papers would have it
on the front page tomorrow you know
um
i i think the tactic right now is to to
to greet it with silence you know
um
you know hope that
you know the blow over which which is a
long tradition in this this town
um
but but i would say to them you know i'm
of irish background you know and
the the british used to say what they
thought was an insult that the problem
with the irish is they don't know when
they've lost you know
so i i would leave that with them
um
but in terms
we got to your first question
i think what's new is is that it's
become it's become
the problem has become
really deeply institutionalized
i mean as i mentioned a year ago
because of the courage of dr frederick
whitehurst
and i should point out
which is which you know just came upon
me one day months later he's the first
whistleblower the fbi's ever had
the first
i don't know how how old they are i
don't know 80 70 years
he'll probably be the last
but uh i mean there have been people who
left the fbi and criticized it but
nevertheless they had a whistleblower
and the second thing was
there's never been
a television program
in this country critical of the fbi
never
i worked on one
that
came close but at the end of the day
uh for whatever reasons it didn't work
out i mean it aired but it was i my
opinion was a whitewash
even there okay
you know
buck revell
of the fbi at the time he you know did
everything possible to prevent he and
his
agents did everything possible to
prevent that show from appearing
and
on the day of the program the program
was scheduled the fbi called weta and
said don't put that on
wa eta considered not putting it on
and what they did do
is the other thing the fbi said to weta
was listen don't put a plug on for the
producer's book the producer of the
program wrote a book you know with the
series
weta did not put the plug on for the
book
so
in terms of what's new it's like i think
they've actually escalated
they've escalated in the lab in terms of
you know
making matters worse
they refuse for example the lab refuses
to submit to you know external blind
what they call proficiency testing
you know
it's absurd that a laboratory any
laboratory can you know exist without
external testing
it's required by law
of all other types of clinical labs
you know
congress
congress 1994 congress put the fbi in
charge of dna analysis in this country
the fbi
i mean that's absurd
and at the same time they won't submit
to external proficiency testing or any
monitoring or anybody having any input
into the dna analysis and then i just
gave the example the unabomber
i mean i could go on and on about the
you know
incompetence and the in the conscious
manipulation of dna evidence by the fbi
laboratory
so
um
so so things that things are i think
actually worse and
you know i think it's sort of capsulated
with
uh
vis-a-vis hoover
well within the within the bureau
amongst certain parts you know free is
known as hoover with kids okay
um
so that that's that's what that's where
that's where it is right now and
and actually free testified about a year
ago he said look
to itself
the the fbi is the most dangerous
these are his words the most dangerous
agency in the u.s government
well they've been left to themselves and
his words are
true
um
and we found
that
you know
uh
that the lab is just running rampant
they're just totally uh well they're not
out of control they're controlled by
people who want to convict
at any cost
regardless of the truth with no
uh they don't want scientists you know
like i just told you in the explosives
unit they spent a year consciously not
hiring scientists
yeah
i'm kind of
innocent of all these speak up i'm i'm
sort of oblivious to what's happening
here but it seems to me that
if the dna evidence is so vital
then what about the attorneys for the
people who are convicted of these crimes
why didn't they speak out more
forcefully and demand a recount of the
decision of the juries and so forth in
this and take it to the supreme court if
necessary to feel
all these appeals they could have made
and put pressure on you sure on cnn on
the on c-span on all the television
networks and get the publicity that that
the uh tom brokaw and all these guys get
to
to
taint the public's opinion to get their
opinion or whatever right well first of
all essentially nobody knows knows about
it
even very often the defense attorneys
uh for example uh they don't know that
the fbi is getting away with this
uh many cases no
um they're not very competent attorneys
are they well that is a criticism of
them
i agree
um
and hopefully what i'm trying to do is
you know i i've been working with
attorneys and attorneys groups and
there's a very good one the national
association of criminal defense lawyers
and
they've been working to uh
deal with these matters and they they've
pursued for example the laboratory
they've been
in fact dan alcorn's here today maybe he
he can say a few words they've been
um obtaining documents from the
laboratory through the freedom
information act
and trying to
inform the public and form other lawyers
and i'll let dan say a word in a second
if he wants um
the other problem though is that
i don't know what the latest estimate is
but something like 80 of defendants in
this country cannot afford a defense
expert
okay
and
i mean
and it's becoming vital these days to
have a defense expert because so much of
the prosecution is
dependent on forensic science
and
um
very often you know the lawyers that
these people have is some public
defender who's overworked you know
really has um
no
interest in the defendant or is just
exhausted
or is incompetent
and
they they they
they cop a plea
and the the other thing that does go on
though from the forensic side is that
um
prosecutors will go to a defense lawyer
and say look
his dna matches when it doesn't okay
they will lie
so they have some
person who's totally totally penniless
you're just overwhelmed by the situation
doesn't know what's going on
faces maybe death maybe life
you know
i don't know how many times they'll say
well okay we'll plead guilty and get 10
years you know
in the story you know the defense
attorney's you know he won't have to do
any work so
um
that's that's that's the reality out
there
it's very
potent when it comes to knowing the
guilt or innocence of a person but they
used to do
put a lot of stop and polygraph test but
it's been proven to be a fallacy hasn't
it more or less absolutely yeah it's not
a lot in court anymore well i'll tell
you
it's not publicized but dna has a lot of
problems actually and eventually it will
come out
but unfortunately it's going to be after
i don't know how many thousands of
people are wrongfully convicted you know
there's a lot of problems j simpson
trial wasn't the dna they're accused of
being tampered with absolutely by the
policeman absolutely in in my estimation
it was
they planted blood etc etc
what they what was interesting in the
in the uh oj case was that the
prosecutor
chose not to use the fbi lab to do the
dna analysis
because they knew
they weren't competent you know the
public didn't
but what they did do was they sent
blood
to uh the fbi laboratory
okay
to test for
preservative
edta
the reason for that was
if they found preservative in the blood
that would strongly suggest that the
blood had been planted
okay
okay so the blood went to roger motz
at the chemistry and toxicology unit
first of all mars wasn't qualified to do
any analysis of the blood
but he did it
and he claimed in court
that he on the spot developed on the
spot developed a technique
there was no
no known technique at the time for for
detecting edta for some reason
he claimed he created a technique on the
spot okay
that's not the way science works you
know
didn't they also say that the blood in
the o.j simpson trial had been exposed
to and been refrigerated and been
properly cared for absolutely the whole
the whole nine yards
but anyway so so so
rajamats
uh created this neck
new technique and analyzed the blood and
testified right
in the morning he testified that
he did find edta
the afternoon he changed his testimony
you know
so so they asked him the obvious you
know
uh
you know what happened he said
well i felt i wasn't telling the whole
truth in the morning with yes and no
but now i want to tell the whole truth
you know
so i mean this is a
this is a scientist
at the fbi lab who has tremendous power
over people's lives i mean roger motz
uh he was involved in the first case
that i mentioned raja moody
roy moody i'm sorry
he was involved in uh you know invalid
you know examinations in the moody case
and moody's on death row but roger mats
has worked
i don't know maybe a thousand cases in
his career
you know
i mean
and again this is in my opinion this is
the opinion of dr frederick whitehurst
who was working in the same lab with
roger motz he said you know he he put
his name on paper saying this man is
incompetent and he's denied
justice to how many he doesn't know how
many people you know
i mean roy moody did not get a fair
trial as as guaranteed by the
constitution
and this is the this is the
opinion not just of our investigation
but of dr whitehurst and other
scientists at the fbi lab
dan did you want to say something about
i did the question is a very good
question because i think it's what most
people would assume which is that the
adversary system of justice would have
brought the scandal out a long time ago
but that has not happened because in the
criminal justice field
most of the defendants have no money no
resources and what's happened over the
years is the judges have come to rely
entirely on the fbi laboratory for the
testing and the judges in most cases do
not authorize funds to get an
independent test done for a defendant
and what's happened in the system is
that the fbi laboratory or a state
government laboratory has become the one
that's relied on to give objective
results and that the system is operated
that way for some time without
authorization for funds to do
independent testing so you never had
really an independent test unless the
defendant had a lot of resources that
they could bring to bear and get their
own defense
part of what happened here is that
in the o.j simpson trial because o.j
simpson had the resources to put on an
elaborate defense actually this issue
became
public and came to public attention and
dr whitehurst who had been blowing the
whistle in the fbi for some time without
public attention to it it became known
to the public because it became an issue
of the o.j simpson trial and then went
on out it became a governmental issue so
you're very right to make the point that
the system the way it operates is not
getting these
kind of problems out to public view and
you really need to
have pressure brought to bear
governmentally here in washington
to try to get this solved and get the
fbi operating as an institution that's
putting out good results and not these
results that aren't accurate
i i would like to say too on the
positive side
there are two very significant
things that have happened that exist in
this town um
after dr whitehurst left the fbi he
formed the forensic justice project
and
what he's doing he and others
are
they're taking cases
largely i think people have already
already been convicted
and they're reviewing the lab documents
and analyzing them
and
if it shows that you know improper work
was done they're they're providing this
to the justice department
uh more or less demanding that the case
be reopened
and if the justice department doesn't
responded
if i get it straight they're going to
provide this information
to uh the defense lawyers
or the defendants if need be
um
so i would
highly recommend that people become
aware of the forensic justice project
and related to it is the national
whistleblowers center
and david calipinto is here and i'd like
to him to tell us about the center and
ways people can get involved you know
so david's down in the back there
thanks john sure
i didn't mean to put you on the spot
that's all right uh i think with john
uncovered in his book in terms of the
national scandal
uh he and phillip
uh really
demonstrates the need for our country to
encourage people to come forward like dr
whitehurst who i had the privilege of
representing
and
he
and other employees of the fbi really
were responsible for reporting some of
the misconduct
that was documented brilliantly i think
in uh tainting evidence
and uh
however there aren't
laws in place
to protect people to come forward in the
fbi even though congress passed a law in
1989
to give whistleblower protection for fbi
employees the justice department has yet
to implement that law
and they were ordered attorney general
reno was ordered by president clinton in
april of 1997
over a year ago to implement that law
for fbi employees and to date it has not
been implemented so if we're going to
have some sort of effective public
outside oversight of what the fbi is
doing not just in the laboratory but in
other parts of the fbi the other law
enforcement functions that it carries
out
we have to be able to support the
employees to report the misconduct when
it occurs otherwise we'll never know
about it and i think that this scandal
demonstrates that the fbi succeeded for
almost 25 years
in
covering this up and keeping it from the
american people
and uh what
dr whitehurst is doing now through the
forensic justice project is he's
committed to requesting under the
freedom of information act
files from
the cases that people have actually
worked on in the lab
and to go over those cases case by case
with other scientists to determine
whether or not other people have been
that we don't know about yet have been
hurt by this forensic fraud that's been
taking place
unfortunately the justice department
refuse
refuses to expend the resources to
conduct this review
so it's left to people like fred
whitehurst and other scientists who are
willing to do it on their own
and
if people are interested in
either the whistleblower center or the
forensic justice project i'd invite them
to
visit us at
the internet www.whistleblowers.org
or www.forensicjustice.org
thank
you thank you dude
um
i would like to also give my email
address
um
because uh
we
myself and philip are continuing
continuing to pursue this
so it's k john 39679
at aol.com
and one of the actions that we've
undertaken as individuals
we've actually uh
i guess applied is the right word to the
justice department for the prosecution
of stephen burmeister for perjury in the
uh the trial of uh
timothy mcveigh
and um
like it or not that they're carrying out
an investigation
and um
i think if uh
if justice is done he will be prosecuted
and i think
the part of the intent of that is to is
to motivate other people
that you know
like i said at the beginning the fbi is
right there you know 16 blocks away it's
it's no big big deal
yeah john
um
in your research john have you found any
analogous situation at the state level
forensic science is not regulated which
is outrageous
you know
a truck driver's test is more
demanding
than than than that of a forensic expert
there are no legal requirements
if a judge says it's okay for you to be
a
a dna analyst tomorrow john at a trial
you're on okay
yeah
so that that explains a lot of it and
the fbi
has
uh lobbied and fought against regulation
of the field and i think that speaks for
itself they want to allow
uh
manipulable incompetent people so they
can just get convictions they they don't
want
a legitimate scientist like fred
whitehurst i mean that's that's a key
thing to keep in mind about dr
whitehurst
i mean he wasn't just whistling
whistleblowing i mean he was doing his
work at the same time in fact he was
receiving incredibly high praise from
the fbi
but very often what his work consisted
of
was he would analyze say a bomb
and say well
there are three possibilities
they didn't want to hear that i mean as
a scientist he felt compelled to say
does x y and z possible reasons they
didn't want to hear that they wanted to
hear the one
that indicated that joe brown was the
obama okay
um
but that goes on in the fbi lab but all
through forensic science because there's
no regulation
there's uh
there's no real monitoring of the field
uh they have what's called the
ask lad american society of crime lab
directors
they were founded by the fbi basically
okay
but but listen to this the fbi has never
bothered to get accredited by this group
so i asked you know i asked i
interviewed john hicks who was the
uh former head of the fbi lab until
recently
i said you know
you know you
you're allowed the fbi the up tells
other labs to get accredited okay
but you don't get a credit to yourself
and basically it'd be a shoe-in because
you created this group you know
he said well
you know we did an internal
investigation of the lab
and we concluded that we met all the all
the you know the standards of the
accreditation agency
so what's the need you know
and and plus it's expensive you know the
fbi is expensive right all the money
they have it's expensive to get
accredited
okay
you know maybe
but upon looking into it he lied to me
their internal investigation
said they would not
receive accreditation
james mudd the quality control director
you know said
no way in hell would they they qualify
you know
and i obtained the report
saying that they would not be receive
accreditation and he lied to me you know
and uh
but equally important is the justice
department received that report saying
that they would not be
accredited if they were subjected to
review
the justice department took no action
including not publicizing that fact
and bear in mind all the time now they
they're churning out cases
night and day you know
i don't know they do like a 160 000
cases a year you know and they're
intervening they're going into little
courthouses
in montana you know they they're out
there like you know reaping in business
you know
they're just totally incompetent and
consciously
manipulating and on and on and on
mr kelly i recently read that louis free
may be resigning from this position this
august as director and if that occurs
what changes do you foresee or what do
you expect from the future of the fbi
um
i would see none
and um
you know my feeling is like like
louis free has been looking for a quiet
time to to to
to resign
um
because i i think
in fact what should happen was
and this is very often how it works in
washington these people resign you know
nixon resigns and so forth i mean they
should be prosecuted you know they
shouldn't be allowed to just resign they
should be prosecuted lewis free should
be prosecuted for what he did in the
case of roy moody
and god knows where else you know
but
again i i
um
it's it's just the history of the fbi
lab when people resign
for example they have a new
head of the laboratory you know he's
always been there about a year i guess
you know big fanfare when he's
appointed um
he's he's actually a scientist okay
which was i think a first for the fbi
lab to have a scientist head the lab
so people you know you naturally think
well okay things are gonna pick up you
know
but wait a minute you look a little
closer first of all
free in the fbi promise they would
appoint a forensic scientist
this guy was a bomb maker
you know from los alamos nuclear bombs
you know that's you know
okay so they don't give a forensic
scientist all right you know always with
the fbi you gotta go oh okay at least
they did something they put a scientist
under him for a year
things have gotten worse
you know one of the first thing they
said you know breastfeeding oh gosh you
know we're going to hire qualified
scientists
and at the time they had a lot of
openings because they got rid of some of
well they allowed to resign some of the
really bad guys you know so they had
openings you know
like i said earlier
it's cheaper for them it's 25 percent
cheaper or more
to employ
a professional scientist than
than a special agent
because special agents get higher
salaries
and bonuses and all this stuff
for a year
they hired
in the explosives unit only special
agents
and and so this was under the new
you know wonderful scientific head of
the lab you know
and during that year they also did not
start the accreditation investigation
free promise back in 1993
that oh [ __ ] you know
oh gosh
you know i didn't know that lab wasn't
accredited
we're going to get that done right away
you know
i keep forgetting what year this is but
it's it seems like it's been quite a
while since free promised that
and and for most of the tenure the new
fbi lab director he didn't even do that
he didn't even start the accreditation
process you know
a couple of let me just mention two
other points
a couple of other amazing
recommendations of the inspector general
a year ago was that
in essence lab reports should be
truthful
you know i think that says a lot that
they had to recommend that right first
of all you know
but they said and not only does it have
be truthful the lab report should be
truthful but the fbi should put that in
writing that you know examiners have to
write truthful reports okay
you know no guarantee that they'd do it
but the fbi should at least put it in
writing
a year later
it's not in writing
so the ig says what happened
you know we're taking you what 10
seconds to put that in writing
or we'll you know in the new version of
the protocol we'll put that in there you
know
again this is under the new
scientific head of the lab
a second thing they said was
and i think this is telling was that
fbi
testimony should be
monitored and reviewed maybe once a year
okay once a year
okay
um
preferably more often
but why should they be monitored because
because you know the ig had found that
they lied okay
they lied on the stand okay a year later
new lab director
did you monitor any testimonies oh no
no we decided not to
oh what's the problem oh it's really
hard to get transcripts
you know
i mean literally this is in writing in
in the in the ig's updated report this
is inviting it's really difficult for
the fbi to get transcripts of their
agents testimonies i mean i mean you can
walk into a court downtown and get them
you know
um
so
uh
and the other
funny one was uh
the uh no i'll get back to it
i think you should yeah i think she'd
bring this subject up
his common knowledge of j edgar hoover
uh just like martin luther king so much
he won him dead right i mean that's
that's my interpretation of the attitude
edgar hoover had j edgar hoover head
toward martin luther king and the man
who was found guilty of having murdered
martin luther king
they didn't give them a fair trial did
they did they ever get a confession out
of him did they ever
did they do
dna testing did they do anything at all
to prove that he was actually and then
his son martin luther king's son said
just before the fellow died
of natural causes or whatever yeah that
he
believed that he hadn't murdered his
father right well well first off
i can't i can't jump on them for dna
testing they didn't have dna testing at
the time
but uh but what's interesting on that
particular point was that uh
i don't know the answer to the second
party question
uh but
what's interesting on
is the fact that uh you know these
letters that hoover sent around
uh they were created in the lab
so that's that's how he used the lab one
of the examples the nice way he used to
lab you know these letters claiming
king was having affairs or whatever
threatening letters and i think they
sent them one that said he should kill
himself or something like that
all that stuff was created in the lab
and that's how they see the left that's
how the fbi sees the lab as an
instrument to in my opinion carry out
crimes
and i want to emphasize that this is
what we claim in the book we're not
claiming simply screw-ups and
incompetence and mishaps
and and deficiencies we're saying these
crimes these are crimes you know
somebody's denied their constitutional
right to a trial that's a crime somebody
sent
to prison wrongfully that's a crime
somebody
somebody is incompetent in a lab
and his superior knows that and let and
yet lets him function that's a crime you
know it's not a crime that he's
incompetent but if his superior knows it
and he's having an effect on the
constitutional rights of somebody else
that's a crime
you know in my opinion lewis freeze is
guilty of a crime in the case of roy
moody
he knew that that testimony was false
and
so
again i want to emphasize that these are
crimes and i uh
and that
you know they're just
to to me it's just undeniable that there
are thousands of people who are
wrongfully imprisoned in this country
because it's a whistleblower or anything
you think about uh leonard pelter
and uh the movie actor of
robert redford and people like that very
famous people have come out to speak for
leonard felter's innocence and the crime
he was accused and yeah he's still in
prison yeah well um again uh interesting
on leonard uh again it was the lab i i
can't remember the exact details but
there was a ballistics test that were
that were
yeah yeah and then they admitted it and
also the affidavit that they used to get
him out of canada they later admitted
was totally absolutely fabricated right
and that was those were the two main
ones but there were others as well but i
would say otherwise in response to your
to your question is that there are two
people in congress
that people should contact uh senator
chuck grassley
from iowa
and representative robert wexler
and it really doesn't take much because
they get 10 calls 10 letters
robert wechsler w-e-x-l-e-r
you know my experience is they get 10
calls or 10 letters they think there's a
mass movement out there you know
and
and also
no it gives them it gives them for in
particular grassley grassley's been very
good on the fbi and stayed on the case
but if he gets the smallest
additional you know response and from
from uh
people out there in the countryside or
here
um
you know he's encouraged he moves you
know
but if nobody calls nothing um
but but also
you know people can do things like i did
i mean you can just call up the fbi you
know and i won't have pen star
investigating me
well if they do call me and i'll
publicize your case you know
that's great but but people do have to
take action you know otherwise they just
keep rolling they just
that's just been the history like
again last year they did this this big
expose of the fbi lab you know
and the usual breast beating and we're
going to clean that up right away have
you had any midnight calls from people
threatening you for this
no
no i haven't um
i had a few nasty phone calls on radio
shows but that's that's about it you
know
i i think the
tactic again right now at least is to
greet me with silence you know
but i'll tell you you know it's not like
i'm not without concern particularly
since i'm a father you know
i mean that thought frightens me you
know
um and i and i saw what they did to dr
whitehurst they all but destroyed him
and his family
um
and
that's a
situation that comes back to dr blake's
assessment of uh
the fbi that in his opinion is it's
acting as a gestapo
and
the freedom of information act doesn't
always prove to be beneficial
no no and then that
in particular what the fbi did
they by and large uh
don't cooperate with the freedom of
information act
period they just
be the lie and say they don't have
anything or they they send you you know
totally deleted pages
and um
so
you know
you know
in the case in the question hand two
things have to happen at least two
things one is congress has got to take
action
uh
the white house has to take action i
mean you know it's not like clinton
isn't aware of all this stuff i mean i
send him stuff you know i sent him my
book you know
uh
you know um
the other thing
though in this question here is is the
uh forensic science community has to
you know
stand up to these people you know
um
and so far they by and large they
haven't there are good people out there
and they've taken on the fbi as
scientists
but what has happened is they got the
usual response from the fbi lab and the
lawyers at the fbi in other words
for example
the dna expert in the
unobama case
when it became known that he was going
to
go to work as a defense expert
the fbi
uh opened a full you know background
investigation of this person simply
because he was going to be a defense
expert okay
they went back to his college records he
had been arrested for a prank in college
and actually been acquitted
and they sealed the file you know court
case because there was no conviction and
you know
so forth the fbi went back and got that
opened
and subsequently there was a vicious
rumor about this person totally false
and um
and you know the guy the guy the
scientist was just shattered you know he
essentially
said you know
god you know i'm not going to get
involved in
you know forensic testimony anymore and
you know the guy is still a nervous
wreck you know and he's
um
but that's what they do rather than
have a scientific dialogue you know
they go after the scientific defense
experts
and
with the dna situation they have they
had this orwellian group called dna
legal assistance unit
and what that was was a hit team
they
compiled files on dna experts you know
it's called legal assistance right how
do they assist
they compile files on
dna experts
real dna experts real scientists
john sylvester
who's now in charge of civil rights at
the fbi he was the former head of the
dna legal assistance unit
like my daughter pointed out he used to
follow
dna
defense experts around the country
literally
he'd show up in court
you know taking notes sitting with the
prosecutor coaching the prosecutor
you know all around the country
um
and uh
so that's their scientific response to
legitimate scientists you know
rather than say okay you know we kind of
made a mistake that's the way science
works let's get together and work it out
no they open a file on you
they they track you they discredit you
the character assassinate you this has
come from the lab you know this is in
the
you know the thugs who work in the
undercover operations you know
judgment like mark lane's book about the
kennedy assassination of those well i'd
call it more prejudgment i mean
you know before you get out of the box
they
they've condemned you
so
okay well i want i'd like to thank uh
uh writers for sponsoring us today and
it was uh
really gracious of them and again i want
to give my uh
e out e email address for folks out
there in the country
so it's k john
39679
at aol.com
and thank you all for coming i want to
thank you
[Applause]
disaster relief and operating funding
for bosnia and iraq
now a hearing on the operations of the
fbi's crime lab this is a a room in the
rayburn office building on capitol hill
where the house judiciary subcommittee
gathered today a number of fbi officials
and the justice department's inspector
general reviewed the quality of the
lab's work and fbi admissions that
forensic mistakes were made during some
investigations this is congressman bill
mccullum he chairs the meeting
the secretary of crime will come to
order
today's subcommittee holds the first of
a series of hearings concerning the
federal bureau of investigation
it's the responsibility of congress to
determine whether the law is passed by
the legislative branch are properly and
faithfully executed and that the monies
authorized and appropriated by congress
are being expended as this congress
intended
as the largest federal law enforcement
agency the federal bureau of
investigation is deserving of special
attention in relation to the oversight
duties of the subcommittee on crime
accordingly the subcommittee's hearings
will examine a number of important
issues facing the bureau today
over the last few years troubling
allegations have been raised concerning
the laboratory division of the fbi
these allegations have been raised
principally by dr frederick whitehurst a
supervisory special agent who works in
the fbi lab the numerous allegations
that dr whitehurst raised eventually
resulted in an investigation by the
department of justice's inspector
general
the results of that investigation
released just last month in a 500 page
report
is the subject of today's hearing
for years the fbi has been considered
among the best forensic laboratories in
the world
each year scientific analysis in
connection with thousands of cases is
conducted at the fbi lab both in federal
investigations and in state and criminal
local law enforcement investigations the
result of those analyses often form the
basis of criminal prosecutions
the accuracy of those investigations can
determine the guilt or innocence of an
accused for that reason alone the work
of the lab cannot be too carefully
scrutinized
today we consider whether the findings
of the inspector general which sustain a
significant number of dr whitehurst
allegations and point out other
instances of inappropriate conduct
evidence systemic problems within the
fbi lab which undermine its credibility
as an objective and impartial finder of
scientific fact
we will consider ways in which the fbi
laboratory can be improved and when
those reforms may be implemented and we
will consider dr whitehurst disturbing
allegations that the fbi has retaliated
against him because of the allegations
he has made concerning the lab
the fbi laboratory is an integral part
of the role the fbi plays in our
criminal justice system
congress must ensure that the
investigations in the lab are performed
in an impartial manner that the best
qualified people work there and that the
highest scientific standards are
required of them at all times
i think it is also essential that we
assure that the fbi's personnel when
they testify at trial not only testify
for the best scientific basis but give
the most objective statements they
possibly can to the witness stand
it is again as i've said earlier a
question often of guilt or innocence of
someone when an expert witnesses call
from the fbi lab and the honesty and
integrity of the process of the criminal
justice system is at stake anytime a
witness from this laboratory testifies
this oversight is essential to helping
restore public confidence that our
criminal justice system is fair and just
as
as much as humanly possible it can be i
welcome each of the witnesses here today
and look forward to receiving their
testimony
are there any others who wish to make
opening statements this morning yes mr
chairman mr giekas
i thank the chairman i think that he is
the chairman is embarking on a series of
very important
hearings
so that we can determine not only past
actions or
non-actions on the part of the fbi
particularly with its lab system but
also as a means for
projecting a better future for
the integrity and capacity of the fbi
laboratory and the fbi
in general
in pre-reading some of the testimony and
specifically with respect to dr
whitehurst i'm
confused a little bit and will
pose my questions to try to clear my own
muddiness in this regard
as to
whether or not the case at the world
trade center for instance or the current
cases
are all in jeopardy because of
what dr whitehurst alleged or what the
office of inspector general determined
those are important questions not just
to determine what we can do in the
future but how they have affected
cases that are already completed
and cases that may be
currently in the court system i'm very
worried about all of that and uh
and i'm complimentary of the chairman
for giving us this opportunity to uh
examine these issues more thoroughly i
thank the chairman thank you very much
mr geese mr hutchinson
mr chairman i've expressed my
appreciation to you for holding this
hearing and i've been in the courtroom
when experts from the fbi lab have
presented their testimony and i've seen
on the juries
the respect and
confidence that they have in the
expert testimony from the fbi laboratory
and that's just something that i can
assure you
should never be changed
we have to maintain that confidence that
professionalism and these allegations
are disturbing i'm grateful for the
oig and their report but it is is
critical to the
federal prosecution and the fairness of
our system we have accurate information
coming out of the fbi laboratory and so
for those reasons i'm very grateful for
holding these hearings i look forward to
the testimony
thank you very much mr coble
very briefly mr chairman i too
appreciate your having
seen fit to conduct these hearings and
thank you all for being here
not unlike the gentleman from arkansas i
too have witnessed
juror's response to fbi
agents who testify
that the response is as if
the testimony came from mount olympus
but sometimes when i hear about the
imperfections and the mistakes that have
been forthcoming
something transpired between the trip
from mount olympus to the witness box
and i think in many instances
innocent people mr chairman this may be
revealed today innocent people may well
have
been awarded active prison sentences
based upon
imperfect
testimony or inaccurate testimony
i'm not interested in seeing
any guilty person walk away from the
slamming door behind him but neither do
i want to see an innocent person walk
into that that cell
and i hope that uh we will be
illuminated today mr chairman as we hear
uh testimony and i thank the chairman
thank you very much mr kobel i might add
to my colleagues and for everybody
else's information as i indicate at the
beginning of this this is the first of a
series of oversight hearings on the
federal bureau of investigation
there may be still another one on the
lab but there certainly are going to be
others on such topics as the richard
jewell matter and the file gate question
of the white house and a number of other
of the more controversial concerns we
have because that's our responsibility
as the crime subcommittee
we have a statement from john conyers
who is our ranking minority member on
the full judiciary committee that i
would like to enter into the record he
will be here but is not here at the
moment without objection i'd like to do
so hearing no objection it is so entered
and at this time i will call our first
panel of witnesses today
frederick whitehurst if when i call you
if you can come forward please and
be seated frederick whitehurst is a
supervisory special agent
with a federal bureau of investigation a
15-year veteran of the fbi he has worked
in the fbi laboratory since 1986 he
holds a bachelor's degree in chemistry
from east carolina university a phd in
chemistry from duke university and a law
degree
from georgetown university he is
accompanied today by his attorney
stephen cohn the washington firm of cone
cone and calif pinto did i pronounce
that correctly mr cohn
calipinto
the second member of the panel today is
daniel alcorn he is an attorney with the
firm of finsterwald and alcorn in vienna
virginia among the areas in which he
concentrates his practice is litigation
concerning the freedom of information
act he received his bachelor of laws
degree from
the university of virginia and appears
today
to counsel as counsel to the national
association of criminal defense lawyers
because this is an oversight hearing as
opposed to an ordinary fact-finding
hearing
i'm going to ask that each of the
panelists today be sworn and that is the
normal procedure for oversight hearing
so if you could stand and raise your
right hand i would appreciate it
repeat after me do you solemnly swear
that the testimony you're about to give
today should be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
do you do so
thank you let the
record reflect that all of the witnesses
responded in the affirmative
mr whitehurst you're our first panelist
today and please we have a copy of your
testimony we will enter the full copies
of all written testimony of the record
you may summarize give us whatever
portion that you wish of your statement
and and uh please proceed to do so
mr chairman i understand that i've got
about 15 or 20 minutes you may take yes
you may take that at the appropriate
length i realized you could probably go
on a lot longer than that but if you
could put that in that parameter then it
would help us because we need to lay the
predicate to ask you some questions and
and so on yes uh i would like to thank
first of all thank you for inviting me
here to speak about these issues as a
supervisory special agent of the fbi i
must inform you that the
opinions i give and the statements i
make are mine they're not necessarily
the
the opinions or the statements of the
fbi
i would like to
i would like to thank um
uh
while i'm here also um
congressman conyers for um supporting me
since um i first came forward in about
1993 to get the ig investigation going
and also to thank senator grassley for
his his interest and concern over the
past year
i'd uh like to start out by saying
that
i have read the report
and
i find myself very much in agreement
with most of that report
the report
i recognize was put together with a
great deal of effort
and in my opinion is a courageous
document to put forth
i know that the people that worked on
that report um
mr mr um bromwich's uh
staff
put a lot of effort into it there was a
great deal of personal sacrifice and
soul searching put into that report i
don't necessarily agree with everything
in the report
but that's human
and i think as the days go into months
and into uh
let's hope not years
that we'll come to agreements on those
issues
there are some issues that i raised
as i was supposed to that have not
panned out
there are some issues that i raised that
do not appear from the report to panned
out to have been validated
i think there are
some technical errors and some areas of
judgment there
and then there the most important issues
have
been proven
to be
very real issues that we need to deal
with
i'd like to also express my concern
about how we infer the data
in the report
congressman koble expressed a concern
and congressman hutchinson i believe
expressed a concern about
my laboratory the fbi laboratory losing
its credibility
that report is about
a small group of apples
and a bushel of apples
and before the whole bushel went rotten
we
came forward and said let's fix these
apples
the apples themselves are not
necessarily all rotten they made some
bad mistakes
it's obvious from a report
but i would hope that we number one
don't over infer
or that we don't under infer the
significance of what's in that report
if we over infer
i'm not going to be standing with those
people that choose to do that
the over-inference is that we paint a
broad brush
point at the whole fbi laboratory and
say we can't trust it we're going to be
doing ourselves a disservice under those
circumstances i worked in that
laboratory for 11 years
i've worked with some of the most
professional people
that i've ever had on occasion to work
with
i don't think that
we do ourselves a good service by
distrusting the product that comes out
of the laboratory
but at the same time i don't think what
we should
we should thank you sir
under infer what's going on there
an examiner such as myself in a 10-year
period of time can examine
a thousand cases or 3 000 cases
if i go astray i can affect the lives of
hundreds or thousands of people
if ten like me out of the six hundred
and some people in the lab go astray we
can be speaking about tens of thousands
of people's lives that might be affected
if we
be conservative and realistic we can
talk about hundreds of lives that can be
affected if we look at
the reaction in this country over the
matter involving the bombing in atlanta
and the errors that were made there
and multiply that times 100 or five
hundred we then begin to see that we
can't under infer what's
going on at the fbi laboratory
we can't say well only one guy was doing
it or six guys were doing it and they
only did it five or six times
if i have 500 cases of malfeasance
that have shown up in courts of law
that have affected justice
then we begin to wander into feel that
that i've
been i've heard a lot of people talk
about here here up on the hill and that
is people begin to lose faith in their
government
and i think that's very dangerous
i'm not i'm not going to
and for the data
but i'm not going to
sit back and say well only one or two
american citizens were hurt
and so it's
really not that big a deal
i'd like to give you a succinct summary
of what i've been through in the fbi
laboratory why i'm sitting here today
i
came into the fbi in 1982 and worked in
fbi field offices for four years by
houston sacramento and los angeles as a
criminal investigator
upon my arrival at the fbi laboratory in
1986 i was met in the first week by one
of my colleagues
one of our senior
examiners there and warned about the bad
work
of one of the other fellows working
there and told to stay away from him
he was shortly that fellow who i was
told to stay away from was shortly
thereafter assigned to me as a training
agent i couldn't stay away from him
i wondered why is the senior examiner in
the fbi lab telling me a new kid on the
block about this this is something that
should have gone forward to management i
asked that question it had gone forward
to management
again and again and people were
frustrated because nothing was done
and so i introduced you to chapter one
of the ig report
i personally decided that
people might be being hurt
it was a sloppy work product
there were racist comments
there was it was an appalling thing that
i was looking at
i spent three years in combat with
combat units in vietnam fighting for
fairness and justice and
and all those things that some people
have come to feel are a hokey but i
believe they're the
basis for this country's
uh strength
and i was going to give it up to a
sloppy work product and so i just
decided i'm going to ride this horse all
the way in
and so i went forward and as i went
forward my managers told me yes
the first one told me well we know about
it freddy's our cross to bear he's not
our cross to bear at the fbi he is the
cross to bear of every citizen whose
lives he affects
they told me
um
we know there's a problem come online as
fast as you can and we'll move him out
but they never told me we're gonna find
out who's been hurt and we're going to
stop this work product
and i continued to hear complaints from
my fellow examiners from people in the
laboratory that are just had just given
up
i couldn't give up and i won't give up
that lasted from 1986 to 1992 that was
essentially what was on the docket
how can we allow this to happen how can
we allow a guy
have a an office so sloppy in a trace
analysis laboratory that he's allowed to
put a sign up this is garbage pit on it
that wasn't the fbi laboratory that i
wanted to
be associated with
in 1992
the fbi had heard about this issue for
me again and again and there were a
number of
look-sees at it and a number of casting
it aside well it's not that bad a
problem 1992 my technician came to me
and advised me that she'd carried my
work product to a
another examiner who told her he didn't
really care what i wrote that he'd fix
it
that was absolutely unheard of
as astonished as this nation was by the
ig report that's how astonished we were
as examiners in the laboratory that in
unqualified individuals rewriting my
reports and as it turned out after my
investigation had been going on for five
years without my authorization of
permission
and then things started falling into
place
there was some malfeasance going on
there were people afraid to come forward
and really say something about it a lot
of us were talking about it in the
hallway and that is in violation of
executive order
if we have any indication of misconduct
we're supposed to come forward with it
we're not supposed to decide whether
it's right or wrong we're supposed to
come forward with those indications
i started on a trail through my
management that went from my immediate
supervisor through the director of the
fbi
and at each point where i felt that the
issues were not being
settled
i decided that i was told to go to
appropriate authority and if they
weren't going to settle it at that level
they had deemed themselves inappropriate
and i went to the next level
because the issues just were not settled
it just were not
i found myself in
in the world trade center coming under
pressures
uh seeing some things that were going
wrong there i brought those issues
forward
the prosecution dealt very
professionally with my concerns and the
concerns of my colleagues
and then a number of other cases came
falling out of the woodwork
just because i've come forward with
indications of misconduct does not mean
there's misconduct
and i know that
the inference that i draw is drawn from
the data i have
and it may not be as complete as it
ought to be
it's as complete as i'm allowed it
to be
as an fbi agent and
a guy that works for the president of
the united states who puts out an
executive order that tells me to come
forward with these indications
i think that
i'm very proud to have worked with the
inspector general's office
and i think that they finally listened
and i think that i found the appropriate
authority
and i think we've got a a
a pretty fair analysis again as i said
there's some technical errors
that i perceive to be technic
excuse me technical errors there's also
judgment errors in my opinion
we may end up agreeing to disagree on
some things
but finally the report is there and what
do we do with it
and i have some suggestions
i don't see my suggestions as the only
suggestions
in 1994 i
wrote a paper
for publication called black magic in
the bureau to thrust into the nose of my
supervisors to tell them i am not going
to stop i can't stop it's illogical that
you've told me to do this and now you're
punishing me or suppressing me when i do
this
and i suggested what needed to happen
and most importantly
for me the suggestions were we need
rigid
oversight
in that laboratory
but before the site i want to know who's
been hurt
long time ago i saw a
program in which mr free was being
featured
and they called him the new centurion
and
he brought out those concerns that it
was our job to protect the american
people
we were the centurions
i believe that people could very well
have been hurt
i have indication
that people have been hurt
i want to know who got hurt
and i think
finally
once
we've worked on who got hurt
we have proven over 25-year period of
time and that's the time that my
colleagues and i have been able to
determine this
these these things have been going wrong
the apples have been rotting
that we have not been able as an
organization to handle this problem
we have inspectors we have offices of
professional responsibility we have
managers we just didn't handle this
problem
we're human
we need some help
i think i'll close by saying i brought
some of these issues to a manager at one
time and he told me fred there's nothing
we can do about it we're in a quicksand
a personnel quicksand we've allowed it
to go on to too long
if i were sinking
in quicksand i'd reach my hand out to
anyone with a stick or a rope
and say please give me a hand i made a
big mistake and i need some help
i thank you for your attention sir
thank you very much mr whiners mr cohen
i understand you're here in a supportive
role although you'll answer questions
you don't have a statement is that
correct that's correct uh and any issue
related to the matter pending in federal
court which are the retaliation concerns
uh i'm more than willing to answer any
question that the committee may have on
that fair enough mr alken welcome and uh
you may give your testimony at this
point summarize any way you wish again
your written testimony will be submitted
and holding the record without objection
all right thank you very much mr
chairman and to the other
members of the subcommittee my name is
dan alcorn i represent the
national association of criminal defense
lawyers which is a group of over 9 000
lawyers both private lawyers public
defenders judges and law professors who
are concerned about the administration
of criminal justice in the united states
and the organization is dedicated to see
that we have a fair administration of
criminal justice in the united states
our organization brought the freedom of
information lawsuit which resulted in
this report being released publicly on
april the 15th we felt it was very
important that the inspector general's
report be released to the public we are
pursuing additional materials in our
freedom of information suit which we
expect will take an additional
period of months but we will be pursuing
additional materials that relate to the
investigation
the concern of the national association
of criminal defense lawyers is what the
inspector general's report
means to the administration of criminal
justice in this country
one thing that we have to point out is
that there had been three prior
investigations of mr whitehurst
allegations within the fbi
before the inspector general came along
and issued the report that has the very
troubling findings that it has and i
think one of the key things that i would
urge on this subcommittee is to look
into why internally three prior reviews
of the situation did not come to the
conclusions which the inspector general
did when he made
his commitment to make a full
investigation of this and we think that
this raises issues about the ability
within the fbi to police internally
and to review their actions internally
and we think this is a very important
governmental issue
we see it in the courtrooms of the
country every day but at this level of
the u.s congress we think it's an issue
that you need to grapple with about how
do we in a national law enforcement
organization how do we have effective
self-policing how do we get the
organization to perform in the way that
we want as a seeker of truth and a
seeker of justice
we are very concerned as defense lawyers
that the department of justice has put
out a report which we provided to the
committee the copies that we had
it's a 1996 department of justice report
called
convicted by juries exonerated by
science
and what it is is a case study
of 28 cases that were found around the
united states in which individuals had
gone through trial all but one had gone
through trial one pleaded guilty
but
had gone through trial by jury had been
convicted
later dna testing which wasn't available
at the time of their trials indicated
that they were innocent
of the crime of which they were
convicted and they were all released
from prison and had their convictions
overturned this is all occurred within
the last 10 years it's a 10 year period
immediately before us
these 28 individuals served a total of
197 years in prison
you know our country's been around a
little longer than that but innocent
individuals
served
197 years combined total
in the prisons of the united states
now we think that this describes a kind
of problem
that exists in the system that the
committee needs to be concerned about as
we engage in crime fighting as we engage
in increasing the budgets of these
organizations we also need to keep as
our guide star
justice and truth in our system and to
have innocent people serving 197 years
in prison is something that we simply
should not tolerate as we go about the
important work of crime fighting
the another aspect of this report that
was very interesting was that the
conclusion was that scientific testimony
scientific evidence other than dna
evidence was not really very reliable in
cases
about pointing to guilt or innocence of
these individuals
the other scientific
evidence such as hair sample testing
and the other
types of testing that was performed did
not
in any case
lead to the innocence of the individual
and in fact most of the cases help to
inculpate them in other words help to
make them appear more guilty although in
none of the 28 cases did the other
scientific testimony actually point
specifically and individually to that
person but the other scientific evidence
was used to say it narrows the field to
this individual and one of the policy
conclusions of the department of justice
is that we have to be careful
in our use of scientific evidence as a
result of these cases is clear that we
need to be careful
in the way we use scientific evidence
in these trials because we now have
cases in which the science did not help
us keep innocent people from going to
prison
in concluding
our concern is the following the the
management the current management of the
fbi has overseen
the problems that have developed to the
point today
the inspector general made
recommendations for changes
the recommendations went to current fbi
management and they have said that they
will
try to implement the changes that were
recommended but here's the problem for
the congress i think
how can you have certainty that the
management that supervised uh the
problems and allowed them to fester and
develop and conducted three reviews that
didn't find
the problems how can you have certainty
that that management is going to be able
to implement the appropriate reforms
in order to get us to the point where we
want to be where we have a properly
functioning criminal justice system and
i think this is terribly important
because i think that
what dr whitehurst describes and what is
described in the inspector general's
report
is a problem of management
systemic management within the federal
bureau of investigation that has
permitted these situations to develop
and to continue and so we call
our organization feels that the congress
has an extremely important role here in
its oversight role
and in its appropriation role
that if an executive agency if their
problems identified and they need to be
corrected and they involve fundamental
issues of our values as americans the
congress should become very involved in
oversight and should use its role as a
co-equal branch of the government
to see that the executive branch
does begin to perform in the way that we
want them to perform
and so we think that the the concept of
of checks and balances and co-equal
branches of government is very
applicable here in this situation
that the congress can identify problems
that exist in this executive agency we
think the congress should take up the
responsibility of continuing oversight
and see that these problems are actually
corrected in the real world rather than
to have some press releases put out the
changes will be made but not have them
actually happen we think that today
would be the beginning of your
oversight to see that changes are
implemented finally we would call to
into question whether
in fact a scientific laboratory should
be within the federal bureau of
investigation at all and we think that
you should put on
the agenda for consideration whether
it's really reasonable to expect that
a
law enforcement organization such as the
fbi is the appropriate place to have an
objective
scientific laboratory and that is part
of considering these issues that exist
of whether
proper management can be applied within
the fbi to the laboratory and whether
that executive branch agency is going to
be able to clean up this problem you may
want to consider whether
the laboratory would become an
independent
organization
and would have a governance which would
be more likely uh to provide the kind of
objective results that we're talking
about and we have some of the ideas that
have come to us have been either judges
or lawyers or other public officials who
might
serve on a board of such a
national crime laboratory whose entire
mission and focus
would be one of seeking objective
results in cases seeking truth
uh in the science of cases
and so in conclusion let me just say
that we hope that in your deliberations
that you will not ignore that
the
management
at the fbi which has been in place
for some years
has in fact supervised
the conduct which is at issue here today
and that we hope that the congress will
not
in its oversight
ignore the problems
that that evidences and that the
congress will take
seriously its oversight responsibility
to see that reforms are actually
implemented in the real world on the
ground in this crime laboratory thank
you very much mr chairman
thank you mr alcorn we'll now go to a
five-minute rule which we have as a
process for asking questions and may go
through more than one round depending
upon the needs of the committee i
recognize myself first mr whitehurst do
you have any reason to believe that
director free knew
actually intended to ignore the material
concerns that you had expressed prior to
the inspector general getting involved
in doing his analysis in other words how
happened management did in your opinion
the neglect of this laboratory go
sir i took the issues to the office of
general counsel and the office of
general counsel oh i think in 1993 1994
period
if we had left it at that
at their findings
the ig report would not be showing us
the rudolph the oklahoma city
the avianca
all of those those issues where there
were real issues the
the
response really i got was these are
overblown issues that you're presenting
to us that was out of mr free's office
of general counsel that wasn't mr
director free himself as far as you know
do you know whether that was ever
brought to his attention or
that he personally was involved in
making those decisions early on i
believe sir i've got um
a documentation memo or whatever that mr
free signed off on
about those matters i didn't i went to
mr session with these matters just
before he left office left his his
position but i didn't personally haven't
personally talked to mr free about that
what was mr sessions reaction to your
complaint an allegation he took them
very seriously he told me that um i took
chapter one essentially the ig report to
him
and he said if this is true there's
gonna you know this this is really
significant and he wanted to
and
in fact he called me for another session
uh in which i talked to him for about an
hour uh both he and his um legal counsel
chief
um but i think he took the issues very
seriously sir
you've indicated in your testimony that
you think that the inspector general's
report has is something you generally
concur with i think you use those kinds
of words something that effect
what
is your reaction with regard to the
recommended reforms in terms of do they
go far enough
if they're fully implemented are they
adequate
all right you know i go back to
to
wanting outside oversight
um if the american society of crime
laboratory directors can go into that
laboratory unhindered
with the support of this nation
then i think
that the report makes a good
recommendation
i have a concern from having worked
there for 11 years that there might be
things written on paper but not actually
instituted
i think
accreditation is a is a step
where mechanisms are put into place
to
make sure things don't go wrong
but
despite the fact that a lab can be
accredited you can still find that
though the mechanisms are there a bad
product
can come out of a lab i think that's
where further oversight is
important well in particular the
recommendation includes having
non-agents in positions of senior
management uh i would think that that
could be very helpful
and if you have more agents that have
scientific backgrounds rather than
having as many apparently that don't as
have been there and so on i don't want
to go down the whole litany but uh it
would appear that on the face of it i
realize you have some apprehension about
whether they'll be fully implemented but
on the face of it these recommendations
are relatively solid at least to the
layman and that's why i was asking you
you're not the layman you're working in
the lab
and and i'm curious as to whether you
think the actual recommendations
themselves
if implemented and i realize that's the
big if sure are
are corrective would be corrective of
the problems that you saw
are adequate are sufficient the
recommendations that is what they
suggest being done or would you suggest
other things that should be done that
they did not suggest
in the ig report
yes i i think um
to make the lab better
um if if askglad comes in and it's and
there's a public
record of what they found in the
laboratory and there's a public record
of
what
measures were taken in other words if
there's some oversight beyond
asklat i think that we could depend on
that
that process being being viable
working
again
i would like to see an oversight body
beyond ask lad
that's there after asklat is gone to be
sure that
what's what
supposedly is implemented is actually
implemented and do you think that overs
what who could that oversight body be
the inspector general or or some
scientific panel or
congress
i think a scientific panel
would be appropriate of outside
experts from other agencies or from the
the private world or where
we have
the national national academy of science
out there the national research council
we've got um we do have bodies out there
that can
conduct that kind of oversight
one last question uh from my perspective
ms whitehurst as far as the
work product of most of the
scientists that are working there with
you in the laboratory from your
observations
uh you've testified
that there being problems specifically
here you've given a lot of evidence as a
whistleblower but the work product of
most of the scientists who are there is
that work product good
adequate
exceptionally good how do you rate the
work product of most of your colleagues
you work with i would say this i'm very
proud to have worked with them
and
i've worked with them for instance on
the world trade center bombing case
where we were working 20 22-hour days
and sleeping on the floor
for
days and days on end
they're the kind of people that
don't quit don't want to quit they're
totally dedicated completely
completely dedicated
most of them we've got again some bad
apples but you're convinced the quality
of the product they've produced
generally
in most instances has been a good
quality product
yes i believe i believe there's some
some issues of protocol validation which
are catching up with us now
as a result of the supreme court ruling
in dober dobert versus maryl dow
requiring reliability and
for years we've depended upon the fact
that our teachers said this is reliable
now the courts are demanding of us to
prove the reliability beyond peer review
and some of those issues are catching up
with this but i don't think their issues
of i think the word is malfeasance
people not
doing their job correctly on purpose or
whatever i think they're just
because the world's becoming more
complicated and these
these um kinds of materials we analyze
are
getting beyond our present capabilities
thank you very much mr whitehurst mr
jackson lee you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you very much mr chairman and i
appreciate
these hearings for the
reason that we do have a responsibility
to ensure
the integrity
of the highest legal
system
in our country and certainly a justice
system that all the world watches
uh mr chairman i would ask unanimous
consent to have my opening statement
submitted for the record without
objection sorted
uh mr whitehurst uh first of all i
appreciate your presence along with mr
alcorn and
you raised uh several interesting points
in your
testimony which i'd like to follow up
and it is likely that we may have a
second round and i may not complete my
questioning
first of all let me get uh your present
status
at the fbi where what uh status are you
in terms of employment with the fbi i'm
on administrative leave at the is at the
present time also i'm a supervisory
special agent assigned to the hazardous
materials response unit
but
right now i'm on administrative leave
would one be led to believe that your
present employment status
would color your testimony here today
do we hear
is it
would i be led to believe or or have any
reason to believe
uh that you're
being placed on administrative leave
um
places you in an adversarial position
where you're out to get the fbi
well i think if you
uh you can answer that
um
very clearly if you see that what i'm
saying today is what i've said since
1986
i'm not an adversary of the fbi
um my loyalty
i would hope wouldn't be questioned
i've placed
my future my family's future my fortune
on the line
we have a few bad apples if i were an
adversary of the fbi i wouldn't sit here
and ask you to use a very thin brush
that oig report i'd say paint the whole
laboratory paint the whole fbi i don't
believe that and that would be a
disservice to all of us so i
the administrative leave um
is with full pay
i haven't been hurt financially
well at least pay wise anyhow by by this
process
have you been hurt personally
excuse me have you been hurt personally
ms jackson the dr whitehurst has a has a
complaint in federal district court
under the first amendment and which
deals with a lot of the retaliation
issues
and i'm more than glad to answer those
questions but the parties have agreed to
mediation of the employment dispute
and i'm here to to resolve that but but
for the record uh we do believe that dr
whitehurst has been damaged in his
reputation
and you would consider that that he's
been hurt personally yes
dr whitehurst if you were to look at
this uh long history of problems and you
started
reporting this in 1988
where would you most and i don't like
the terminology blame but where would
you most think
uh the solution could have uh begun
looking and assessing the issues that
you were raising where could we have
most begun to solve those problems
i think ma'am
most of all
we're afraid of ourselves
everybody's afraid and the issues that
i've raised were not raised by me they
were raised by me and my colleagues and
were afraid to go forward
i think it has to do with embarrassment
it has to do with fear of retaliation
fear of losing our jobs
but we're afraid of ourselves in that
laboratory
a scientific laboratory is a place where
ideas are
are shared arguments are welcome that's
part of the scientific process
we're afraid
we're afraid to come forward
and we need to address that
to be most effective as scientists
let me follow up on that because i i
guess i can glean from your
answer that the first place that we
could have started to remedy this would
have been internally and so my question
is did other scientists in the crime lab
share your concerns regarding scientific
misconduct
and are you able to share with us who
those scientists are
or were are they still in the lab
and what actions did they make
individually and separate from you maybe
in the internal process to make those
concerns known
yes some other scientists in the lab did
share my concerns uh if i can go back to
1986 and my very first week in the
laboratory or the second week i can't
remember exactly which
our chief chemist roger marks came to me
to warn me about the man who turned out
to be my training agent i took um
martz's
words as kind of confusing to me
initially
um but marx knew there was a bad product
and he knew people had tried to fix it
um roger march is one of the individuals
by the way that's that's spoken about in
that report my supervisor
my former unit chief james corby
um
was the guy that i went to for reality
check all the time was unbelievable some
of the things i was saying i went to
other examiners david nichols roger
palmer
ed kelso pat welsh
steve burmeister
just
just
so many people that were concerned um
scientists at quantico in our research
facility that were concerned about the
science that we were doing
uh concerned about
issues like who we were and were not
employing
um
about who was putting their names on
papers and things like that there were
there's just
it's a
it's kind of a boiling pot of people
that are
that do have very real concerns concerns
about contamination
uh in the laboratory
for years
this is example i use is for years our
our ventilation system was blowing out
something we came to refer to as black
grain it turned out had left lead
particulate in it and nobody would do
anything about it
lead in a lab looking for lead
creates a reasonable doubt if it's
blowing in from the outside do you know
so there's
i can go on and list more people that we
had um women in the lab that were
concerned about health problems some my
the chemist working with me kelly
hargenin
was concerned about
a child she
she's now had
there just
just many people expressing these
concerns and very angry about some of
the things
i represent the city of cincinnati and
there's just a story that's broken back
there this week about a a police officer
that's apparently admitted
planting drugs on a particular defendant
who
uh as a result went to went to uh prison
and uh it certainly does
shatter to some extent the confidence
that we have assuming that this is all
true in police officers and i think it's
a bit similar to what some of the
allegations are that have been made
recently with reference to the fbi
uh i mean i think the public
uh would like to think and i certainly
would like to think that when you hear
the something's gone through the fbi
crime lab for example i mean what could
be more motherhood and apple pie than
the fbi
whether it's our reliance upon
fingerprinting
or investigation of various bombing
incidents which have taken place i mean
i think we want to
assume that it's everything's above
board that
completely accurate scientific uh
evidence and experimentation has been
has been carried out and that's why i
think the allegations that have been
made uh are are so disturbing
and and uh mr whitehurst i'd ask if you
would comment on
the allegations that you've brought
forth and the oig's
report
and the changes which are being made
could you comment on the the
the confidence uh the loss of confidence
perhaps
in law enforcement and the fbi labs that
allegations such as you brought forth
bring to the public
i think sir you were able to name one
policeman on the whole police force
that leaves me confident
i believe we're a microcosm of society
we're gonna pick up bad wood we just are
um i i don't think that we can't afford
to lose confidence when i as an fbi
agent go to someone's front door and ask
questions i can't have them closing the
door on my face every time
so i
i think that it's sort of a wake-up call
we're not as law enforcement officers
above review
we shouldn't be
but it doesn't mean we're bad it just
means we need some outside oversight and
there's oversight in you know citizen
groups or whatever for police
departments
why should there not be no regulation of
forensic labs in this country
before the problem goes bad before the
problems like this show up
let's catch them let's nip them in the
bud
i'm
an fbi agent and i will open my door to
an fbi agent and let him in the house
i'm confident that the fbi lab
by and large is putting out a good
product
i don't want to over infer that data sir
i think that's exactly right i think
that uh as unpleasant as
oversight hearings like this may be
on occasion the fact that they may shake
our confidence a bit in some of our
institutions
i think the strength of those
institutions over the long run
us depended upon having these types of
hearings where we let
let the chips fall where they may
let the whole agency air out and if
there are problems then certainly
fix those problems so that the fbi is as
good as
it possibly can be and i want to thank
you for coming forward with your
testimony would you like to comment on
the oig report itself
i know you did a little bit already but
are you basically satisfied with the
recommendations that have been
made as a result of
your allegations and others
i am in the process of reviewing the
report i expect it to take me a bit
longer
what i've seen so far
indicates to me as i said
they really took a close look they
really listened mr glenn denning uh
and mr miato ran that crew and they
really
looked deeply into what i was talking
about i didn't just get the brush off
and i think we can feel confident about
that there's some scientific issues in
there that i you know i take issue with
there's some scientific technical issues
that i disagree with um
but i'm i'm elated you know when they
showed me the report to review i i was
like a kid in a candy shop it was
my gosh we've we've got there we've got
there it's on the table and now we can
move forward after all these years okay
and final question um
the uh
certainly what what you've brought
forward and some of the things which uh
you're alleging
would give
uh some defense attorneys must alcorn i
might want to bring you in on this also
um
maybe a field day on some cases which is
one of the unfortunate things about this
that
some cases that may not merit review
we'll have attorneys filing appeals and
wanting to overturn convictions
certainly if people were convicted
and are behind bars and and are innocent
we want to know that but mr alcorn if
you could comment do you know how many
cases
that we may be talking about here that
may be
under jeopardy either appeals as a
result of what's happened in the crime
lab well hundreds and perhaps thousands
will be looked at and you know of course
the result is we want to get to good
science good objective results i do want
to say that on the issue of we do no one
any favor we don't do law enforcement
any favor if we give them a kind of
power that is not checked by some sort
of oversight because no human being can
resist the temptation that comes with
that kind of of unbridled power you know
none of us can resist that have given
that and i think the problem that we're
trying to submit to the congress here is
how do we check
in an appropriate way
the kind of power that we're giving to
some of our law enforcement institutions
because of the problem of crime that we
have and i think that's an important
national
policy issue i think dr whitehurst has
done his part by coming forward but
we're advocating
some systemic changes so that we have a
check and balance
in these law enforcement agencies thank
you very much
mr hutchinson you're recognized for five
minutes i thank the chairman and i
appreciate the testimony the witnesses
presented today
let me start mr whitehurst
with you
it's my understanding that the oig
report
looked at the explosives unit the
materials analysis unit and the
chemistry toxology unit
uh
now how many units all total are there
in the uh laboratory division of the fbi
well i've heard 25 or 30 but um that is
reconfiguring all the time and since
i've been gone since the 20th of january
and um i would imagine they might have
reconfigured since then
but this would be uh dealing with
problems in about three units of the fbi
laboratory which might be 25 units yes
it was actually four because the issue
involving the matter of
the bad testimony in the elsi hastings
matter came out of the hares and fibers
unit so it's actually four units that
that were
reviewed i've been handing a note
indicating about 35 units in the fbi
laboratory okay sound reasonable to you
that sounds right and the oig report
whether it be three or four if you
include that last unit dealt with only
four units of the fbi laboratory yes
and uh
the other units i mean there's there's
numerous but like the document
unit
and the fingerprint unit both those
there's not been any problem uh either
in your review or the oig's review
i'm not you know i wasn't
working in those units and so
what what i did sir was when problems
were presented to me i brought them
forward
you know and i wasn't in those units so
and you're not aware of any problems
then no not to say that they might
no one can say that there's not a
problem that doesn't exist but you're
not aware of any problems in those units
and the oig did not become aware of any
problem in those units
um
no i'm not right now sir i just wasn't
acquainted with those units
uh mr whitehurst uh one thing i wanted
to ask you about
and i admire your struggle first of all
because i know that uh you've been
through a lot and
and that the result i believe is is
something that's beneficial for
our court system uh but one thing did
disturb me a little bit and i wanted you
to comment on it that
did you ever communicate your concerns
with defense counsel and expert
witnesses in a criminal case
yes he did
and uh what can you tell me what case
that was yes that was a matter in just
in this the u.s versus stephen sonakas
okay t-s-i-n-a
the criminal subject matter was this a
robbery it's a bombing
it was an explosives some
related
prior to going to defense council
did you go the united states attorney no
sir i didn't
is this not a severe breach of
the ethical standards and
responsibilities of the fbi
you mean on my part yes
i recognized what i was doing was
unorthodox when i did it
i didn't know where else to go
well you could have gone the united
states attorney could you yes i could i
could but i reached a judgment based
upon a
interaction with him
that said to me
this man is also
going to take what i've said
as
you know so what that sort of situation
sir and that's and that's why i went to
the defense expert i didn't talk to the
attorney himself but i talked to the
defense expert and you gave him
information that they could use in
cross-examination
i told him
that
the essentially that the
the testimony or what this fellow this
other agent was presenting was suspect
and you never told the united states
attorney that
i didn't tell him until after uh after
the fact after the trial
no the trial is still going on i uh i
met with him in his office and explained
to him at that point my misgivings
now
mr alcorn
let me talk to you because
as my colleague indicated
this is a field day for defense
attorneys can you just be very specific
and tell me in your view how can what's
the best way for the credibility to be
returned to and we should put it in
perspective the three or four units of
the fbi laboratory out of the 35 units
well let me on that point when the
inspector general released his report he
said that no one should take it that it
validates the rest of the laboratory
because he made no investigation
of anything other than the specific
allegations that were brought to him in
those units so we really have had no
review or investigation and he did not
want anyone to take it that this was
validating the rest of those units our
concern is independence what we believe
that what's happened here is that in the
chain of command down the fbi because
the laboratory is in the chain of
command that that creates a problem and
has created a problem
my time is going to wind up here the
other than the independence of the
laboratory which is a
big issue there but other than that what
would be the most significant thing the
fbi can do at this point we need to have
more open discovery and criminal cases
you're questioning dr whitehurst about
speaking to defense counsel i think it's
actually positive when a case is tried
with as much truthful information as
possible about the case we do not have
open discovery in many districts in the
country i've tried cases in districts
where we do and we've prevented mistakes
from being made
in the cases which we don't want
mistakes
made in the system and and my final
point you know is the defense counsel he
talked to defense counsel but defense
counsel are in the u.s constitution
by specific wording and name and so
we're all sworn to uphold the u.s
constitution and that includes defense
counsel we do have an adversarial system
of justice right but we're seeking truth
absolutely and we should all remember
that thank you very much mr thank you mr
mr geekers you're recognized for five
minutes
yes i thank the chairman
mr whitehorse the
the article that you wrote black magic
and the bureau
begins by
talking about the plaque that you
received in recognition of your
outstanding contribution to the
successful investigation and prosecution
of the world trade center bombing case
so that i take it you uh you did good
work there or at least it seemed to be
good work to those who awarded you the
plaque
it was the
u.s attorney
then you go on to say in this same
article in the next paragraph that in
the trade center case scientific fraud
was prevented
are you saying that it was prevented
because you had blown the whistle
and thus
what might have been tainted testimony
did not get to the jury
yes it wasn't just me that blew the
whistle if you will or brought the
issues forward it was myself and other
individuals in the lab
so that as far as you were concerned
when the
matter went to trial in the world
trade center case
there was no
uh discrepancy about which you had
complained is that correct
yes uh the the specific complaint was
about a report that had gone out that
had been um
it represented the opinion of
unqualified examiners about a particular
area
of expertise and that did not go forward
that did not go forward you prevented it
in other words
i did um my others did yes yes that's
correct but then the the
oig report in commenting on the world
trade center bombing
centers on the testimony of williams
and it almost is a scathing review of
his lack of expertise and so forth what
was your relationship to williams
agent williams was a fellow who worked
in the explosive unit he was a principal
examiner of evidence and i was an
auxiliary examiner which meant i did i
worked on evidence did analysis of
evidence that he sent to me
you gave or prevented the evidence that
you prevented from going
williams did not prevent is that correct
yes that's correct what happened was a
report was issued and went forward to
the prosecutor the report was flawed
it was flawed
and
my i i and another
examiner
raised issues about the flawed report
and
my supervisor told me go get it go get
everything that goes into it and rewrite
it because it shouldn't have been
written mr williams allowed that report
to go forward
but
mr williams wasn't in a position to
understand when he reviewed the report
what was wrong with it at that time
so you didn't think there was anything
wrong with the williams report
no no this is confusing isn't it it's a
sense i'm trying to okay
he confused myself
what went on with uh new york
with the situation in the world trade
center was that a report was issued that
was flawed
we raised issues
we said this is a flawed report it was
not removed the steve burmeister and i
said well okay we'll expose the fraud in
court
you you will bring that report back or
we'll just we'll testify to this on the
stand
my supervisor said bring the report back
he recognized it was flawed he said
bring the report back we brought it back
and we fixed it the issues in the ig
report have to do with mr williams's
testimony during the
trial itself
and i did not find out about that
testimony i didn't review that testimony
until
a couple of years after the testimony
took place
well then why if you were
you didn't know anything about what
williams might say in court and which
later you found surprising
but that you you expressed sadness at
receiving the award
for
your contribution to the the world trade
center case
even though you had prevented fraud i
was it was just
a sad thing that it even got to that it
was said what sad thing that we got to
that that a report came out of the fbi
laboratory that was that flawed
that we knew we knew had problems with
it and we wouldn't do anything about it
that's a sad situation did you say
anything about that when you received
the plaque
no it wasn't an appropriate time to say
something about it sir
you didn't think about refusing to take
it
there's different ways of raising issues
and i didn't think it was appropriate at
that time to raise that issue sir
i was in the director's office you feel
you deserve the plaque
i think that i did a very good job in
the world trade center bombing case
whether i deserve a plaque or not that's
up to others to decide to but you felt a
sadness in
at the moment that you received it yes
was did you feel good about that what
you had prevented from going into k into
the case was that your contribution
my contribution was the hard work
the laboratory that we set up there
the management of the analysis of
samples
and also
stopping that flawed science from going
forward then you wouldn't feel good
about that
sure i would
but you express sadness
it is a sad thing that the fbi would
allow such report to go out of its
laboratory sir
it is and i think that we've heard that
here but you were successful in
preventing it
from being entered into evidence only by
taking the methods that we took
and you should feel good about that
yes
i have no questions
mr kobel you're recognized for five
minutes i thank the chairman gentlemen
good to have you all with us
dr whitehars let me talk to you a bit
about retaliation
first of all it is my belief that any
whistleblower
probably has felt the sting of
retaliation
if i work for a guy and i think the work
product is
imperfect and inaccurate and i blow the
whistle
common sense tells me that my
supervisor's not going to come up to
yourself gee thanks for blowing the
whistle on our sloppy job
and i think the gut reaction is going to
be i'm going to nail the whistle blower
now having that's my belief i ca i can't
do the proven or disprove that
but let me ask you this dr whitehurst
regarding your performance review of
december 95.
i realize that performance review
is not the only available route
that one need pursue to impose
retaliation but it is a convenient route
now in that performance
uh review of yours your supervisor
readied you superior are exceptional now
that would tend to
support the fbi's position that they
have in fact not retaliated what say to
that
mr council
um
again the retaliation issues are
currently in federal court and we're
moving into mediation on that we've
agreed to that but
i think what the record would show is
that mr corby who was his unit chief
actually supported dr whitehurst's
whistleblowing and supported the vast
majority of the scientific concerns he
was raising and what you'll see in the
fbi that there was a disconnect often
between some of what the scientists were
saying and what was happening out of
groups such as the office of
professional responsibility and the
office of general counsel it's from
those groups that most of the
retaliation came from mr corbyn
who signed off on five or six glowing
evaluations of dr whitehurst was a
supporter and if you look at the 1993
evaluation you'll see right
and in the words he used to describe dr
whitehurst on a world trade
are are glowing and exceptional
that
brings us to the oversight issue and it
brings us to how do you protect
whistleblowers
and as uh in the pre-fault remarks i
filed uh president clinton has recently
directed the attorney general to set up
legally mandated protections for
whistleblowers that did not exist
although in law they existed had not
been implemented from 1989 to 1997
and in terms of oversight an effective
mechanism to protect whistleblowers is
absolutely critical that's where we
would go with that i thank you for that
answer and as i said i realize that
performance review is not the exclusive
route to be pursuing that could be gamed
one way or the other
dr whitehurst
is it your belief that the fbi culture
well strike that
does the fbi culture reward one's status
as an agent
as opposed to a non-agent
does it reward your status as an agent
opposed to a non-agent in other words
does one who who enjoys the status of an
agent
does he or she
enjoy preferential treatment
compared to his or her colleagues who
does not have the status of agent but
rather is known as a non-agent you know
it's interesting that you ask that
question then the special agent that
recruited me carl mcleod in houston
texas back in 1981 told me that
i wanted to come into the fbi as a
scientist not as an agent and he said
you need to be an agent you'll go
further you'll get more out of the fbi
as an agent
all right so so so given what did it
well did you find that to be the culture
in fact i believe that
a lot of people do do harbor that
concern also and speak about it that we
treat non-agents as second-class
citizens i said that now given that
culture then do you think that may have
contributed to some of the problems at
the lab
yes i do
uh
mr alcorn uh you may have said this and
if so and i apologize for having not
picked up on it
were you involved as defense counsel in
with any of the defendants
whom you mentioned earlier who were
victims of the inaccurate
laboratory findings
no i was not that comes out of the
department of justice report from last
year in which they did research to try
to find
uh they had heard about cases and they
were able to find 28.
mr chairman i think i have no further
questions thank you thank you mr
copeland mr wexler you're recognized for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman this is one
question mr whitehurst and i apologize
if it's been asked before before i i
came into the hearing room um
with respect to your experience um are
you concerned
that there are people that have been
convicted or wrongfully convicted as a
result of some of the the
what appears to be
less than than prudent behavior at the
fbi in terms of the crime lab
yes sir i am concerned about that
and if i may then just to follow that up
and again i apologize if this is uh
material that's been asked and answered
with respect to that concern which seems
in my mind to be a very legitimate one
and i and i admire you for it what is
the appropriate course of action either
in terms of your
course of action at this point or in
terms of what you might recommend to
this committee in terms of what it
should do
i think that the um the ig report
says there are some problems
it doesn't go far enough to look into
the history of
the problem-causers if you will or the
problem
employees
in the matter involving the false
testimony as the ig referred to it uh in
the uh trial of of congressman hastings
for instance the individual that was
involved in that probably worked on four
or five thousand cases in his career
it
i i have reviewed a
a
wall street journal
article which indicates there might be
some other problems and i think we need
to if if we can say there's clearly a
problem with this employee and the way
this employee testified
in in this matter we need to look
backwards and see
if that's indeed the case in other cases
okay
all right thank you mr chairman
thank you mr webster mr bowie are you
recognized for five minutes
thank you just a couple questions one
and i want to get to the culture
question
so i can understand the the lab a little
bit better um
if in fact the the culture is they they
do not want specialists
um then
agents will come into the lab spend a
few years there and then move in and out
of the lab tell me about how the how
that works
well in the past um i you know agents
have come in and they've sort of divided
into a couple of groups they came in
under the science program they're doing
their stunt in the lab they just want to
leave then there's also agents that have
come in like
my supervisor james corby that spent
over 30 years in the fbi laboratory and
it's a for a scientist it's a
fascinating beautiful place to work it's
really great and so you you know you get
all all the neat
the
uh good solid problems to work on that
sort of thing so um
excuse me a scientist would see it as a
it's like being
you know a kid in a candy shop
but are there agents that come in spend
three or four years there and then go go
back out into the fields with their
knowledge and expertise
yes
i i know is that the normal flow of
personnel no my my experience is that
most people come in
and stay for a number of years for a
long time
if in fact there's a culture
within the fbi that perpetuates
this problem in the lab
what is your recommendation to cure
i think
well that's a difficult one sir i i
think that
so you've written 235 memorandums you've
written letters you've
you have an opportunity now to
to present a cure to a panel that's
going to listen
i don't think you should have to stutter
but i am stuttering
i would like to know that
our managers recognize all of us as very
valuable members of the team
i'm not sure that's part of our
management culture
i'd like
anyone that's been associated with any
matter
to be recognized
which ought to be
when you talk about chain of custody
and who actually ran the equipment and
who actually understands the science
i don't know how you
solve the problem of supreme arrogance
sir
i don't know how you address it
if you don't recruit it
if you don't recruit people with some
humility if you don't
fill them with some understanding that
supreme arrogance is very destructive
well do you flush the lab and you have
solely uh non-agents as scientists that
works in just in the lab you know i i
don't think that's a good idea some
people have suggested that
but there are
there are definitely cases where science
is needed
where a practicing scientist is needed
but he also needs to be an fbi agent
and so i don't see us flushing the
laboratory
that's been a long running argument back
and forth i don't see flushing all the
agents out of the lab
egos within the realms of science can be
pretty large because you hold on tight
to your theories do you not
so i don't think you ever want to flush
the word ego out from a scientist
i understand
what you're saying
well again i i won't take up your the
time to do this what i would ask you to
do though is to think about that
question and submit in writing to panel
your uh what you recommend to cure with
regard to the lab would you do that for
us
sure i i think that would be uh very
helpful the other thing i i have to ask
real quick is your uh
this failure to cooperate with the
professional responsibility and into the
allegations that you had improperly
disclosed information to the media
why did you fail to cooperate and are
continuing to fail cooperate with the
investigation and defer to council mr
that's again a matter that is subject to
our suit in federal court and as i
mentioned before we're attempting to go
into mediation
it's important to understand that it's
our position that dr whitehurst did not
fail to cooperate
the issue turned on the right to counsel
it was the second time in dr
whitehurst's career in the bureau that
he was asked to
quote unquote cooperate with some form
of investigation and that he was not
allowed full access to council the first
time
we instructed dr whitehurst not to go
forward until the right to council issue
was resolved
that matter was laid to rest but now
they have a new policy
the second time it came up the same
issue arose and we again gave that
instruction i understand there's a new
policy and they say that issue is now in
court
we did raise the constitutional right to
counsel as one of the claims in court
it's under mediation now i know and i'm
speaking on behalf of my client to say
we hope that those matters can be
settled and resolved through a very
respected mediation process in federal
court all right thank you mr chairman
thank you mister
we don't have the time to go through
full complete two rounds of questions
for every panel but we are going to
attempt a little bit of that with you ms
twitter's because we had so few here to
begin with in the questioning and i'm
going to yield myself another five
minutes i don't know if i'll consume all
of it and ask a couple of questions i
want to pursue first the culture
question just a bit with respect
particularly to the expert witness
testimony of those at the laboratory
that you've observed and your your
opinions your observations about the
attitude going in as experts
are those who testify from the
laboratory and or have they in the past
been generally prosecution oriented is
is it is it a culture that suggests that
our job is to go in and
and to prove the case or help the
prosecutor prove the case
uh or
is it
the job of the person there the attitude
normally who goes to testify that
they're there just to let all hang out
uh scientifically
well you know we divide into different
groups in the laboratory about that and
it's a a discussion that goes on
um
quite often for a long time i understood
it to be
not desirable to be working
you know some people were just
expressing the fact that i'm not there
for the prosecutor i'm there for the
science
i went off to law school and found out
the prosecutors looking for justice
i am too and so i work for the
prosecutor if my concept of a prosecutor
is a fellow who's just trying to prove
guilt
then of course i find myself
appalled when somebody wants me to leave
out my understanding of the data that
doesn't support a finding of guilt
but there are
quite a number of people in the
laboratory that are still left with that
feeling or there were on the 20th of
january when i left
that are troubled by
our giving opinions that leave out so
much of our understanding of the data
well you know i looked at the ig's
report in the details with respect to
some of these cases and those who are
most criticized individually for expert
witness testimony appear to be
people who
look like they just stretched it they
they went out and and tried to make it
sound as good as possible and that's
where the trouble came from not that not
necessarily that the underlying evidence
wasn't there or not there it's just they
wanted to make the case that's what it
looks like i don't know if it's true but
that's what the
the ig report in some of these cases
look like to me as the outside observer
so i'm concerned about that and i'm i'm
interested very much in what you've had
to say i'm also interested in whether or
not you observed during your tenure
there or have observed during your
tenure there a rivalry with a bureau of
alcohol tobacco farms explosives
unit in terms of getting the scientific
evidence and in terms of getting there
faster sooner quicker and whether or not
that a if that rivalry exists in your
opinion and b the degree to which that
might negatively affect the work product
does the fbi
scientists and agents at the laboratory
attempt to move too quickly to beat the
atf so to speak
i think over my tenure and i raised this
issue in one of my letters to the ig
that i heard so many times from
men that declared themselves to be the
premier experts in explosives our
explosive unit personnel that the atf
couldn't
do their job were incompetent whatever
it was rivalry that i asked this
question if this is what the fbi
believes isn't this exculpatory
information in any court of law in which
the atf
laboratory appears
it was it's a valid question from my
point of view if if they're not doing
their job right and the fbi believes the
atf can't do their job right and we're
articulating it loudly
well don't defendants and court of law
deserve that i personally don't agree
with that point of view i i have worked
closely with the atf for
with their lab for ever since i've been
in the laboratory
and i think they have a very
professional product has that rivalry
ever negatively affected the work
product that you've observed at the fbi
lab in the sense of people trying to
beat the atf and trying to do you know
one of them or whatever
um
when personnel in the fbi laboratory
no longer wanted to conduct explosive
residue testing because of allegations
i'd raised that the testing that i was
doing i went to atf and said can we work
together and i
very quickly thereafter got a note from
my my section chief through my unit
chief that said you can't talk to them
stay away from them they won't do the
testing at this point sir
there are many parts of our explosives
analysis protocol that haven't been
validated all right let me ask you a
question about the oklahoma city bombing
very briefly did you work on that
mr mccomb the
fbi
in discussions we've had have asked that
because of a protective order issued by
the judge in that case that uh my client
not directly address
matters related to oklahoma city well
very that's that's satisfactory but let
me ask one question that won't be in the
details of of that and uh maybe you can
answer it if you can't he can't um the
office of the inspector general
particularly criticized a supervisory
special agent david williams
and in that process there's reference
being made to a letter a 30-page letter
that you sent
dated september the 5th 1995 regarding
that particular agent
is that
something that you sent from your own
knowledge was this
or was this a criticism a
a letter that you prepared based upon
what others represented to you in other
words i'm not clear on the that's the
reason i asked that question i'm not
clear on whether or not this is one of
those cases where you personally observe
the deficiencies that you set forth or
whether or not you were merely
transmitting other people's observations
okay okay certainly we need to dance
with this one that's been enough but i
want to be sure that you understand i'm
not asking substance information i'm
asking procedural yes mr chairman mr
williams gave me his report to review i
reviewed the report
we initially started a process where he
and i were going to discuss it it had
already been issued i don't know why he
gave me the report
the process of our discussion
was stopped by management
and at that point i went to my manager
and said
there's problems here we're about to go
through this again
but
my 30 page memo came from my personal
review
of that
that particular report all right not
from work on the subject of of oklahoma
city but on your review of that report
all right i understand thank you
mr jackson lee you're recognized
thank you very much mr chairman let me
um just for the record state that in the
last congress we
had
the very sensitive duty to oversee and
uh to review the waco tragedy and
several other incidences and
i hope that we
proceed with these hearings over the
next couple of days in the context in
which
i think is most appropriate to restore
the faith of the american people in the
criminal justice system mr alcon i
welcome your statement not in an
adversarial way that you are part of the
constitution we should recognize that uh
mr whitehurst in particular
um i think that we do ourselves a
disservice if we
give suggestions that this is not a
place where you would be welcome we
don't want any suggestion i believe as
an oversight committee
that
individuals who have something to say
about our whole system of government or
our whole system of justice are not
welcomed in the united states congress
so with that i would like to ask some
more pointed questions
um
did the whistleblower act of 1989
protect you
from your perspective
is that something mr cohen if you have
to answer that is that something that is
sufficiently in place that we can
um
be
comfortable
that we will have the opportunity to
hear information uh as it is needed
i think that's a very important question
the whistleblower protection act of 1989
amended a provision to protect fbi
agents and strengthened it considerably
to give fbi agents a right to a hearing
a right to discovery a right to an
attorney attorney's fees if they win
other damages it sets strict time limits
and if you look at when dr whitehurst
first started blowing the whistle in a
more public way 1989 there he had a
right
to a hearing within a specified time
limit
but the fbi did not implement that law
the attorney general did not implement
that law the president did not implement
that law so between 1989 and 1997
you had a situation in which
whistleblowers at the fbi were in a
lawless
institution
it's no wonder why people were afraid to
come forward their mandated procedures
were not implemented and they were in
place but none no they they weren't even
in place nothing
nothing was done
to implement the law
president clinton on april 14 1997 at
the direct result of dr whitehurst's
first amendment suit in which we sought
a mandamus against the president an
injunction against the attorney general
ordered the attorney general to finally
implement that law it's still not in
place but what is incredible is that dr
whitehurst had to be in this franz kafka
type of reality
in which there was no due process where
laws were passed and they meant nothing
and he had to go through procedure after
procedure after procedure
uh in in in in a kafka's in france
kafka's castle thank you i hope let me
um if you finish your last sentence sure
i just hope that that will change thank
you
uh dr whitehurst you started
in 1988 you operated under more than one
director of the fbi
what is your assessment of the role that
a director of the fbi could have taken
in the circumstances that you spoke of
actually ma'am started in 1986 but
i think that a lot of the issues i
raised were very
complex issues
i think that the director
could be
could be very clear with us
what our role is we're investigators
that's what we do we don't decide guilt
and fill in the blanks i think that
message could have been very clearly put
forward again and again and again
and you're saying that it was not done
during the during your time of making
mention of these concerns
yes during my time we were concerned we
talked among ourselves but but the
directors whoever they might have been
say from 86 to now to the present
you're saying that you did not get a
sense
uh that um there was a response
from the top down on the concerns you
are making is that my understanding yes
all right let me just go on very quickly
um you had mentioned a concern about the
procedures used by the fbi lab in
determining the composition of paint
might you just briefly expand on that
yes when i was taken out of explosives i
was put into as a trainee in the paint
analysis area my
supervisor jim corby had been really the
foremost forensic pain analyst in this
country for many years and he realized
we were running into problems because
the paint was changing we were using the
old techniques to analyze them
and what really turned out was
we didn't have a very clearly written
protocol and we don't have any
documentation of having validated that
protocol that's to know that the answers
we're getting out of it are correct it
doesn't mean they're wrong it's just we
don't know if they're right
when daubert was was um ruled on the
daubert case in in the supreme court
we ended up with it being sort of put in
our face you've got to say whether that
what you're doing is reliable or not
before it was just peer review
let me let me get the rest of that in
writing and ask this question so that
you can answer it all eyes were on
atlanta this past summer and of course
with richard jewell
my question is how much lab work and lab
participation was in the initial
investigation dealing with the richard
jewell matter i i don't know that i
wasn't involved in that and so you're
not aware whether any lab analysis or
you're not
i guess involved enough to know what lab
analysis was utilized in that
investigation would you say that there
was lab analysis i know that there was a
lab analysis but i don't know what it
was and was it out of the atlanta office
or out of washington d.c washington dc
is the only that's the only lab we have
all right yes thank you thank you mr
jackson lee mr shabbat you're recognized
thank you mr interesting time i'll keep
my uh questions real brief just have a
very brief question here
mr whitehurst in your testimony here
this morning you stated that
among the problems that you witnessed
there was pressure on scientists to
change the contents of reports in order
to bolster a prosecutor's case
could you give any specific examples of
that taking place
yes in the world trade center case i had
a report brought to me
we had detected some materials which
were consistent with a particular type
of explosive however they're also
consistent with materials on your hand
right now
and in sewage and in a number of other
things
um
i had marked through when it was the
paper was handed to me marked through
the statements that gave the alternative
explanations for the data
and
my supervisor told me that they and i
didn't know who they were but they
wanted me to take those statements out
um
he said he disagreed with that
but um
there wasn't a basis at all to take the
statements out that was an example of
um
you know what's there's
is there's something i call a scientific
argument which you can enter into
if you get somebody coming at you i
don't want it i don't want it
that that kind of pressures is
inappropriate
you also mention in here that there was
fabrication of of data and
misinterpretation of data
are there any particularly egregious
examples of that that you'd like to
bring up at this particular hearing
i think when i look at the ig report and
the things that i've reported overall i
i have an understanding if a man walks
into a court of law and he testifies
something he doesn't know anything about
he's got to get he's got to get his
testimony from someplace
do you know i mean he's got well you
make it up but you want an answer i'll
give you an answer i don't you know i
don't have any data to base my answer on
but let me give you an answer so if you
have a guy who's got a degree in english
and goes into court and testifies about
chemical analysis though he's never had
any
any background in chemical analysis at
all
where is he getting that information
he's just
from my my point of view he must be just
fabricating it right there in front of
you okay then my final question or point
here is in in the time that that you
were serving in your capacity in the lab
and these various examples that you've
talked about where where either
data was uh fabricated or people were
bolstering prosecutors cases
do you have a feel for for how many of
your colleagues
were involved in that type of of
behavior versus the number who were
doing their jobs appropriately and were
dotting all the i's and crossing all the
t's i mean was it a small number of
people was it significant would you
comment on no it was a small number of
people i understand at this point
there's over 600 people in the
laboratory i could be wrong about that
but
um
i i think there were less than 10 people
you know i that were actually involved
in some sort of
um getting outside the bounds of
of um where they were supposed to be
operating do you know how many of those
people are still there
no i i haven't been there now since the
20th of january sorry do you know if any
of them are still there i mean
do you know that they're all gone
i i
you know i understood i read in the
newspaper that there were four of us
that were that were
removed from our positions
i don't know where the other three
um you know i i really don't know where
they went to would you comment on the
fbi's
the
higher-ups
response to your allegations about this
um
as to whether they were
interested in perhaps
acting upon the the evidence that you
brought forth i i think um
i made allegations for quite a long time
i think this is very demonstrative of
you know what you want to know my um my
training agent came online and one of
the first cases he worked he started
running into the same problems i did and
he went to the section chief and he came
back from the section chief almost with
tears and eyes he said that guy sat
right there and told me that the people
i was complaining about have been
stretching the truth and testimony in
court for years
and that was the end of it
there was a this the problem going on
inside those wall sir was very well
known it's just um it's embarrassing and
it was sort of out of control
they didn't seem to be able to control
it
okay thank you gentlemen you're back
about my time thank you mr chabot mr
wexler you recognized for five minutes
[Music]
question earlier with respect to
your concern that there are people who
have in fact been wrongfully convicted
as a result
of mistake or inappropriate behavior on
behalf of the the crime lab how many
people are we talking about a few a
dozen
i don't know sir
i for a long time i didn't know any
i i just knew that this has to have hurt
somebody
and then the issue with
with congressman hastings came forward
and it was my gosh is surprising me the
first guy that was denied due process is
now a us congressman
you know
i'm beginning to hear and i read the
media the news stories about this and
getting indications and there are some
people that communicate with me through
my attorney about issues but we haven't
settled those yet
and just to clarify the record
my office has obtained some confidential
communications from
defendants whom
were found were had been convicted
uh were found to be innocent
uh and and it's under review and it
looks fairly clear to us at this time
that it was based upon uh improper lab
work
those defendants have asked for
confidentiality and we hope to get an
outside scientific review before that
allegation goes forward okay when you
say those those defendants were
convicted and now found to be innocent
found to be innocent by the people
who yeah the charges were dropped by
other circumstances the real uh okay
criminals were surfaced uh after the
conviction so those people are not
sitting in prison today no no
are there people sitting in prison today
that may fall under
your category of concern
it remains a concern sir
okay um the the oig report
concludes that along with
the significant problems that you
identified
that you expressed unsupported
allegations against many of your
colleagues regarding perjury fabrication
and conspiracy
right do you take exception to that
finding you know any law enforcement
officer gets complaints all the time
i found myself in a position one day
where three different senior agents
senior excuse me scientists were telling
me that another individual had committed
perjury they wouldn't repeat those
allegations when i went forward with
them i
i can understand as embarrassing as this
is and as problematic is for anybody
that comes forward that people might not
come forward
have you made any unsupported
allegations
what i did sir was to bring forward
indications of misconduct
if i
if i made allegations
i had a lot of data
to go forward with them
but most often my letters if you ever
get a chance to read them if you haven't
say this seems to be what's going on but
i don't know i'm not an attorney
could you guys look at this and give me
some feedback because i can't get it in
the fbi
thank you
thank you mr webster mr hutchinson
thank you mr chairman i'll see if i can
just ask a couple of questions uh mr
whitehurst uh
mr alcorn indicated that he thought
there should be an independent
consideration given to uh
the
laboratory becoming under the auspices
of an independent agency what is your
view of that
sir i've seen that view
um
i was i'd like to go back to a period of
history where i saw something like this
happen before i was in vietnam for three
years and when the me lie incident broke
some unit commanders took the guns away
from their soldiers
forensic science is a tool of law
enforcement
we've got to have it in our hands there
just has to be oversight of what's going
on because the pressures on law
enforcement are extensive
you know in oklahoma city happens we
have got to find who did it
the pressure's there and it's reasonable
it's human
if you take that lab too far away from
the
law enforcement agencies
it's going to start doing things that
are not productive i think
with my experience i'd like to see the
labs remain with the law enforcement
agencies but i'd like to see very clear
oversight protocols developed and
validated that sort of thing
what you're saying makes a tremendous
amount of sense i mean investigative
responsibilities are critical and that
has to remain with the fbi or the law
enforcement agency at least it would
appear to me
are you satisfied with the accreditation
process that the fbi has agreed to under
the oig's recommendation
as a first step sir yes i am thank you
thank you mr hutchinson and thank you dr
whitehurst mr alcorn mr cohen we
appreciate very much you're coming to
testify today mr mr chairman if i could
just ask that the doj report uh
convicted by jury is exonerated by
science be made a part of the record of
the pursuit without objection it will so
be done mr alcorn thank you thank you
all very very much again for coming to
contribute today
our second panel consists of just one
witness but a very important witness
michael bromwich
who was confirmed as inspector general
of the department of justice in june of
1994
as such mr bromwich oversees the work of
approximately 360 employees nationwide
his office has brought authority to
conduct investigations into allegations
of employee misconduct against the 100
000 employees of the department of
justice its contractors and grant
recipients
from 1983 to 1987 mr bromwich was an
assistant united states attorney in new
york city prosecuting a number of
matters ranging from white-collar fraud
to narcotics trafficking from 1987 to
1989 he served as associate counsel in
the office of the independent council
investigating the iran contra matter
from 1989 to 1993 mr bromwich was
engaged in private practice specializing
in white-collar criminal defense work he
received his bachelor's degree a
master's degree in public policy and his
law degree from harvard university we
welcome you today mr bromwich uh as you
probably understand i'm swearing all the
witnesses today so if you'd stand and
raise your right hand i'd appreciate it
do you swear that the testimony you're
about to give shall be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth i
do sir thank you may be seated
you may proceed with your testimony
today uh your entire written testimony
will be entered into the record
without objection and you may summarize
any portion of it that you wish
please thank you thank you very much mr
chairman members of the subcommittee
thank you for inviting me to appear
before you today to testify about the
investigation conducted by my office
into allegations of wrongdoing and
improper practices within certain
sections of the fbi lab the complex and
technical subject matter the issues
under investigation made this
investigation one of the most difficult
ever undertaken by my office my
testimony today will briefly describe
the background and process of the
investigation outline our conclusions
and describe our recommendations for
changes at the fbi lab
in late 1993 and early 1994 my office
was conducting an audit of
the fbi laboratory forensic services in
the fbi lab when we became aware of
certain general allegations about
improper laboratory practices being made
by dr whitehurst a phd scientist
employed in the lab
these allegations were referred to the
investigations division of the oig which
conducted an initial preliminary
investigation
this preliminary inquiry discovered
evidence corroborating at least some of
dr whitehurst's allegations
at that point i decided that a much more
extensive investigation involving an
investment of significant resources was
warranted that happened in july of 1995.
it was clear to me that an investigation
of scientific practices required the
expertise of experienced forensic
scientists we conducted a search for
individuals with international
reputations who had expertise in the
relevant scientific fields and in the
operation of scientific labs
ultimately we were able to enlist the
services of five internationally
renowned scientists to consult with us
including mr nicholas cartwright the
officer in charge of the science and
technology branch of the royal canadian
mounted police
dr paul ferrara the director of the
division of forensic science for the
commonwealth of virginia
dr gerard murray the principal
scientific officer of the forensic
science agency of northern ireland
and one of the principal experts called
in on ira bombing cases mr douglas lucas
the retired director of the center of
forensic sciences of the province of
ontario and dr richard schwabel the
retired directory of the surety
assessment center of the sandia national
lab in albuquerque new mexico
these men spent countless hours
reviewing files interviewing witnesses
and reviewing and editing the oig's
investigative report
the department of justice the congress
and the american people owe them an
immense debt of gratitude for their
services in this matter
in addition to the scientists the
investigative team consisted of four
prosecutors of considerable experience
three of whom are assisting united
states attorneys and one of whom is a
trial attorney from the department's
criminal division
as well as oig investigators and support
staff
the most intensive phase of the
investigation took 18 months required
interviews of over 100 individuals many
of whom were interviewed more than once
and the review of over 60 000 pages of
documents
the result was a 517-page report
released publicly on april 15 1997
in which we detailed and analyzed the
evidence we found set forth our
conclusions and made recommendations for
changes in lab practices mr chairman if
i made departures for a moment from my
prepared statement i did hear the early
part of the hearing and i heard mr
alcorn state that it was the result of
the lawsuit filed by his organization
that the report was released on april
15th i can tell you mr chairman that
from the time we began uh our expanded
inquiry in the summer of 1995 it was
absolutely clear to me that this was to
be a report that had to be
publicly disseminated
because the issues raised were of such
extreme importance it was never my
intention nor the intention the attorney
general of the united states or the fbi
to keep the report secret
so that any suggestion that we had such
an intention is completely uh unfounded
sir could you pull the mic a little
closer i'm sorry sure
and and i think the mic is on but the
light doesn't appear to be you want to
double check to make sure it is oh
there's it wasn't maybe it wasn't
i thought it was i guess we were wrong i
have a loud voice so it may have
appeared to me thank you
in the report we examined 18 specific
cases including some of the most
significant prosecutions in the recent
history of the department such as the
oklahoma city bombing case the world
trade center bombing case the mail bomb
assassination of united states circuit
judge robert vance and the bombing
aboard an avianca airlines jet
despite the significance of these
prosecutions and the potential impact of
our investigation department officials
were supportive of this office and our
work on the investigation
after the completion of a draft report
in january the oig solicited comments
from the fbi and from prosecutors
primarily in the united states
attorney's offices and other lawyers who
handle the cases we examined to ensure
that no factual errors appeared in the
draft report
although we made some changes to the
report in response to those comments in
most cases we did not make requested
changes in the draft and we explained
our reasoning either in the final report
or in a separate appendix that was
publicly distributed that contains the
responses and our replies to those
responses
dr whitehurst ultimately submitted over
200 letters to the oig setting forth
allegations against many of his
colleagues in the lab as well as others
in the fbi
his allegations implicated some of the
most fundamental aspects of federal law
enforcement including the reliability of
the procedures employed by the lab to
analyze evidence the integrity of the
person's engaging in that analysis and
the objectivity of the testimony given
in cases by lab examiners
his allegations primarily concern
practices in three units of the fbi lab
the explosives unit the materials
analysis unit and the chemistry
toxicology unit
accordingly our investigation focused on
those three units although we did
consider the work of some personnel in
other units when we had specific
information
our investigation did not substantiate
the vast majority of the allegations dr
whitehurst made against lab examiners
most significantly the investigation did
not substantiate dr whitehurst's claims
that examiners had committed perjury and
fabricated evidence in various cases
however we did find deficient practices
in the lab and unprofessional conduct by
several examiners in a number of key
instances we found problems that dr
whitehurst had not raised but that were
discovered independently by our
investigative team
we found significant instances of
testimonial errors substandard
analytical work and deficient practices
in several cases we found instances of
examiners giving scientifically flawed
testimony that is testimony that relied
on speculation or collateral evidence to
reach conclusions rather than on
scientifically valid methods of analysis
for example in the case of united states
versus synapsis the fbi explosive
examiner reached his conclusion that
tools found in the defendant's home
contained residue of an explosive by
relying in part on collateral evidence
that was collected during a search of
the defendant's garbage
rather than conducting the appropriate
scientific tests of the tools themselves
we specifically concluded that the
examiner's work in the synagos case was
inadequate and unprofessional
in the case involving the bombing of an
avianca airlines jet we determined that
the fbi explosive examiner's testimony
regarding the type of bomb used was
based on a theory that was
scientifically unsound and beyond the
examiner's expertise
we found other instances of examiners
giving inaccurate testimony
in a hearing conducted by the
investigating committee of the judicial
council of the 11th circuit regarding
then-judge elsie hastings the lab
examiner testified falsely that he had
performed a certain scientific test when
in fact another examiner had performed a
test and he also testified inaccurately
regarding the results and the
significance of the test
in a death penalty case in florida
another examiner who was the chief of
the chemistry toxicology unit testified
inaccurately on several points including
testimony about tests he had performed
performed or the results of those tests
three explosives unit examiners altered
omitted or improperly supplemented some
of dr whitehurst internal reports as
they were being compiled into an
official report of the lab
some of these alterations or omissions
resulted in material changes to dr
whitehurst's conclusions
we also found instances of examiners
giving testimony beyond their expertise
insufficient documentation of test
results and an inadequate record
management system in the lab
although we found instances where
examiners gave inaccurate or misleading
testimony we did not conclude that any
examiner had committed perjury this was
not because the oig investigators did
not look for evidence of perjury indeed
all four attorneys leading the
investigation were experienced
prosecutors as am i
in the alc hastings matter for example
we determined that the examiner had
testified falsely
nonetheless after examining all of the
evidence we determined that there was
insufficient evidence from which to
conclude that the examiner in the
hastings matter or any examiner in the
other cases we looked at intentionally
lied or made a false statement while
under oath
we have however and this is important
referred the entire investigative report
to the public integrity section of the
criminal division for its review to
determine whether further investigation
or prosecution of any matter is
warranted
in addition to problems with specific
examiners we also noted numerous
management deficiencies the issues
arising out of the case of united states
versus synapsis illustrate not only the
failings of an individual examiner but
also systemic management failures
in 1989 an assistant united states
attorney wrote to the laboratory
strongly criticizing the conduct of the
explosives residue examiner who
testified for the government in the
synagos case
although the fbi conducted various
reviews of the examiner's work in 1989
1991 and 1995
the lab never adequately investigated or
resolved the concerns about the
examiner's work that were raised by the
sonakas prosecutor or by fbi scientists
who performed the later fbi reviews the
lab's inability to resolve in a timely
way
serious and credible allegations of
incompetence made against the examiner
allowed the problem to fester for almost
six years
other management lapses included an
inability to resolve scientific
disagreements among lab examiners a
failure to establish procedures and
protocols or to enforce existing ones
and a failure to establish a climate
in which meaningful peer reviews were
the norm
these management failures contributed
substantially to the types of examiner
problems that we documented in the
report
it is important not only to identify
problems but to prescribe solutions as
well we take that part of our mission
very seriously
we made numerous recommendations that we
believe will help the fbi lab move into
the next century
as an outstanding and world-leading
forensic lab
our first recommendation was one already
accepted by the fbi by the time we made
it that the lab pursue
prompt accreditation by the american
society of crime lab directors
laboratory accreditation board i know
you have a witness from that board
scheduled to testify in the panel after
me
the fbi's response to the oig draft
report acknowledged that quote the lab
could and should have sought
accreditation a decade ago unquote and
we commend the fbi for now making such
accreditation a top priority for the lab
although accreditation should not be
seen as a panacea for all the ills of
the lab the criteria used in the
accreditation process should promote
valuable and productive interchanges
with other labs as well as to assist the
lab in modernizing policies and
practices
we also recommended in our report
restructuring certain units in the lab
changing procedures for reporting
results of scientific analyses improving
case documentation practices developing
and implementing a coordinated training
program for examiners and monitoring
more closely the court testimony of
examiners the fbi has said that it
agrees with and intends to implement all
of these recommendations
the systemic recommendations that we
made in the report will help the lab
avoid in the future the problems we
encountered in the matters we had under
investigation
we also made recommendations with
respect to individuals based on our
review of their work and as part of the
organization and cultural changes that
should be undertaken by the fbi
these recommendations included
transferring certain examiners and
removing others from supervisory
responsibilities
the fbi has referred all matters
involving the discipline of agents
criticized in the report to the justice
management division of the department of
justice that is it will not be
undertaken by the fbi but by the justice
management division of the department of
justice
since the release of the report concerns
have been expressed about our
recommendations concerning dr whitehurst
and i'd like to address those just for a
moment
we concluded that dr whitehurst could no
longer effectively function in the lab
and recommended that the fbi consider
what role if any he could usefully serve
in other components of the fbi
i want to ensure you mr chairman and the
other members of this subcommittee that
our conclusion and recommendation were
not influenced in any way by any desire
to shoot the messenger
indeed my organization depends on
individuals like dr whitehurst coming
forward and providing information to us
nonetheless we are obligated to hold him
to the same standards by which we
evaluated other individuals in the lab
i can unequivocally say that it was dr
whiter's performance as a scientist and
the manner in which he made sweeping
unsubstantiated allegations against
numerous individuals that caused us to
draw the conclusions that we did
in assessing the fbi lab as a whole it
is important to bear in mind that we did
not review the entire lab or the work of
every examiner even in the units we did
look at
and consequently our findings should not
necessarily be applied to other units or
to all examiners in the lab
indeed we saw examples of superb work
and encountered lab personnel dedicated
to the highest traditions of forensic
science
our objective in the investigation was
not only to review and resolve dr
whitehurst's allegations in a fair and
impartial manner but also to identify
and comment on issues that should be
addressed by the lab to achieve
excellence in forensic science
we believe that full implementation of
these recommendations although requiring
a significant commitment of time effort
and resources will bring the fbi closer
to its goal of having one of the finest
scientific labs in the law enforcement
community in the international law
enforcement community
mr chairman that concludes my prepared
statement i have one other comment to
make based on
submitted printed testimony and then i'm
happy to answer any questions that you
or other members of the subcommittee may
have
mr chairman i i note that in
the prepared testimony filed by
mr cohn
on page 12 of
his letter that begins his submission
at article number at item number four he
says the following
one of the most disturbing revelations
contained in fbi release documents was
correspondence between the fbi and doj
ig
and the letter appears at exhibit 18.
they reveal a high level of cooperation
between the fbi and the ig
instead of the independence dr
whitehurst had expected from the ig the
ig and fbi had entered into a secret
deal in violation of their own operating
procedures to allow the fbi full access
to all of dr whiteheart's letters full
access to the interviews of fbi
employees and a co-equal role in writing
the final ig report although the only
the ig's name would be on the report
these agreements were reached behind dr
whitehurst back and had they been known
dr whitehurst would have ceased
cooperating with the ig
only the intense public pressure
resulting from the public attention
concerning the crime lab generated by
the public disclosure of dr whitehurst's
allegations during the o.j simpson
matter forced the ig to back off from
the agreements with the fbi
however the complete lack of written
procedures and the failure to institute
regulations required under the wpa
allowed this collusion to occur
virtually every statement in that
paragraph mr chairman is false or
materially misleading in fact there was
a time when my office was investigating
certain of dr whitehurst's allegations
and the fbi opr continued to investigate
some of dr whitehear's allegations you
will notice that the letter that appears
at exhibit 18 is dated i believe june of
1995.
that was at a time before the
corroborating evidence had been brought
to my attention which occurred in late
july
and before i sought to take over the
entire investigation what happened mr
chairman is when i found out about the
corroborating information
about dr whitehurst's claims under the
attorney general order that governs
jurisdiction involving my office fbi opr
and other internal uh misconduct
organizations within the department of
justice i went to the deputy attorney
general and said that i believed that we
needed to conduct the entire
investigation and that the investigative
results would not be credible if the fbi
did a part of the investigation
the deputy attorney general asked me to
talk directly with the director of the
fbi to find out whether he had any
opposition to my taking over the entire
investigation i met with director free
on august 2nd 1995
and i told him of my conversation with
the deputy attorney general and i asked
him whether he had any objection to our
taking over the entire investigation i
pointed out to him which he already knew
that some of dr whiter's allegations
were made against him personally in
connection with the van pac
investigation and the moody prosecution
director free agreed immediately agreed
that we that is the office of inspector
general should take over the entire
investigation although he offered any
support that the bureau could provide
from that point forward mr chairman it
was people under my leadership that
conducted the entire investigation the
lawyers the scientists the investigators
none of them was fbi personnel all of
them worked directly for me so the
suggestion that there was collusion
between my office and the fbi could not
be more false
thank you very much mr bromwich and we
will now go to a question period i think
you very accurately and technically walk
through that dating issue
i yield myself five minutes we'll try to
abide by the five-minute rule probably
only one round of questions because of
the time
so my panelists all understand that
first of all dr whitehurst has raised
allegations of misconduct on the part of
fbi director louis free
did you substantiate any of those
allegations mr brownwich no we did not
there were specific allegations against
director free in connection with his
role as a prosecutor in the van pac
investigation and the moody prosecution
we did not substantiate any of those
allegations your investigation as you
said has only concentrated on three of
the 35 units within the fbi laboratory
is there any way you can know from your
investigation whether or not the same
type of problems you found were limited
to just those three or whether they were
more broadly based no we can't tell
based on the work that we have done we
did focus on the three sections of the
lab because those were the only sections
of the lab for which we had specific
allegations i am comforted uh to a
substantial extent by the fact that the
accreditation process is going to be
going forward and going to be cool go
forward promptly i think that
accreditation process with what it
entails that is bringing in forensic
scientists from other labs to take a
comprehensive view of the lab not just
the three sections we looked at
but the many sections we didn't that if
there are such problems that exist in
those other sections the likely greater
likelihood is that they will surface do
you have the authority or the resources
to investigate all of the remaining
32
units or divisions of the laboratory
i don't have the resources to do it i
think i could get the authority to do it
as a as an expansion uh of this i
frankly don't view that as an optimal
use of either my resources or the
resources of the department of justice
we did a very intense review of these
three sections of the lab we made
certain systemic findings and
recommendations that we generalized to
the entire lab the fbi has embraced all
40 of those recommendations and i don't
believe that in the absence of specific
allegations i don't believe it is
appropriate for us or any other body to
go
running in right now and start throwing
around other sections
putting this into context your entire
report of course is highly critical of
those three units
putting it in context can you give us a
an evaluation uh
of the overall performance of the fbi
lab is this mean it's rotten to the core
does your report is that to be read that
way it certainly does our report does
not say or should it nor should it
suggest that the fbi lab is rotten to
the core far from it we believe it is a
good forensic lab as things stand now we
think that with the recommendations that
we have made that have been embraced by
the fbi and through going through the
very rigorous
accreditation process that a good lab
would will be made far better
in terms of the fbi's relationship with
your office this letter obviously was
disturbing even if it was dated in june
and even though your explanation has
been good about it where it says
subsequent to the conclusion of all
investigations our offices will
collaborate on a jointly prepared report
which will be written as an office of
the inspector general
document
i i find that to be
somewhat offensive even if it is true
which it is i know that you went on and
became very independent in your work
product after that i find it offensive
too mr chairman i was not aware of that
letter uh and had i been made aware of
it i would have immediately instructed
the fbi that that is not the way we were
going to proceed and the other question
i have has to do with the office of
professional responsibility do you
believe that you have
sufficient
opportunities to do the external review
of the fbi generally that you would like
to do or that should be done or do we
defer all too often to the office of
professional responsibility to do it i
have a view mr chairman that i've stated
publicly before and that i'll state
publicly again that with respect to
powerful public institutions like the
fbi that play major roles in our
national life
that it is important to have external
review and i think that means external
review by the congress but it also means
external branch external review and we
are the entity best situated to do that
given the current configuration of the
entities within the department that do
internal misconduct matters we do very
little
investigation into allegations of
misconduct against fbi personnel frankly
i don't have the resources to do it even
if the jurisdictional order is read
differently than they do you believe you
should have the resources and should
have jurisdiction would be better
government yes i think so um the fbi has
stated it doesn't believe that
full-scale external inspections of
segments of the lab should be done at
five year intervals because it would
unduly interrupt lab operations do you
agree or disagree i i disagree with that
and i'm not sure that is still their
position given their commitment to the
accreditation process and the periodic
reviews that that accreditation process
requires
um
last question i have for you there's
been some raising of the question of the
alcie hasting congressman hastings
situation uh did you explore that uh in
context of this did that hair
fiber unit and mr malone and all the
questions raised by the wall street
journal piece get covered by your work
product or is that something beyond the
scope of what you did can you i just
want you to explain to me what you did
and didn't do with the hastings matter
that's fine uh the hastings allegation
uh we did investigate and we
investigated fully and it is presented
fully in our report
we were not aware of the other
allegations against mr malone until the
wall street journal article which i
believe was either published the day
after or two days after our report was
published we had no knowledge of those
matters
and therefore we did not investigate
them so all
all that we looked at in terms of mr
malone was the one allegation that we
had in the hastings case which we did
investigate fully and we did find that
mr malone engaged in misconduct and you
did not do a thorough review then of
that unit that was the fourth unit
referred to by dr whitehurst that's
correct we did not do really any review
of that unit other than the review
entailed in pursuing that particular
allegation do you have any plans to do
further reviews or requests to do them
we don't right now um
again my my view is that it we would be
all be better served by allowing the
bureau to try to seek as rapidly as
possible the implementation
of our recommendations and to seek
prompt accreditation by
askglad
if in the course of any of those reviews
there are specific allegations and
warrant investigation i would certainly
give serious consideration to doing so
lastly because i don't want to come
around for another round of questions on
april 14th just one day before your
report was released as was indicated in
the testimony just before us president
clinton directed the attorney general to
establish appropriate processes within
the department of justice to quote carry
out the functions unquote vested in the
president in the whistleblower
protection act of 1989. the question is
why didn't the department of justice
establish these procedures before this
point i don't know the answer to that mr
chairman all right thank you very much
thank you mr bronwich miss jackson lee
you're recognized for five minutes
thank you very much um and thank you for
your testimony can you tell me why so
long as i understand dr whitehurst's
testimony
these
issues of concern he raised starting in
1986
and as i understand your investigation
begun in what 94-95
so why did it take so long for the
involvement of the oig in this issue we
didn't exist until the spring of 1989.
my office was created through the
inspector general act amendments of 1988
and my organization opened its doors in
the spring of 1989.
uh we still
still my question is why so long
we don't have we have very limited
jurisdiction as i tried to indicate in
my responses to the chairman's question
to investigate
internal misconduct matters within the
fbi and and the the the answer is that
we
i'm not aware that anybody in my
organization had knowledge of dr
whitehurst's allegations until they
surfaced
in the course of our forensic services
audit in 1993 i don't think dr
whiteheart suggests that he or anyone
else brought those allegations to our
attention before
late 1993 early 1994. and in your
opinion or your assessment would there
not been anyone else in department of
justice that could have appropriately
investigated
um this matter
in as much as your doors opened about
1989 would there have been
any other procedures that could have
been utilized to get this information
forward and to have the least amount of
damage on the justice system that we now
uh are are facing at this point
there has been since 1974 an office of
professional responsibility within the
department of justice separate and apart
from fbi's internal office of
professional responsibility and some
matters over the years have been
undertaken by that office of
professional responsibility
frequently in tandem with the fbi's
office of professional responsibility
doj's opr does not have its own
investigating agents
and therefore must rely on fbi agents my
situation is very different i've got my
own agents
why um
i guess what i'm trying to determine is
where we might have corrected it from
that perspective is that to investigate
it uh earlier
uh and possibly uh why didn't opr find
out about it and be able to provide
assistance
i can't answer that question
congresswoman i'm sorry in your report
you mentioned uh several several points
if i might recount them that the
lab was determined to have had
scientifically flawed and inaccurate
testimony
or maybe those participating land
outright fabrication of test results
inadequate or non-existent
record-keeping and test result
documentation and failure by management
to resolve serious and credible
allegations of incompetence
in
a
note or a paragraph that you make in
citing
mr hastings situation
you note in particular
that there was no if i have it correctly
intentionally no one intentionally lied
or made false statements under oath
um
just moving beyond those facts
circumstances
even if
one did not lie intentionally or make
false statements under oath
there is still the potential for damage
to existing cases and so that minor
clarification does not in any way
take away from the seriousness of the
impact on some of the cases that might
have uh been tainted by these uh
investigations that's entirely correct
and is that clear in your report because
i i see the qualify of your statement
and um being that your report is very
extensive i'm not sure whether you also
qualified it in the report i think we do
make it clear in the report if it's
insufficiently clear i i aim to make it
clear now what we do not seek to do in
the report is to try to assess the
particular damage that may have been
done within the context of the specific
cases that we've examined that's not
something that we should be doing and
frankly given the extensive trial
records that
exist in many of these cases
i don't think it's something we could
have done
so what we aim to do was to investigate
as thoroughly as possible the specific
misconduct allegations against the
individuals and to
say as straight as we possibly could
what our findings were on them but we do
not seek to minimize our findings i
think that the findings in here are very
powerful and very critical of many
aspects of the work that was done well
first of all i think it's very important
that you raise the issue of the
accreditation and i appreciate that but
i wanted to make sure that we clarified
uh that just that very finite
distinction on the oath there is still
damage let me um follow up by
also
uh commenting on your statements
regarding dr whitehurst
and i'm not even going to suggest i
think they were you're tempted to
politely and this is in your testimony
couch them in polite terms but
i would beg to differ and
believe that you have in fact killed the
messenger
um you're suggesting that um
there was a level of incompetence on the
part of dr whitehurst and correct me if
i'm wrong uh that he can no longer
effectively function in the laboratory
uh and uh that you recommended that he
be put in another role in responsibility
that really concerns me and i'd also
like to ask as to whether or not
you looked at the fact that the
whistleblower act was not implemented
and seemingly could not protect dr
whitehurst was that part of your report
uh as well but but i'm very concerned
about uh statements made by dr
whitehurst let me try even with the
light on i'd like to give her as full an
answer as i possibly can we did not look
at the whistleblower protection act
aspect of this but let me turn to your
uh other concerns
we tried to be as balanced as we could
and we we are at some pains in our
report to specifically credit dr
whitehurst for his courage his
perseverance and his tenacity
in continuing to bring these allegations
to the attention of people within the
fbi for years and then ultimately to us
i think he deserves a tremendous amount
of credit for that i don't think that
giving him that credit ought to
disassemble our critical faculties and
prevent us from
properly evaluating both dr whitehurst's
own scientific work
and the allegations that he made against
his colleagues he in essence accused his
colleagues in the lab of being criminals
perjurers
fabricators of evidence
fabricators of testimony obstructors of
justice
suppressor suppressors or of exculpatory
material
it is one thing to bring factual matters
to the attention of an entity like mine
and that is what we credit dr whitehurst
for doing
but the labels that he attached to them
and the terms in which he condemned his
colleagues are just without any
evidentiary support the people in the
lab because they were interviewed
because there's a grapevine of knowledge
in the lab they know what dr whitehurst
has said about that
they know that he has accused them of
being criminals
when we see those allegations and we
made our findings that none of those
allegations
was supported
that is what led us to the view that dr
whitehurst could not effectively
function in the lab any longer dr
whitehurst admits
that as a result of his allegations
there are substantial or were
substantial tensions when he was still
in the lab between him and other
examiners so it was from that
perspective a discomfort because of the
accusations being made that he had that
that you made this conclusion yes thank
you thank you miss jackson lee mr barr
you're recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
uh mr bromwich i know that uh
the the work that brings you here today
concerns primarily
the uh or maybe exclusively the
allegations uh by mr whitehurst and and
these concerned i think
three components of the fbi lab the
explosives unit the materials analysis
unit and the chem toxicology unit and
you've gone through both in your verbal
testimony and in your written testimony
some specific
matters that you've looked into with
regard to specific cases
this subcommittee currently has
scheduled for a week from today some
additional hearings
focusing specific on specifically on the
centennial olympic bombing case in
atlanta during the course of your review
of the allegations in this case
have you come across anything either
directly or indirectly that would
indicate problems with regard to the
investigation thus far
in the centennial bombing case no we
have not okay
just so you know mr barr i actually met
within the last two weeks with the
current u.s attorney for the northern
district of georgia i know the office
you used to hold mr alexander who sought
my advice and suggestions on how to deal
with various issues relating to forensic
science in the lab so i my impression is
that he's being extremely responsible in
trying to make sure that the work that's
done in that case in the olympic park
bombing case
does not suffer from some of the same
infirmities that we discovered in the
cases that we reviewed good thank you
now i know you
you have no vested interest in in the
the bureaucracy at the crime lab or its
structure or or
uh it's functioning
uh with that in mind uh let me ask you
the following question uh the most
serious findings of misconduct seem to
have occurred within the explosives unit
at the lab
and you recommend a significant
restructuring of the explosives unit
including transferring its
responsibility for crime scene
management to components outside the
scientific analysis section at the lab
have you given any consideration and do
you have any opinion on a different
approach and that would be to
transfer it to another federal agency
such as fbi atf
the lead or perhaps exclusive
jurisdiction as a federal agency to
investigate cases in which explosives
have been used or appear to have been
used mr barr we didn't consider that our
focus was limited to the fbi lab i
believe that with the implementation of
the recommendations that we've made and
with the accreditation process there is
no reason to believe the fbi cannot do
the kind of work and explosives that it
has done in the past i don't have a view
on whether it's a good policy judgment
to make such a transfer but i don't see
any need for it
based on what we were viewed and just to
underscore the obvious we didn't look at
atf's lab in our investigation at all
okay
[Applause]
in addition to the failings of specific
examiners
you also find that there were systemic
management failures that affected the
work performed in the three units
explosives materials analysis and chem
toxicology
wouldn't these same management problems
have affected the work of the other
units within the same section of the lab
or within the entire lab division uh
that's a good question there's not a
simple answer to that we think that
flaws like an inadequate case management
system improper documentation of reports
may carry over to other sections of the
lab we just don't know because we didn't
look at those and frankly that is why we
couched our recommendations in more
general terms because we had a sense
that if we found for exa for example
poor record management uh retention
policies poor case management and so
forth that that was more than likely not
just limited to those three sections of
the lab but might exist lab wide and
that's why we really exceeded uh the
scope of the three sections when we came
to make our systemic recommendations
those recommendations have been made as
to the entire lab and they have been
embraced by the fbi as to the entire lab
okay thank you
thank you mr barr mr webster you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman um
mr bromwich i certainly respect your
integrity and the effort that you and
and those who joined with you uh put
forth with respect to the preparation of
this report thank you i'm i'm troubled
however by what i think i understand the
logic to be and
in some of the conclusions and and also
troubled with respect to
what may have been an incomplete
response because you didn't have time to
to
miss jackson lee's question
let me quote the report
as it relates to dr whitehurst most
significantly i quote the investigation
did not substantiate dr whitehurst
claims that examiners had committed
perjury and fabricated evidence
going down to the next paragraph i quote
we found significant instances of
testimonial errors substandard
analytical work and deficient practices
then i quote again the following page
the conclusion that three executive unit
examiners altered omitted or improperly
supplemented some of dr whitehurst
internal reports as they were being
compiled into an official report of the
laboratory some of these alterations or
omissions resulted in material changes
to dr whitehurst conclusions
with all due respect let's go back to
the first sentence
the investigation did not substantiate
dr whitehurst claims that examiners had
committed perjury and fabricated
evidence
what is
improperly supplementing reports what is
omissions what are altercations that do
not do not then amount to fabricating
evidence as you know mr wechsler perjury
is a crime and that is the crime of
lying under oath with the intent to lie
under oath it is not a matter of
misstating evidence uh by mistake it is
not a matter because of lack of
scientific knowledge or sophistication
going beyond the bounds of your
expertise it is flat out lying making
statements uh that say a when you know
not a is true or when you know b is true
so there is i don't believe with all due
respect any inconsistency between our
saying that we found no perjury and no
fabrication of testimony while at the
same time making very specific and
pointed criticisms of the conduct that
was engaged in by a number of examiners
in the lab and we chose those words
carefully both in what we said our proof
didn't support and in what we said they
do support
i took very keen notice of the
distinction between
uh what may be
the proof required for establishing
perjury and what i thought
and maybe i misunderstood the sentence
fabricating evidence is is fabricating
fabricating evidence of specific crime
pardon me this fabrication of evidence a
specific crime no but it would
constitute obstruction of justice okay
and and am i not reading the sentence
correctly it says did not substantiate
dr whitehurst claims that examiners had
committed perjury i understand your
conclusion with respect to perjury but
the second part of the sentence quite
damning as it is to dr whitehurst and
fabricated evidence we did not find that
examiners in the lab quote fabricated
evidence
unquote
and i assume that to be the case because
these reports that were altered omitted
or improperly supplemented so
supplemented were not then used as
evidence
it's two things either they were not
used as evidence or the the changes
to fabricating evidence as i said it
constitutes the crime of obstruction of
justice and again you require the
element of intent did this person by
this conduct mean in fact
to
make up evidence as opposed maybe even
unconsciously to stretching the limits
of what the science permits if i may
then you you you
seem to get quite agitated uh with
respect to dr whitehurst's assertions
with respect to certain members of the
fbi that they in fact engaged in
criminal behavior what were the motives
then of the unit examiners as they
fabricated altered and modified his
reports what were their motives i don't
know what their motives were sir but
you've concluded that it wasn't an
intentional motive we found no evidence
that they intentionally
that they they made the changes or
alterations they did with the specific
intent necessary to make them guilty of
obstruction of justice or perjury
[Music]
what
if their intent
wasn't criminal then what legitimate law
enforcement purpose would there be to
alter
omit
or supplement someone's report what a
number of the witnesses said mr wexler
was that the dictations or that is the
preliminary reports that they got from
dr whiters were unreadable or incoherent
and so they changed them now we didn't
take those claims at face value and the
changes tended to be of a particular
sort
but but it doesn't support the
suggestion that that you're making
well you use the if i may mr chairman um
you use the adjective material changes
not just changes material changes and
the specific kinds of changes that we
have in mind were from saying that that
a the discovery of
a substance was consistent with
a chemical or a compound to
the evidence was identified as something
so that is what we view as a material
difference and we admit we stated it as
material because we didn't think it was
appropriate to minimize what they'd done
it still doesn't amount to a crime last
question all of these uh changes that
were made because they apparently
couldn't uh decipher dr whitehurst right
i apologize if i mischaracterized your
your statement but did you ever find any
of those changes made to disfavor the
prosecution's position
we we did not to my recollection so
these changes always happen to favor the
prosecution's position i i think that's
right i think there was one exception
with all due respect
isn't that a little coincidental
uh
we unders
the report was written doesn't that get
to the motive of the person doing it
it suggests things about motives of the
person doing it and i don't deny for a
moment that there may have been
pressures within the lab
to
push evidence to the limits that's
that's a that's that's something that we
discussed
at great length in the report
uh i i am reminded that
not all of the changes favored the
prosecution some of the issues that we
discussed were very technically complex
and i think my statement agreeing with
your suggestion that they all favored uh
the prosecution was was somewhat too
facile
okay thank you
okay i thank the gentleman from from
florida uh the gentleman from alabama mr
hutch mr hutcherson is recognized
thank you arkansas
going to uh your re report
mr brown which
ron which i want to refer to a page four
and you don't you can recall your
testimony but in one place you indicated
that after the draft report
was made in january that you solicited
comments from the fbi and from
prosecutors
and also other lawyers who handled cases
did this include defense attorneys that
you solicited input from on the
evaluation of the crime laboratory it
did not by and large mr hutcherson
because we were interested in people who
had had firsthand contact with the
people who had conducted the science i
think the one exception to that is that
we did with respect to the hastings
matter uh speak with both mr hastings
himself and his
counsel i think it's mr anderson terry
anderson uh so that was the one
exception to it but by and large we did
not talk to defense counsel
in your discussions with the prosecutors
i assume most of these were assistant
united states attorneys
uh
was were there
uh
information they provided to you
generally supportive they were critical
of your draft report or what was their
reaction to your dream
they submitted actually it's a matter of
public record we we published a separate
volume of the responses the written
responses that we got
from the prosecutors and the other
lawyers who were involved in the the
cases that we examined and then we in
the same volume we published our reply
to those responses and there really was
very little if any uh interaction
between my office and theirs other than
what's on paper in general i in general
they took issue with some of the factual
assertions that we made in
our report sometimes based on their more
detailed knowledge of the record of
their cases uh sometimes we just uh
agreed to disagree with them i would
think that if you
uh contact the united states attorney's
office and ask them you know what kind
of job and what experience have you had
with the fbi crime laboratory that they
would generally be very supportive and
say that by and large
99 of the time they do excellent work
and and so on is that the kind of
response you got or not we did it on the
basis of specific cases i can tell you
from my own experience as a prosecutor
that that certainly was the general view
in my office of the people from the fbi
lab who we got to testify as our
witnesses we had a very high collective
regard for uh their abilities and and
and the work that they did
and that has been my experience as well
uh you don't know my background but i
was a united states attorney
uh also in your report you referred to
different instances in which
various
lab experts gave inaccurate testimony
and you
cited a number of specific examples
one of them in the
case in which
they included collateral evidence that
they should not have examined
and one of them was
improperly supplementing some of the
reports
in any of these instances did you find
examples of where a supervisor would
have pressured
a witness
or
an examiner that might have influenced
their testimony we didn't find that
right and so it was sort of a self
motivation among the examiners and the
and as they testified that they simply
went a little bit too far
and
made conclusions they should not have
made that that's generally what we found
yes but you didn't found no examples of
where a supervisor would have told them
to do this or pressure them to do this
we did not did you ever find an example
of an assistant united states attorney
ever pressuring a an examiner to
alter the testimony we did not
now
lastly
in your report you talked about the fbi
had agreed to
pursue accreditation with the american
society of crime laboratory directors
and i was just curious why has this
never been done before
it's a good question and i think it's
probably a complicated answer and i know
that you have two people from the fbi
they could probably give a fuller answer
than i'm able to give interestingly
the fbi has participated since the
inception of ass clad in various aspects
of its activities and yet for i think
the 18 years that it has been in
existence it made no move to seek
accreditation i think that may be part
of the culture of the fbi that uh if i
may say historically has resisted
external review but i think you can get
a fuller answer from the fbi witnesses
who follow me is this the best
accreditation board that we could pursue
accreditation with i think it is it is
the best one that i know of i don't
claim extensive knowledge but but i do
know enough to know that it is a very
thorough accreditation process and one
that should give the congress and the
american people confidence assuming the
fbi lab is in fact accredited thank you
thank you mr chairman
the gentleman from north carolina mr
colbert was recognized for five minutes
like the chair mr bronwich i apologize
to you i had to be at other meetings
while you were testifying and i have not
yet mastered being at three places
simultaneously so with your permission
i'm going to revisit an issue
uh uttered and raised when mr dr
whitehurst was with us
uh it is my belief
mr broadway that there's probably not a
single federal agency
in existence that is not guilty of
reckless spending
it is my further because they're
spending money that belongs to others
except my agency
you may be the lone exception mr bravos
but but the point is they're spending
money that belongs to others i can spend
your money you can spend mine that's the
premise i can't prove it scientifically
but common sense tells me that
common sense furthermore tells me
that there would be more whistleblowers
who could step forward and probably res
their testimony would probably result in
reduced reckless spending
but for the fact
they fear retaliation
now it is my belief i continue
by saying to you that i believe every
whistleblower who has come forward
probably
has felt the painful
imposition of retaliation one way or
another
now mr brownwick you may not be able to
but can you confirm or reject
my conclusion
i can reject it in part because we
looked very closely at dr whiteheart's
specific allegations of retaliatory
measures that were taken against him
from 1989 through
1995 and we
determined that there were good
insufficient reasons for
the various steps that had been taken
such that we did not believe it
constituted retaliation now i do believe
that the fear
and threat of retaliation do discourage
whistleblowers from coming forward
that's why we consider
the well-being of whistleblowers to be a
very important one my organization and
other inspectors general rely on that
kind of information
but we don't assume it
and when we have specific allegations of
it we do our very best within our scarce
resources to in fact investigate those
claims if you examine the lengthy
chapter we have in our report that
focused specifically on dr whitehurst's
allegations of retaliation i think
you'll see that we did not
simply give them the back of our hand
far from it we subjected them to very
close and extended scrutiny
i want to revisit that issue my friend
from florida raised and prior to mr
webster's having raised it the chairman
himself
also from florida got into this
the chairman
that i'm paraphrasing now he was
concerned perhaps that the lab
may have just been a mere extension of
the u.s attorney's office you know here
we got this guy here he's accused of a b
and c
a let's nail him a mr lab you do your
work get it back to us as quickly as you
can
mr wechsler has more or less
uh charted that same course and and and
sir if there's any truth to this that
greatly disturbs me
now i'm not i'm not here mr chairman to
defend
guilty defendants
i want to nail them
but if there's a defendant who is in
fact not guilty i don't want him nailed
as a result of inaccurate
uh and imperfect uh
documentation that comes as i said
before that comes down from mount
olympus as though it's impeccable don't
dare you don't dare challenge that now
am i some screwball
off the wall with these sort of concerns
uh no you're not uh but as i was afraid
you might say yes
but as i responded to mr hutchinson's
more specific questions we did not find
certainly any overt nor really even any
subtle pressure that was imposed by
prosecutors that the testimony of fbi
examiners be slanted in a particular way
i heard in the panel that preceded me
some back and forth about
possible cultural pressures that exist
within the lab because of its
association with a law enforcement
agency that's a lot more
subtle but still very important and i
don't think we can
rule out of hand that those pressures in
fact
have existed historically indeed mr
matic who's a witness on the panel that
follows me has acknowledged that that is
a tension within a law enforcement
agency like the fbi when it has a
forensic
laboratory associated with it i think
that what that requires then is extra
special effort by
laboratory management supervisors and
examiners in the lab to make sure that
their analysis is absolutely right down
the middle
in every case and to do everything that
they possibly can to make sure that no
external influences that may tilt them
in favor of conviction
take hold and affect either the
preparation of reports or the
presentation
of testimony i share your concern about
the possibility of slanting testimony
and therefore of convicting defendants
improperly i was a defense lawyer for
four years so i've seen this from both
sides of the street
so i think there may be cultural
pressures but the kind of overt
pressuring or muscling that you are
suggesting we did not find well i thank
you mr broadway mr chairman i think
there's no i don't think we can emphasis
to emphasize too strongly the importance
of objectivity
as these tests are conducted and as you
know this is our first lag on what may
well be a long journey and i hope it
will be illuminating thank you so thank
you mr bosh thank you service thank you
and for the for the record the chair
would like to also go on on record that
uh it does not find the gentleman from
north carolina's ideas and notions to be
screwball either and i thank the
chairman for that thank you the
gentleman from ohio mr shabbat is
recognized for five minutes chairman
i'll keep my remarks relatively brief we
have i have another hearing that was
going on at the same time as this one so
i'm trying to cover two hearings at the
same time here um the first question i
wanted to ask you is that in the
in the
report that your office did
you recommended that several fbi
employees be removed from their
positions in the fbi lab
and has that taken place
at this time and are you satisfied with
the results there were temporary
measures that were taken after our draft
report was issued any final decisions on
personnel moves will be ultimately
decided
not by the fbi but by the justice
management division of the department of
justice i don't know how long that
process will take but it'll be a process
where the results are made known
publicly
okay thank you
mr whitehurst this morning in his
testimony
made some if true some very disturbing
allegations and just to make sure that
i'm
perfectly
consistent with what he said at that
time i wanted to read a couple of things
he said here to you
he said that among the problems that he
witnessed at the at the fbi
he said there was fabrication and
misrepresentation of data
that there was pressure on scientists to
change the contents of reports in order
to bolster a prosecutor's
case uh and then he went on and said
things of that
same ilk in in different language
it's my understanding that you feel that
his statements in that area uh are not
accurate uh is is that true that's
correct okay and would you tell us why
it is that you have that feeling that
his
allegations about
fabrication of data and reports being
changed in order to bolster a
prosecutor's case because out of bounds
because in every
specific instance in which mr whitehurst
alleged that that had happened
through an exhaustive
review of the relevant documents and
detailed interviews using those
documents with the specific individuals
who were involved in the particular case
in the context of which the allegations
were made we did not find that that
happened okay
okay that's somewhat reassuring uh
obviously
as i mentioned before
i think most americans certainly when
you think of the fbi crime lab and the
number of cases that it's been used
uh in very important cases oftentimes
over the years
you know you would hope
that this type of behavior
never occurs or certainly that it's
it's not a very common thing and i'm
it's it's reassuring that uh in your
report
that this wasn't found to be rampant or
really in existence i certainly shared
your view but but as you well know our
report is extremely critical i mean this
is a report uh for which there really is
no precedent with respect to the fbi lab
and frankly i don't know
whether there's any precedent for any
other law enforcement or part of a law
enforcement agency so
this is a very critical report but
we felt a
duty and obligation to make sure that
particularly with respect to the
most extreme allegations that is those
alleging fabrication of evidence
suppression of exculpatory material
perjury and so forth that we subjected
the allegations to the cold test of of
evidence and we did not find evidence to
support those claims okay thank you mr
whitehurst had also
testified this morning that he felt that
there were although he couldn't put a
number on it a significant number
of cases uh that might have been
jeopardized by the content the the
activities that he alleged
um the uh mr alcorn of course
uh
is the council for the national
association of criminal defense lawyers
and so that certainly would tell you
uh where he's coming from on on the
issue but he said that he thought there
were hundreds or perhaps thousands
of of cases that may be in jeopardy uh
could be appealed
as a result of of the allegations
contained would you comment on that
there certainly will be a huge number of
cases that are challenged and in which
new trial motions will be made that's a
far cry from meaning that in fact the
convictions will be overturned i mean i
believe that there is growing up right
now a mini cottage industry among
defense lawyers to make as a routine
basis with respect to people already
convicted claims that the conviction
arrests in crucial part on the evidence
and the testimony that come out of the
crime lab now i predict i think it's a
safe prediction that the lion's share of
those will not even relate to any of the
three sections
that we looked at it'll relate to latent
fingerprints it'll relate to dna it will
relate to other sections in the lab that
we didn't examine so i think that mr
alcorn is correct to suggest that there
will be
many many many challenges that are made
that is not to say that there will be
lots of cases uh that will be overturned
i think if we're going to be honest uh
with each other nobody knows the answer
to that uh that that would be pure
guesswork on anybody's part the light is
telling me i'm out of time if i could
just uh mr chairman just have an
additional 30 seconds here that
objection the gentleman is recognized
for an additional minute okay i thank
you
um and
i guess the the thing that that i keep
thinking about this this whole matter
with respect to the hundreds or perhaps
thousands of cases
that could be appealed if they're
if there are
innocent people
uh that that have been
unjustly accused we certainly want to
know that
i'm sure everybody wants to know that
and and we want justice to be done on
the other hand
uh one can fathom that we're talking
about millions and millions of dollars
if you're talking about hundreds or
thousands of cases
uh being appealed when you consider the
government attorney's time involved
oftentimes these defendants are indigent
and therefore
the taxpayers are also paying for their
legal counsel the defense counsels in
this case the court's time
uh so
it's uh
those of us that are very concerned
about trying to balance the budget keep
the cost of government within reason
uh
it it's it's particularly disturbing to
think that we may be looking at hundreds
or thousands of cases and and hopefully
there aren't
innocent people behind bars or the
number is extremely small uh but these
hearings are important to make sure that
uh that
our citizens of this country are
satisfied that justice is being done
thank you chairman
thank you uh without objection the uh oh
did the uh distinguished ranking member
have uh questions good night the ranking
member the uh honorable mr conyers is
recognized for five minutes
good morning mr bromwich good morning mr
conyers
um
are things uh
okay
not so good
or terrible
um if those are my three choices i would
say that in the three sections of the
lab that we looked at they were not so
good
what happened to uh
the laboratory examiner
who test testified falsely
in the judge alcy hastings matter
uh i am not aware that anything has
happened to him sir
well isn't that
well i thought that would be in within
your
jurisdiction let me clarify that it's
not we we do not have the responsibility
to
impose discipline on any other part of
the department of justice whether it be
fbi employee or a dea employee or i
didn't suggest that you did
i'm sorry i must have misunderstood um
i i know that i know the inspector
general's
responsibilities are pervasive and but
not that wide
um well what what happened to him i mean
it it's a matter that you you bring to
our attention right and we congratulate
you for that right okay now it's been
brought to our attention
uh so that's it
now that that's not it we've referred
our entire entire report
to the public integrity section of the
criminal division to determine whether
any criminal charges can be brought
against mr malone the examiner in that
case or anybody else who is discussed in
in the course of our 517-page report in
addition to that there will be
a disciplinary process disciplinary
process that
i think you you might well expect mr
malone to be subjected to that will be
carried out by the justice management
division of the department of justice
all disciplinary matters have been
taken away or moved away from the bureau
and will be handled by the justice
management division of the department of
justice i see
now this occurred what over five years
ago
the
the false testimony i happened longer
ago than that happened 12 years ago
happened in 1985 okay
more than twice as long
uh
has any disposition been reached on it
yet i'm sorry has any disposition been
reached on it yet
no
to my knowledge no disposition has been
reached on and in fact we were in our
report extremely critical of senior
managers in the lab for having
failed in our judgment utterly to deal
with what was a very serious allegation
so
12 years later we don't
we don't know what's happened and
i guess it's uh
on our watch to
to follow up now i think we do know what
happened we found that mr malone
testified falsely in the 1985 hearing uh
have disciplinary steps been taken
against him no they have not but our
report is out there and i think it is
fairly
clear what our conclusions are as to his
conduct and we find that he engaged in
very substantial misconduct
was he under oath when he testified uh i
don't know i believe he was but let me
let me provide you with an answer uh in
writing to be 100 sure well that that
that would be helpful
so
well let me ask you is mr malone still
on his post
my understanding is that he is but i
don't know what
uh recent steps may have been taken by
the fbi in response to uh our report i
just don't know the answer to that mr
conyers
at the time at the time that the report
was released it was my understanding
that he was no longer in the lab but he
was a working agent in one of the fbi's
field offices that's all i know
well um
let's see who's
within whose range of assignments and
the federal government
is it to
determine when we find something
as unconscionable as this
among us
in a
happening from a sworn agent
whose job is it
in your view to see that 12 years don't
elapse before we finally
if ever do anything about it i think
that the blame for
what went wrong in the malone matter
lies squarely at the door of the fbi
well i don't doubt i don't think anybody
will argue with that but
but 12 years goes by 13 years go by 14
15 16 17
uh
isn't there somewhere along the line
somewhere in in our duties and yours and
the integrity section and the department
of justice and janet reno
and the white house isn't there
somebody's job to say
this terrible matter that we all know
about that happened
and the office the agent was under oath
and it was awful and
blah blah blah
doesn't somewhere along the line in this
whole thing somebody says well yeah but
what do we do about it we we belatedly
mr conyers we when we had the allegation
brought to our attention
in the midst of our investigation we
think we did what we could do which is
to
investigate the allegations thoroughly
and to do what i think it was our
responsibility to do which is in a
public report
to specifically
describe what we found which is not in
any way shape or form
complementary of mr malone or anybody in
the fbi we are sharply critical of mr
malone and all the people in his chain
of command who failed to do anything
about this and failed to give the
information to anyone outside the fbi so
we have done something about it was it
belated you bet it was but our action
was not belated as soon as we found out
about it we investigated it to death
well i guess it's uh it's on
i've tried to push this into your box
and you pushed it pretty effectively
into mind i guess it's up to us now to
uh
figure out what we do about it and by
the way all these other incidents that
you've reported which are pretty
numerous i understand
about how many are they
uh could i have a an additional minute
mr chairman that objection uh the
gentleman is uh allowed an additional
minute
how how many uh how many transgressions
have you brought to uh
public attention and the judiciary
committee in particular
that are encompassed in your report
there are scores of no score findings i
i don't have an exact number for you
congressman
is the question
did we not do it before no okay no the
the question is this sir
how many
instances
of
potential violations of duty
perhaps
law have taken
that have occurred that you have noted
you and your group have noted and put in
the report it's a large number all those
that we found we put in the report there
was nothing kept out of the report yes
i know that there's i don't i don't have
a specific number i could go through the
text of the report and count them up and
i'll be happy to submit that to you well
okay that that's good now but let's just
you and i talking
between us in the room up on the hill uh
was it a hundred or a thousand
it was not in terms of findings of
improper practices or procedures no it
was not even a hundred it certainly was
not anywhere approaching a thousand
okay
so we're under a hundred
right was it more than 25 yes it was
more than 25 okay
could it have been 50 it could have been
50.
all right
well thank you very much you you of
course offer to stay in touch with the
committee as as we try to work through
this
absolutely mr conyers because it may
require us meeting not in a formal
hearing
you know to pursue some of these matters
in greater detail absolutely i think
it's important you probably know this
but let me just let me just say so
we have a very limited
oversight role over the fbi they have
their own internal
opr and it is only in the extraordinary
circumstance that we can go to the
deputy attorney general and get the
ability to investigate misconduct
allegations in the fbi that's what i did
in this case i congratulate you for that
thank you thank you mr chairman okay
thank you mr conyers the gentleman from
florida has asked for unanimous consent
for an additional three minutes and he
is therefore recognized for three
minutes mr westler thank you mr chairman
for your indulge indulgence mr bromwich
if i may again back to the report
um the finding was some and i believe
the operative word was some of dr
whitehurst's internal reports were
altered emitted or improperly
supplemented how many other people's
internal reports did you find were
altered omitted or improperly
supplemented my memory is that there was
at least one other examiner who did
similar work to dr whitehurst's who
uh who had
those kinds of changes made but but you
you should keep in mind that of course
we looked primarily at
whitehurst's cases because those are the
cases that he had personal knowledge of
and therefore those were the cases in
which he made the specific
allegations so i don't want to suggest
to you that there may not have been
instances in which it happened with
respect to other examiners when you say
some
i don't want to get into what mr conyers
got into what are we talking about
in terms of some of dr whitehurst's
conclusion how many reports of his did
you examine uh we examined um i'd like
to submit you a specific number but but
a couple of hundred i would estimate and
then what does some represent in terms
of the ones that were altered emitted or
supplemented again let me get back to
you with the specifics again it's a
relatively small number would you share
for me again your explanation
uh as to
why those
alterations and supplementations and so
forth were not
intentional and that they were just
technical you didn't use the word
technical i don't want to no it's not
it's not a word i would use i don't
would you share with me that explanation
again one more time if you don't mind
sure the reason why we found that mr
that the
people against whom dr whitehurst
alleged criminal conduct is that we did
not find evidence to support that they
had the specific intent to commit
the crimes that does not mean that we
exonerated them from any allegations
that they engaged in improper
practices in fact we found to the
contrary that's that's the meaning of
our conclusions that they
produced scientifically flawed work that
they exceeded their expertise when they
testified on the witness stand in
specific cases so i don't want to see
the the finding that we made that they
didn't commit crimes uh is a significant
finding but so is the finding that they
engaged in shoddy practices poor science
uh and that that kind of work should not
be acceptable in the fbi lab i i realize
you didn't give way to a substantial
amount of the vast majority of the
allegations that dr whitehurst made but
he responded to a question earlier that
he was concerned that there are people
who were wrongfully convicted and that
may be sitting in prison today do you
share that concern i i do share it to
some extent i i would hope that dr
whitehurst and mr cohn and everyone else
who claims that they have received
information that lead to that conclusion
that they would
produce that
to me or to the department of justice so
we can find out whether there is
something to that i think those are very
serious allegations and i care deeply uh
about them and i think it ought to be
everybody's objective to find out
whether in fact it's true and if
evidence is brought to people's
attention suggesting that it is true it
ought to be looked at very carefully
well with all due respect you've
reviewed
the matters or most of the matters that
dr whitehurst is involved with that's
the ones he would know about
you've reviewed the testimony provided
by the fbi in those cases because
otherwise you certainly couldn't have
concluded that there was no perjury
so
is there or is there not somebody
who was convicted as a result
of the actions that are the subject of
this hearing today i don't think it
would be responsible of me mr wechsler
to give you that kind of conclusion we
specifically say in our report that we
do not come to any conclusion as to what
the impact of the improper work or the
shoddy scientific work was on the
outcome of any particular case the trial
records in many of these cases are
extensive some of them include trials
that lasted for months and months and
months so i think that we ought to leave
it to the process that exists that is
defendants who are convicted have the
opportunity to raise based on newly
discovered evidence
evidence that suggests that they may
have been convicted
improperly they will make such motions
their defense lawyers will make such
motions prosecutors will oppose those
motions and judges will decide those
motions it is not my institutional role
to make that decision and i'm very
uncomfortable in even guessing at it and
i appreciate that you have
if the gentleman from florida could wrap
it up please yes you have concluded that
there was no perjury on behalf of any
testifying fbi
employee is that correct that's correct
thank you
okay thank you and i'd like to extend
the thanks to the entire subcommittee to
mr bromwich we appreciate your
indulgence and your testimony both
direct and then answer to questions we
will hear from the third and final panel
uh in at 12 30 we will stand in recess
until until 12 30.
hmm
thanks for watching
how are you going to
point you to parts of the report
roof
point you to parts of the report
hey
so
the subcommittee on crime will come to
order
our third panel today
after this brief recess on the fbi
investigation
and into the crime lab questions
is james that consists of three people
james maddock the deputy general counsel
for the federal bureau of investigation
mr maddock joined the fbi as an agent in
1980 he has served in the washington new
york detroit and san juan offices and
has served as assistant special agent in
charge of the jackson mississippi office
he holds both bachelors and law degrees
from the university of virginia
the second member of the panel is donald
thompson the acting assistant director
of the fbi for the laboratory division
mr thompson first began working at the
fbi in 1971 and became a special agent
in 1973
he served in the el paso chicago and
washington offices
in 1994 he became deputy assistant
director of the laboratory division at
fbi headquarters
in january of 1996 he assumed his
present duties as acting assistant
director of the laboratory division he
received his bachelor's degree from the
university of minnesota
and the third member of our panel is
kevin lothridge president of the
american society of crime laboratory
directors a non-profit professional
society devoted to the improvement of
crime laboratory operations through
solid management practices mr lothridge
is also director of the pinellas county
florida forensic laboratory where he's
worked for over 10 years he holds a
bachelor's degree in forensic science
from eastern kentucky university and a
master's degree in management from
national lewis university i must say
that i've met mr lothros before as a
floridian i've got as any member of this
panel would do i've got to spay
special attention to the fact that
you're here today and and welcome you mr
lothridge but we always welcome our
guests from the fbi when you come before
us
i would suggest that all of the
testimony that you've submitted in
writing
without objection will be admitted to
the record and you may feel free to
summarize it and i don't know which one
of you mr matic i've got listed first
but whichever order you wish to go in
i'll let you proceed please do thank you
mr chairman um
i would uh just like to briefly
summarize if i could uh the testimony uh
to
place my role in this uh overall
investigation perspective
since september 1995 i have served as
the fbi's point person on the inspector
general's investigation of the lab
i supervise the bureau's response to the
igig's draft report and ensured the
fbi's full cooperation with the ig's
investigation
during the course of that investigation
we provided thousands of pages of
documents made employees available for
interview and provided any and all
assistance requested by the ig and his
staff
we do not believe that such a complete
and comprehensive investigation of the
lab would have been possible without the
full cooperation of the fbi
as you know the ig's investigation was
triggered by the hundreds of allegations
that special agent frederick whitehurst
made against fellow fbi employees
the ig found that the vast majority of
those allegations were unsubstantiated
i think it's important to note that many
of mr whitehurst allegations suggested
that his colleagues were guilty of
criminal misconduct tampering with
evidence obstruction of justice perjury
suppression of evidence none of which
were substantiated by the ig
we acknowledged that there were serious
problems with former lab management and
with the performance of several lab
examiners but none of those problems
amounted to criminal misconduct as mr
whitehurst so often alleged
rather the problems identified by the ig
involved individual performance failures
failures which led the ig to make a
number of major recommendations to
improve the fbi lab we have agreed to
each of these recommendations and have
either implemented or taking steps to
implement each of these
as a result we're confident that the
management and individual performance
problems identified by the igr being
resolved and will not recur
additionally it's important to note that
the fbi lab currently consists of 35
units
each of which specializes in a
particular forensic discipline
the ig's investigation focused on three
of those units the explosives unit the
chemistry toxicology unit in the
materials analysis unit
moreover the ig's most serious
criticisms apply to the performance of
only a few individuals within those
units
we have no indication that the remaining
32 units have experienced similar
performance and management problems
we're confident that the extensive audit
procedures that the entire lab is
undergoing in preparation for
accreditation by the american society of
crime lab directors lab accreditation
board
will identify any remaining problems in
the lab
the fbi is committed to eradicating any
weaknesses in the lab and performing its
duties with the highest scientific and
ethical standards
before responding to your specific
questions i'd like to briefly address
three lab related issues
the committee has inquired as to the
impact that the problems identified in
the lab will have on criminal cases
for over a year the fbi has been working
closely with the department of justice
criminal division and with prosecutors
to ensure that no pending or future
prosecutions will be compromised
by this i mean that no prosecution will
be declined and no defendant's right to
a fair trial will be jeopardized by the
problems identified in the lab
we're confident that we will achieve
this goal
with respect to past cases the fbi and
doj are committed to continuing to
review the cases of each of the 13 lab
employees criticized in the ig's report
in which a conviction resulted
we believe that this is the only way to
ensure that no defendant's right to a
fair trial is jeopardized this review
process is being conducted by a task
force comprised of fbi and department of
justice criminal division personnel
the review process for past cases will
be conducted as follows
the fbi
has identified the past cases involving
the 13 lab examiners criticized by the
ig the task force will contact the
contributing agency or the prosecuting
office in each case to determine whether
a conviction was obtained
in each case which resulted in a
conviction the task force will consult
with the appropriate prosecuting
authority to determine whether the lab's
work was material to the conviction
where a determination is made that the
work of lab personnel was material to
the conviction the lab's findings and
any testimony offered by lab personnel
will be submitted to a qualified outside
scientist for review
if the scientist evaluation identifies a
problem with the lab's findings or
testimony in a particular case the fbi
and doj will make all necessary
disclosures to the prosecutor for his or
her determination as to whether
disclosure must legally be made to the
defense
by adopting these procedures the fbi
will be able to fulfill its commitment
to the public and restore public
confidence in the fbi's role in the
criminal justice system
in the wake of the fbi's handling of mr
whitehouse allegations questions have
also arisen about the fbi's ability to
investigate itself
must be remembered however the fbi has
successfully investigated many
significant and sensitive allegations of
misconduct by fbi employees
for example the fbi successfully
investigated and assisted in the
prosecution
of an fbi special agent who was
convicted of killing a confidential
informant the fbi investigated its
former director for misuse of his
position and most recently the fbi
investigated and arrested one of its own
special agents for espionage
unlike most police agencies the fbi has
not one but two independent watchdogs
that provide oversight of the fbi's
employees and activities
in addition to the fbi's office of
professional responsibility the
department of justice office of
professional responsibility also has
oversight over the fbi in certain
circumstances
moreover the department of justice
inspector general may request authority
from the attorney general to take
responsibility for investigating a
particular allegation under
investigation by the fbi's opr
further the fbi can recuse itself from a
particular investigation as it did in
the case of the lab
the fbi remains committed to an
effective internal integrity program
we're dedicating more resources to our
own opr and have hired a career
prosecutor from the department of
justice to head that office
with respect to mr whitehurst
allegations we recognize that we did not
adequately investigate all of those
allegations internally we are reviewing
prior management failures to prevent
such failures in the future
in that regard we're confident that the
changes we are implementing in the
laboratory will ensure there will be no
recurrence of the problems identified in
the ig's investigation
after reviewing the ig's draft report
the fbi made temporary personnel changes
with respect to four lab employees whose
performance and conduct were severely
criticized by the ig
on january 24th 1997 one employee was
reassigned within the lab
two employees were temporarily
reassigned to perform duties outside of
the lab and mr whitehurst was
temporarily placed on administrative
leave with pay
the actions are temporary and each
employee has retained its full pay and
benefits these moves were necessary
however to ensure the lab operated as
effectively and efficiently as possible
pending the release of the ig's final
report
the reason that mr whitehurst was
temporarily placed on administrative
leave with pay
rather than temporar temporarily
reassigned to another role within the
fbi like the other employees was in no
way motivated by mr whitehurst's
protected whistleblowing activities
rather the fbi took this action with
respect to mr whitehurst for two reasons
the findings conclusions and
recommendations regarding mr whitehurst
contained in the ig's draft report
including the determination that mr
whitehurst appears to lack the judgment
and common sense necessary for a
forensic examiner as well as the
recommendation that the fbi consider
what role affinity he can usually
usefully serve and other components of
the fbi and mr whitehurst refusal to
answer questions in direct contravention
of an order to cooperate with regard to
an investigation into allegations that
mr whitehurst without author
authorization
disclosed official information to an
outside party
in order to avoid even the appearance of
retaliation however the fbi requested
that the department of justice make any
final personnel division decisions with
respect to mr whitehurst and all the lab
employees criticized by the ig the
department of justice has assigned that
responsibility to the justice management
division
finally i'd like to re-emphasize the fbi
has agreed to each of the major
recommendations contained in the ig's
report
in fact we've invited the ig to inspect
the lab every six months until both he
and the fbi are satisfied that all the
issues have been resolved
at this time the acting assistant
director of the lab don thompson will
outline some of the most significant
recommendations to improve the lab and
the actions the fbi has already taken to
implement those thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
you need to turn your microphone on mr
thompson there's a little button there
there you go we'll switch thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
i also thank you for the opportunity to
appear here today
and i want to first state that we in the
fbi laboratory do acknowledge the
findings of the inspector general
and agree that there were performance
shortcomings on the part of a small
number of our employees
while these deficiencies did not rise to
the level of perjury
or fabrication of evidence we
nonetheless take them very seriously
and we believe they should not be
characteristic of the high standards
that we demand of ourselves
and that those
of the american people which the
american people expect and deserve of us
however i also believe that they should
not overshadow the outstanding work that
the laboratory has performed on
thousands of cases over the past 60
years
this work has consistently withstood the
test of court proceedings all over the
country at all levels of government
since its creation the fbi laboratory
has pioneered numerous advances in
forensic technology and methods
which have revolutionized the manner in
which forensic evidence can be detected
and analyzed
we
have advanced the use of dna analysis
techniques and for example very recently
brought online a technique which enables
us to exploit hair bone and teeth
evidence in a manner heretofore not
possible
besides assisting in the solution of
several recent violent crime cases this
this technique recently
enabled the exoneration of an individual
who had been in jail for a violent
sexual assault that occurred in 1989
we've also pioneered the development of
automated forensic database systems such
as drug fire and the combined dna index
system also known as codec or codis
and these systems have enabled law
enforcement officials to link evidence
from multiple crimes and share
information across jurisdictions
codis has linked more than 200 sexual
assaults since 1991
and drug fire has produced more than
fifteen hundred evidentiary associations
in crimes involving the use of firearms
the laboratory has also provided
training to hundreds of forensic
practitioners from the state local and
from international organizations who
have and continue to be a credit to
their profession
the fbi has and continues to be a leader
within the forensic community in forming
technical working groups
which are designed to develop standards
for conducting analyses
for training
for qualifications of examiners and for
quality assurance methods
working groups in the areas of dna
materials and fingerprints
have proved immensely productive
and we are forming working groups in the
handwriting and bombing areas
we have long recognized the need for an
updated laboratory facility and we will
be building a new state-of-the-art
facility in quantico virginia
this new project which is scheduled for
completion in the year 2000 will provide
us a world-class facility which will
enhance the quality of our current
forensic capabilities and enable us to
better exploit new and emerging
technologies
consistent with the recommendations made
by the inspector general
the laboratory has already or is in the
process of implementing measures to
enhance and assure the quality of our
work
in 1994 we decided to seek accreditation
with the american society of crime
laboratory directors laboratory
accreditation board
and having undergone extensive
preparations we expect to apply for
accreditation before the end of the year
we are in the process of restructuring
our explosives unit and have revamped
our report writing
procedures we've also fine-tuned a
number of procedures that we had
promulgated the last couple of years
commensurate and consistent with the
ig's recommendations
we have we created a new quality
assurance unit in 1995 which has been
charged with coordinating a total
quality program
we're also strengthening our uniform
training program for examiners with
additional emphasis being placed on case
documentation report preparation and
testimony
finally
the fbi has begun a search for a
world-class scientist to run the
laboratory
in closing i would like to say that we
continue to remain very proud of our
accomplishments
but most certainly we do recognize that
there is always room for improvement and
that we must commit ourselves to doing
so
the inspector general inquiry is
culminating a period of critical
self-examination by the laboratory which
begun three years ago when we decided to
open ourselves up to
external scrutiny and pursue
accreditation
the inspector general has clearly made
excellent recommendations and we have
and will continue to strengthen our
quality assurance processes to ensure
that these problems that he surfaced do
not recur
the fbi is committed mr chairman to
making the required changes to ensure
that the laboratory remains a leader
among forensic laboratories and that its
work meets the rigors of the science and
the law
we are confident that through this
process we are emerging better and
stronger than ever i thank you
thank you mr maddock and mr thompson we
appreciate that mr lothrod you're
recognized
good afternoon mr chairman mccullum and
members of the subcommittee i'm pleased
to have this opportunity to discuss with
you as cloud's role in the professional
management of crime laboratories and to
act as a resource for the committee
the american society of crime laboratory
directors is a not prof not-for-profit
professional society devoted to the
improvement of crime laboratory
operations through sound management
practices its purpose is to foster the
common professional interest of its
members promote to promote and foster
the development of laboratory management
principles and techniques
to acquire preserve and disseminate
information related to the utilization
of crime laboratories to maintain and
improve communications among crime
laboratory directors to promote
encourage and maintain the highest
standard of practice in the field of
crime laboratory services
as cloud's mission is to enhance the
quality of the criminal justice system
through forensic science by applying the
best technologies training resources and
practices for the timely availability of
quality forensic products and services
membership in as cloud is open to all
individuals whose majors duties include
the management or direction of a crime
laboratory a branch crime laboratory or
a crime laboratory system
a crime laboratory is defined as a
laboratory which employs one or more
full-time scientists whose principal
function is the examination of physical
evidence for law enforcement agencies in
criminal justice matters and who provide
opinion testimony with respect to the
physical evidence to the criminal
justice system the society is composed
of crime laboratory directors managers
and supervisors from the united states
in 17 foreign countries the membership
consists of biologists chemists document
examiners physicists toxicologists and
law enforcement officers whose major
function is the management of crime
laboratory
accomplishments of as clad as cloud has
developed several different programs
that have been beneficial to the
forensic science profession
these include the asclad lab
accreditation program and the national
forensic science technology center
a not-for-profit corporation designed to
develop training and advanced degree
programs to forensic scientists by
distance learning methods the nfstc also
provides pre-accreditation audits to the
laboratories preparing for azcloud lab
accreditation
the ask clyde scholarship program which
recognizes outstanding graduate and
undergraduate forensic science students
each year two students
in a forensic science degree program
from an accredited university are
selected to each receive a monetary
scholastic award and a certification of
recognition
ask cloud members have served on many
panels and committees including the
office of inspector general's panel on
the fbi laboratory the dna advisory
board and the search committee for the
new director of the fbi laboratory
laboratory accreditation which seems to
be of interest today the crime
laboratory accreditation program of the
american society of crime laboratory
directors laboratory accreditation board
is a voluntary program in which any
crime laboratory may participate to
discriminate to just demonstrate that
its management operations personnel
procedures and instruments physical
plant and security and personal safety
procedures meet certain standards the
accreditation process is one form of
equality assurance program which may be
combined with proficiency testing
continued education and other programs
to help the laboratory strive to give
better overall service to the criminal
justice system
the process of self-evaluation that
leads to accreditation is an invaluable
management tool for the crime laboratory
director
the fact that the laboratory chooses not
to apply for accreditation does not
imply that a laboratory is inadequate or
that its results cannot be trusted
the laboratory accreditation board has
adopted four accreditation objectives
that clearly define the purpose and
nature of the program
they are to improve the quality of
laboratory services provided to the
criminal justice system to offer the
general public and users of the
laboratory services a means of
identifying throughout the nation and
virtually the world those laboratories
facilities which satisfy accreditation
criteria to develop and maintain
criteria which can be used by a
laboratory to assess its level of
performance and strengthens operation
and lastly to provide an independent and
partial and objective system by which
laboratory facilities can benefit from a
total organizational review
main areas inspected include facilities
and equipment
written operation and technical
procedures interviews of all technical
staff and a review of casework reports
and supporting documents
the major requirements it is required
for a quality assessment and quality
control that a crime laboratory
participate in a program or a
combination of programs that include the
following
one periodic case report and case note
review done and
done on an internal basis
this type of review assures that the
examiners are following the laboratory's
established procedures and that the
findings are properly documented and two
proficiency testing internal and or
external involving the use of blind and
or open samples of which the true
results are unknown to the examiner
prior to the analysis
the accreditation process
crime laboratory directors seeking
information about laboratory
accreditation direct their inquiries to
the executive assistant as clad lab
the reply to such inquiries is a copy of
the accreditation manual the process
need not go any further there is no
obligation on the part of the crime
laboratory director he may elect to
evaluate his own laboratory for the
purpose of self-improvement without
seeking accreditation this is done
without incurring obligation or expense
beyond the cost of the manual when the
laboratory director determines that his
laboratory is prepared he may elect to
apply for formal accreditation following
the instructions in the manual
the process making continue as follows
one self-evaluation of the applicant
laboratory two application and
supporting documents filed by the
applicant laboratory
on-site inspection by a team of trained
inspectors
the inspection report considered by the
asclad laboratory accreditation board
and one year to remedy deficiencies
before the final decision by the board
accreditation review completed by the
laboratory annually and a full
reinspection required every five years
an annual maintenance fee of 500 must be
paid by the accredited laboratory
there are three types of standards that
go into the accreditation program the
first one is essential standards that
directly affect and have fundamental
impact on the work product of the
laboratory or the integrity of the
evidence the laboratory must meet 100
percent of the essential standards
two important standards standards that
are considered key indicators of the
overall quality of the laboratory but
may not directly affect the work product
or the integrity of the evidence the
laboratory must meet 70 percent of the
important standards
lastly the desirable standards standards
that have the least effect on the work
product or the integrity of the evidence
but which nevertheless enhance the work
product of the laboratory the laboratory
must meet fifty percent of the desirable
standards
asclad has several goals that we want to
accomplish to help the profession of
forensic science they include the
delivery of quality forensic science
service by supporting current and future
forensic science initiatives such as the
accreditation of 80 of all crime
laboratories by the year 2000
the continued support of federal
programs that provide research and
development and technology transfer to
state and local forensic laboratories
these include programs at the national
institute of justice bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms the drug
enforcement administration the fair
bureau of investigation and the
department of energy
and developing a continual funding
source to help laboratories improve
quality and provide the timely necessary
forensic services to the criminal
justice community
and in conclusion mr chairman i have
attempted to describe for the
subcommittee what role as clad has in
the professional management of crime
laboratories and some goals we want to
accomplish i believe that in the future
the scientific analysis of physical
evidence will aid more investigations
and enhance the criminal justice process
as cloud wants to be the resource to
this committee on matters concerning
forensic science at this time i would be
pleased to answer any questions the
subcommittee has regarding as cloud and
forensic science thank you very much mr
lothridge and we will now go into the
five-minute rule and i'll recognize
myself for five minutes
mr matic today your testimony is
consistent with that which
we heard in the draft
criticism or response by the fbi to the
inspector general's report which said
that the fbi quote takes full
responsibility for the failings which
have been identified within its
laboratory unquote
and then goes on that particular
official response to take issue with
many of the findings of serious
misconduct by the fbi employees
i'm curious just what is the bureau
taking responsibility for
i don't fully appreciate
where you're drawing the line between
what you're taking responsibility for
and where you're saying hey there really
wasn't much of anything that was really
wrong here
mr chairman we take responsibility for
the findings that the inspector general
rendered in his final report we accept
those
during preparation of our response we
advocated positions that we felt were
justified in support of our employees
they were considered some of those
positions were adopted by the inspector
general and formulating the final report
some were not
we stand uh
by the findings of the inspector general
and accept the failings that he
identified in his report
well the thing that strikes me the most
about much of what i see in the
inspector general's report is the number
of occasions where witnesses from the
laboratory went to court and testified
about things that either were beyond
their expertise or things they fudged
whether they did it intentionally or
they did it unintentionally it's pretty
clear from that report assuming we
accept the basic premise of that report
that that's what they did and they did
it some of them
more than one time and that there was
nobody overseeing that nobody checking
them nobody's saying hey wait a minute
now what's the quality of what we're
getting on the witness stand and that's
a separate issue of course in the
technical findings how could that have
happened how could it have been gone on
as long as it did without anybody
recognizing this was a really a serious
problem mr chairman i there is no excuse
for some of the management failures
which occurred in the lab in the past
and i would concur with your observation
that there was inadequate oversight
about uh courtroom testimony even though
the instances identified by the
inspector general were relatively few
there should have been no such instances
that occurred well you know mr
whitehurst told us this morning that he
first started writing these letters
somewhere and making these concerns
known about 1986 or 1987. he talked
about how he talked to former director
sessions personally about it was assured
that
mr sessions was concerned going to look
into it when director free took over he
said he didn't personally talk with him
but he did talk with your office the
general counsel's office about this
at some length how do you explain that
it took an inspector general's audit
some routine looking over some paperwork
to trigger the actual unearthing of the
magnitude of this problem how do you
explain how
your office the deputy uh the general
counsel's office and the fbi internally
failed at the top to recognize these
many many allegations that mr whitehurst
and i guess some others were making and
take them seriously enough to go
question the people who were below
you in management
who obviously were ignoring the facts mr
chairman i would respectfully
contest some of your observations there
the office of the general counsel did
take many of the allegations raised by
mr whitehurst very seriously in fact
prepared a report for director free
which noted that there was a substantial
basis to some of the allegations raised
by mr whitehurst while also noting that
many appeared not to be substantiated
before many of those recommendations
could be implemented the entire process
was sub subsumed into the ig's
investigation which resulted in this
report
having said that i
recognize that the fbi had failed
failures
in recognizing some of mr whitehorse
early
allegations particularly as they
concerned
the work of uh examiner terry rudolph
there were a number of internal reviews
which failed to go far enough which
failed to recognize the seriousness of
the issues presented
and i can offer no excuse for that i am
confident however that the procedures
that we have in place and are
implementing in preparation for
accreditation
we're also having a review of the entire
lab done by our inspection division with
the assistance of outside scientists
that process will take several months
and we'll begin next month well i'm i'm
pleased that you're doing what you're
doing don't get me wrong i i
sense that the the whole picture of the
lab is not as bad as maybe the public
has got it painted as being on the other
hand i and that you're doing a lot to
correct what was wrong following the
procedures the ig is outlined but i am
extremely concerned about the fact that
there seems to be a lack of willingness
to truly lay responsibility on the
doorsteps of somebody above the
immediate management in the laboratory
when this matter had been perking around
there for nearly nine years before it
was fully explored by anybody before
anybody dug their feet into it and to
say
is the management problem in the check
problem down at the laboratory is not to
my way of thinking sufficient somebody
it might not be director free it might
not be director sessions but somebody in
between had some responsibility they
they didn't
fulfill in my judgment and
now we talk about moving some people
around who were the ones particularly
pointed out to by the ig but but that
doesn't explain the lack of any uh
accountability for somebody in middle
middle management up top somewhere in
washington uh who certainly should have
been paying attention to this mr
chairman i couldn't agree with you more
in fact the responsibility lies with
former senior executive management of
the lab uh if you look at the inspector
general's report uh he criticized
management
from the supervisory level all the way
up to the assistant director level
the fact of the matter is that all of
those executives are now retired from
the fbi
and are no longer subject to
accountability for their actions but
there were serious management failures
which we hope through the processes that
we're putting in place
will not recur
mr jackson lee you're recognized for
five minutes
i think the real crux of
this oversight hearing and our concern
is restoring the integrity and as well
uh the impact
negative impact that all of this may
have had on the justice system as it
relates to the fbi involvement i think
we all have to make a commitment that
even with retired executives and others
uh that there has to be a steady and
continuing
uh concern and um
ability to solve
this what seems to be an ongoing problem
so i i am likewise
sort of
at a loss
on the length of time that it took to um
review this and turn one's attention to
this matter
and i'm going to
ask a series of questions along those
lines but first i'd like to ask mr
lothridge what is the worldwide
reputation of the fbi forensic lab
laboratories have looked for them to
implement technologies for us uh provide
training for us as well as handle cases
that we could not do in our state and
local laboratories and what do you
perceive i don't know if you have any
international reach
but what do you perceive the reputation
of the lab is now after the inspector
general's report
where does the
lab stand in the eyesight of those who
are in the business of criminal
investigation internationally and
nationally
uh i believe everyone's looking at the
inspector general's report
and
digesting what they can of it making
their own decisions based on that
internationally i don't have not heard
anything uh related to that
and you think however that um
if the inspector general's report is as
we see it and read it uh that the fbi
can recoup their integrity and their um
respectability on the national forensic
level
i believe the steps they've taken to
respond to the ig's report have been
very good i think seeking accreditation
as well as bringing outside scientists
for a pre-accreditation audit shows that
they're asking for the community they're
trying to
go out and
get the community's feeling on their
procedures and how they manage their
laboratory and i think that
once they complete the accreditation
process i think a lot of the questions
will be answered
semantics accreditation cannot be the
only answer and one of the accusations
or allegations made was poorly trained
fbi agents
in these matters how are you all
responding to those allegations
after director free took over
he
instituted a program whereby a number of
agents would be reassigned from their
headquarters responsibilities to the
field basically to get agents out in the
field as investigators
a collateral benefit of that in terms of
the lab was the ability to bring in
non-agent scientists
and in fact we're in the process of
still bringing in a number of qualified
scientists to fill vacancies in the lab
additionally as mr thompson mentioned
his statement
we are
aggressively looking for a national
caliber scientist to
head up the lab
we have
are in the process of getting approval
for additional high-level
senior executive science positions in
the lab
and have recognized the need for
enhanced science in the lab we have
instituted
new programs in terms of
training examiners for courtroom
testimony
a rigorous moot court program for new
examiners annual
review of testimony annual seminars for
testimony
and generally taking a number of steps
to make it clear to every examiner in
the lab what the acceptable limits of
courtroom testimony are and at the same
time as i said enhancing the level of
science throughout the laboratory
one of the points that was made in the
inspector general's report was that
he found or at least in certain
instances and i referred to the hastings
case that there was no intentional lying
under oath and i made the point that
intentional lying under oath is
certainly one aspect of intent but if
you lied there has to be impact
i understand through your testimony and
mr thompson's testimony that
with respect to past cases the fbi and
the dog are committed to continue to
review the cases of each of the 13 lab
employees criticizing the inspector
general's report which resulted in a
conviction
this review process is being conducted
by a task force comprised of fbi and
department of justice criminal division
personnel
why not outside involvement
to truly give a sense that this is an
independent review
and then secondly would you answer the
question as what the status of the
whistleblower implementation
whistleblower act implementation is in
the fbi at this time certainly
congressman woman if if i could we are
going to employ outside scientists who
are in the process now of of contracting
with those individuals to review
uh the laboratory findings um in cases
that resulted in a conviction and were
were material to that conviction
and also the testimony so that an
outside individual who is experienced in
a particular forensic discipline will be
making an assessment of whether the
laboratory findings were adequate and
whether the testimony was in accord with
uh with those findings
um
we are uh going to ensure ourselves that
we look at
the past cases of these individuals and
identify any problems that uh uh could
have arisen
and with regard to the whistleblower uh
questions uh uh
i'm sorry could you could you repeat
your question just has it been
implemented the previous testimony
suggests that there were some difficulty
in implementing the whistleblower act to
the fbi even though it had been amended
for such is that
in your opinion in place implemented in
the fbi at this time
the fbi has whistleblower regulations
but they are not um fully adequate as
anticipated by the whistleblower
protection act
that placed a requirement on the
president to
develop additional enforcement
mechanisms to make sure there was no
retaliation against whistleblowers the
president recently
delegated that authority to the attorney
general the department is in the process
now of developing implementing
regulations and
once those are
developed then we will be governed by
those procedures as well
let me thank you and mr mannix
mr mannix and mr thompson for your
integrity and commitment might i just
suggest that possibly the addition of
outside law enforcement
officers chiefs of police others
might be an appropriate addition to
your task force thank you thank you mr
jackson lee mr hutchinson you're
recognized for five minutes thank you mr
chairman and i appreciate uh the fbi's
response to this and
uh trying to address this very serious
problem i wanted to make a short
statement uh
mr maddock and then ask a follow up with
a question
first in your testimony you indicated
that you were reviewing the cases of
each of the 13 lab employees who've been
criticized the oig report
and that you're following a certain
procedure talking to the united states
attorney's office determining if there's
a conviction in the case if there's a
conviction talking to them to see if it
was material the testimony of the lab
employee and then submitting it to an
outside
laboratory i believe and then making
disclosure to the prosecutor if all of
that
fits in with with with your framework
my question i really
believe that if you find that
there was a conviction the case and that
the testimony of the lab employee was
critical that there should be
responsibility the department of justice
to provide that information beyond
simply to the prosecutor
i think in fairness that there should be
some consideration of giving that to the
court i hope you'll talk the attorney
general encourage her to review this
instead of a more stringent policy with
more open disclosure i do not believe
this is sufficient what you've outlined
and then i want to follow up what the
chairman was asking
in regard to your testimony
you indicated that you recognize that we
did not adequately investigate all of
the allegations internally referring to
the allegations of mr whitehurst
now
who the question is who did not
adequately investigate those allegations
you don't need to give me names but are
there certain positions who failed to do
their job and investigating those
allegations
yes sir there was a failure of from the
assistant director level on down
in terms of ensuring an adequate review
how many uh individuals are we speaking
of that failed to do their
responsibility there would be uh four
positions in that chain
and are these all within the laboratory
yes sir no but but the complaints of mr
whitehorse went outside the laboratory
did it not
some of his complaints did yes sir and
who did they go to
some of his complaints were investigated
by the office of professional
responsibility
and did they act responsibly and
investigated appropriately
they investigated some of the
allegations uh very thoroughly and uh i
believe the ig's report uh concurs in
that assessment although the ig also
noted that there was a lack of
thoroughness in some aspects of some of
the allegations
there were a number of allegations
raised by mr whitehurst some of which
centered on
forensic
procedures
others centered on more
individual and personal matters has any
disciplinary action been taken first of
all on the uh
four that you identified initially
on the uh the four management positions
yes uh no sir they have all been
retired
i think the the
last those individuals to retire was
several months ago but they're all
retired now
so that problem's been resolved by them
retiring
uh the fbi is not in a position to take
a disciplinary action against former
employees okay and then the in regard to
the latter where you're speaking of the
office of professional responsibility is
there any disciplinary action will be
taken regard the way they handle this
um the entire report
as i mentioned in my statement has been
referred to the justice management
division and they will be undertaking a
review
of all of the criticisms
that were raised in the uh inspector
general's report
and uh
it will be their determination as to
whether any additional action is
warranted
last i think it is very important that
uh
and i'm pleased that you're
improving the training of your
lab personnel in court testimony uh
that's been a serious problem and i know
there's a
human element here that you
work with us attorney you want to meet
their expectations but you have to guard
against that and i hope that you'll
really improve the ethical standards
there uh and and i'm grateful for your
testimony the way you all are addressing
this we have to have the highest quality
of our laboratory and i appreciate your
commitment uh to that goal thank you mr
chairman
thank you mr hutchinson mr webster
you're recognized for five minutes um
thank you mr chairman
um mr matic um are you are you the guy
in charge of the lab
no congressman oh
so
mr thompson you're you're in charge of
the lab right okay who who when it says
the fbi response on this stuff
um it says the fbi does not believe that
any lab examiner purged himself
whose conclusion is that i know it's the
fbi's
but who is there an individual
congressman if i could uh i was
responsible for the preparation of the
fbi's response to the inspector
general's draft report okay so so then
mr matic i assume then that you believe
and the fbi concurs
that um no lab examiner appears to have
perjured himself is that that were the
finding that was the finding of the
inspector general and and
what did you examine to reach that
conclusion
um in making that statement uh
congressman we are
recognizing the fact that the inspector
general determined that there was no
finding of criminal misconduct or
intentional misconduct on the part of
any fbi employee okay so and again i'm
not trying to put words in your mouth
but you're regurgitating the inspector
general's report that nobody purges
themselves is that it well we think it's
important to note that after an 18-month
investigation which was very thorough
and involved a number of personnel
including assistant u.s attorneys and
highly qualified scientists that they
did determine that there was no criminal
misconduct did you ask any of these guys
that worked in your department there
that apparently gave this false
information or any of these people that
um
changed the reports
in a material manner which we learned
the inspector general concluded yes then
what like what was going on like why
they just said they
did a test when they didn't do a test
just to sort of
did did you wonder why congressman if i
could um
once the ig began his investigation we
were removed from active investigation
of issues surrounding the laboratory and
now the whole process has been turned
over to the justice management division
to make a determination i'm not trying
to give you a hard time then
tell me if what i'm saying is a
mischaracterization then the fbi then
doesn't believe anything the fbi is
regurgitating the inspector general's
report is that fair no uh congressman i
i don't think that is fair okay the fbi
please tell me how it is you've
concluded the fbi has concluded that no
lab examiner has purged him herself
and if i could the fbi recognizes the
serious management and performance
failures that were identified in the
inspector general's lengthy
investigation i appreciate that we
because we were not able to
independently investigate any of these
allegations during the dependency of the
ig's investigation we were not in a
position to make any determination as to
whether anyone committed any additional
acts with
criminal culpability uh so it was simply
an impossibility for us to proceed so
other than the ig's report then there is
no other basis for the fbi
concluding that there was no purge of
testimony from an fbi examiner would
that be fair to say the lab examiner
congressman again i i don't i don't mean
to to uh to argue here but i i did uh
outline the process that we have in mind
for um
reviewing past cases we're going to look
at the past cases of the 13 individuals
who were criticized in the inspector
general's investigation
and if during the course of that review
additional problem incidents occur then
appropriate action will be taken
additionally how many examiners are
there if i may ask
lab examiners
they're divided congressmen into two
categories we have agent examiners we
have approximately 40 who are performing
work at the bench level we have over a
hundred
professional support examiners who we've
brought on in the course of the last
several years and we will be hiring up
to 126 shortly the the report earlier if
i understood it
by and large related to dr whitehurst's
assertions
are you have you limited your
examinations to dr whitehurst's
assertions or how about all the other
examiners that dr whitehurst doesn't or
may not be familiar with
congressman if i could um
i outlined briefly a little bit earlier
the fact that our inspection division
with the assistance of outside
scientists from the forensic
research training center are going to be
conducting a section-by-section
review of the entire laboratory
additionally as mr lothridge indicated
in his statement in the accreditation
process
any uh issues
concerning uh laboratory procedures or
protocols will be identified
okay the the if i understood the
testimony earlier the
investigation relating to whether or not
perjury actually happened related to the
items that dr whitehurst identified
just for your information i don't mean
to you know get too crazy over words but
the fbi and i guess these are yours the
fbi does not believe that any lab
examiner purged himself
the report doesn't if i understood it
correctly go to any and all lab
examiners it goes to just those that dr
whitehurst was courageous enough to
identify
and i'm just curious i mean today how
many reports are being drafted
where somebody is changing the words i'm
sure unintentionally
but is changing the words
and if dr whitehurst doesn't tell us who
will um congressman this the response is
obviously limited to the scope of of the
ig's investigation
in regard to your question about anyone
changing reports that practice is has
been stopped it was stopped years ago it
was reiterated
that it is an unacceptable procedure we
have adopted a new procedure where each
auxiliary examiner signs his own report
it is included verbatim in the overall
report so that it is now impossible
for a change to be made in an auxiliary
examiner's report
do you think the word any lab examiner
do you think that word any is i mean
in second thought do you think that
that's an appropriate statement the fbi
does not believe that any lab examiner
purging himself i do congressman because
it's limited to the scope of the
inspector general's investigation
and how many examiners did they examine
i don't have the answer for that sir
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr wexler because we have a
limited number of people here to ask the
question at the moment i'm going to
yield myself some more time because i
think we need to explore some of these
things to gain a better understanding
and i'll yield to you again mr wexter if
you wish to stay
in a couple of minutes um i'm i'm
curious about some things mr maddox in
one particular part of your draft
testimony the written part you stressed
the report
only finds that's the ideas report
problems in three units of the lab and
that the fbi does not have any
indication that the remaining 32 units
have experienced similar performance and
management problems
but since those three units are the only
ones that the ig actually looked at
how can you possibly know that the other
32 units
don't have any problems
mr chairman i recognize obviously we
can't we can't know the unknown if you
will um
however i would point out that the ig's
investigation
did look at those three units and found
problems regarding only a few
individuals in those units and on only a
small number of cases their
investigation went beyond allegations
that were raised by mr whitehurst and
encompassed anything that they
encountered in the course of that
investigation
i think the best
comfort that i can offer for the
congress for the american public is the
fact
that we are undertaking a further
inspection of the entire lab with the
aid of outside scientists that we're
going to conduct a review of the past
cases of all the individuals who were
criticized in the report and that we are
going through the accreditation process
and all of those procedures
should significantly aid us in
identifying any remaining problems and
ensuring that corrective action where
warranted is taken well in a recent
front page piece of the wall street
journal they particularly criticized mr
malone i think for something far beyond
the alc hastings question that the ig
looked at
are you looking at mr malone's work
product are you examining that now does
anybody have that under review yes mr
chairman we're going to examine all of
the past cases of mr malone
um in
in the
report as well i shouldn't say on the
report in comments that have been made
in the past at least and i want to
clarify this because i thought i heard
you say maybe mr thompson say something
different here that today
the fbi has stated that didn't believe
that full-scale external inspections of
segments of the lab should be done at
five-year intervals
and that some limited outside review and
review by the fbi inspections divisions
should suffice
did i hear something different today
from that mr thompson
the fbi laboratory rejected the
accreditation process for many years
the accreditation process as i believed
mr lothridge mentioned commenced back in
the early 80s
the fbi laboratory did not embrace that
process
we believe that was
a bad decision
and it was three years ago in
consultations between
director free
my predecessor milt allrich and myself
that we decided to go ahead and seek
accreditation and came to the conclusion
that it was indeed
a
profitable
and a necessary thing for the fbi
laboratory
so do i understand that you now believe
that a full-scale and external
inspection of segments of the lab should
be undertaken in five year intervals or
is the
is that what is contemplated by the the
accreditation or how does that work
the five-year reinspections are part of
the ask clad laboratory accreditation
process
we do not believe that we should confine
our activities in monitoring our work
to as-clad accreditation
we're implementing as mr matic mentioned
a full-scale inspection
of our
laboratory by our inspection division
with the assistance of outside
experts
we are layering on a variety of
procedures
that are designed to enable us to go
back
for instance
we're going to form an auto group within
our quality assurance unit which will be
looking at a representative sample of
closed cases and doing a top to bottom
review of those cases to include the
quality of the testimony
and report directly back on those
findings to the assistant director
with the
with the objective to identify any
deficiencies or any trends emerging that
we need to address so you're going to do
yours in addition to the external
review that will come automatically when
mr lothridge's organization
finishes its initial accreditation
process every five years is that correct
that's that's correct congress now um do
you explain something for me about these
examiners are there non-agent examiners
in the lab right now
yes we we have
approximately 63 agents in the
laboratory about 40 of those are
actually on the bench conducting
forensic exams
starting in 1992 we undertook
a a project to create a mix
of agent examiners with
professional support examiners and in
fact the numbers of professional support
examiners
exceeds the number of agents
there's some concern that's been
expressed today about the possibility
the
non-agent examiners that exist the
scientists that are there that aren't
agents might
culturally or in some way be biased or
treated against or whatever is there any
indication a that that's true or b do
you have any way of making sure that
they get as much
fair treatment in terms of promotions
and opportunities to
come to the forefront and do their work
as as an agent examiner or what do you
say about that well let me first say
that the quality of the people that we
are bringing on board which includes
individuals with phds masters and
in addition extensive experience in
forensic science are of just top-notch
quality we are extremely pleased with
them they are
moving into positions of responsibility
they are being assigned to very
significant cases
they are
thus far the the feedback that we are
receiving from prosecutors and other
customers of the laboratory is that they
are performing in an admirable
outstanding manner and it's our design
that we will
bring these people along and afford them
every opportunity to compete for
promotions to the unit chief level and i
foresee that occurring
when these people are mature in their
current position and demonstrate
aptitudes in that area and i believe
this laboratory is going to be well
served by that what's your view of of
the ig's recommendation that some of the
science background doubts be from the
outside of the laboratory be brought in
to to run the lab
at this juncture i think it's a very
excellent
decision that the director has made
first and foremost the position of
assistant director and i've spoken with
the director about this should be a
scientist
that individual should bring with
scientific credentials certainly
management skills and leadership skills
but i think for the overall credibility
of the work that's performed in the
laboratory that's appropriate to have
a world-class scientist in the position
certainly someone coming in from the
outside
is going to have to
near himself or herself into the culture
of the fbi uh there'll be a steep
learning curve but it's our intent to
bring the type of person in who will
have
instant credibility in the position and
will be up to the job of learning what
he or she needs to do to perform the job
we have a target date for accomplishing
this
right we have brought on the services of
a hen hunting firm who is now assisting
us in
identifying
suitable candidates
we plan to have from that outfit a list
of candidates
towards the end of june
we will go through an interview process
and it's our objective to have a person
selected for the position on august 1st
now
i understand that
all of the folks who are employed at the
fbi laboratory
are subject to the civil service hiring
requirements i don't know if the new
head of the lab would be or not but
does this restriction cause a problem
that you don't have say at the cia or
nsa because i know we have some
some special exceptions over there for
allowing higher salaries to be paid to
scientists and so on and my impression
is that we don't have those kind of
exceptions for this laboratory can you
explain that to me no that that is a
very real problem in terms of recruiting
the types of people that we believe need
to be in the laboratory and probably
more
critical is retaining these people
we are able to bring them in at a fairly
comfortable grade level but
unfortunately to attract the types of
people that we need we almost we bring
them in at a level where they they come
in and have topped off and we can offer
them little
promotional opportunities at the bench
level unless they start getting into re
uh management type of positions for
instance we've
and and that's we've paid a price
because of those restrictions we had a
computer scientist come in about a year
ago
he was after six months on the job was
awarded the director's award for
excellence and we lost him in six months
after that because he got a higher
paying job that we just could not
compete with it sounds like that's
something we need to address and i guess
it's gonna take legislation to do that i
gather i i would agree all right
last thing i want to direct my attention
to is the question mr lothridge about
estate labs and the future of the fbi's
work
my impression is that state laboratories
are now beginning to grow that you're
accrediting uh crime laboratories what
do you see for the future with respect
to that and how will that impact uh the
work of the fbi you know historically
it's done work for states as well as for
the federal prosecutors well i think
with the
use of more scientific evidence in court
the state labs are going to be
quite busy and they're going to have to
be able to develop or actually transfer
the techniques that the fbi laboratories
have
i don't think that
right now
cases are
completed in a timely manner i think for
the criminal justice process to really
benefit from scientific evidence cases
need to be on the investigative side
while they're still investigating the
crime versus while they're
prosecuting the crime and uh with that i
think some resources need to be given to
the state and local laboratories to
enhance their capability to provide the
quality timeline
what you're saying is that we are
developing a lot more state laboratory
capability and a lot more needs to be
developed but that the need is so great
that even as that's developed the
workload of the fbi crime lab is not
going to diminish
in the foreseeable future that's correct
mr wexter would you like some follow-up
questions yes please mr chairman um i'm
going to direct my questions to mr
thompson if he doesn't mind and if
if um it's not your area of expertise
and it's mr maddox please just let me
know um
i'm i'm floored i you've had an
opportunity to review the inspector
general's report i assume yes sir okay
um i guess i'm somewhat floored by by
this statement of the fbi the fbi is
aware of no instance in which an fbi
employee failed to disclose exculpatory
evidence and yet in the inspector
general's report
if you don't mind i'll just read the
sentence or two we found other instances
of examiners giving inaccurate testimony
in a hearing conducted by the
investigating committee the judicial
conference of the 11th circuit
regarding then judge alcy hastings the
laboratory examiner testified falsely
that he had performed a certain
scientific test when in fact another
examiner had performed the test and he
also testified inaccurately regarding
the results and significance of the test
now i'm not
congressman hastings spokesperson i know
very little about the case but let's go
back to you the fbi's response
no exculpatory evidence
please does that square with the
investigative report
the issue
in that case
involved whether or not a particular
strap had been cut
or was
broke because it was caught and pulled
apart
both fbi examiners
including mr malone and the other
examiner in the materials analysis
section
fully concurred
in that opinion and that was the key
piece of evidence
mr malone as the report
found
testified that he had participated or
that he had conducted the test to
determine that when in fact he had not
personally conducted the test but was in
the same room with another individual
so
the
that
discrepancy does not in my estimation
disconstitute
with all that
information with all due respect
i don't know if it's a discrepancy or a
falsehood but the inspector general
concluded it was a falsehood i don't
know that's the inspector general but i
guess for you it's just a discrepancy i
would agree that it was a falsehood
um
item number one quoting the fbi response
another item excuse me there is no
information to support allegations that
evidence was fabricated that's in a
quote or tampered with in a quote by
laboratory laboratory employees
inspector general's report again
not me
three explosive units examiners altered
omitted or improperly supplemented some
of dr whitehurst internal reports as
they were being compiled into an
official report
of the laboratory
hello
i
i don't mean to be disrespectful
either
three explosive employees uh unit
examiners either they altered
or they didn't alter which did they do
inspector general seems to suggest they
did if i may because i prepared that
response um
uh
the finding of the inspector general
concerned tampering with evidence or
fabricating evidence there were no such
findings as you're aware a laboratory
reports are generally hearsay and are
not evidence
that does not excuse the fact that
changes were made to auxiliary examiner
reports that practice has stopped that
the people who did those things
are going to be reviewed for
disciplinary action and there's simply
no excuse for it i'm not i'm not trying
to excuse it it was a wrong practice it
has been corrected it
is your
response here
that these reports don't qualify for
your statement here because they're not
evidence
is that it the reports that the
inspector general congressman again
again i
i don't think you're giving it really
fairly simple no no congressman evidence
has been fabricated or it hasn't
everything it just has been tampered
with
it has not it has not there was no
finding by the inspector general in a
year and a half long investigation which
involved four assistant u.s attorneys
and five respected scientists that there
was any evidence tampering or evidence
fabrication there simply was no such
finding
on page six
tell me what in this sentence suggests
there was no finding three explosive
unit examiners altered omitted or
improperly supplemented some of dr
whitehurst's internal reports as they
were being compiled into an official
report of the laboratory are these
reports not used at trial to either
substantiate somebody's testimony or to
corroborate the testimony or to find
differences with the testimony
congressman the reports themselves are
not evident so the results of these so
your answer is then these reports may
have been altered but it doesn't qualify
for your statement because they're not
evidence congressman i believe i explain
um that the alteration of reports is a
wrong practice it has been corrected
years ago there are procedures in place
to make sure that it does not happen
again
that is a distinguishable thing from the
finding of the inspector general
concerning tampering with evidence and
fabricating evidence there was no such
finding if i made mr manic what are what
are these reports used for are they ever
provided to the prosecution or the
defense
the reports are provided yes sir they
are provided to whom
well reports are given to the
prosecutors are they ever provided to
the defense
the prosecutors would make such a
disclosure okay and what and then what
if they're used in the form of the
prosecutor what does the prosecutor do
with them
sir doesn't ever refer to those reports
in the course of a trial
well the the testimony of the examiner
is what is what is at issue does the
defense use the reports to cross-examine
the prosecution's witnesses i'm sure
they do
sir aren't the reports used then as
evidence
well congressman i i don't want to
quibble with you i mean the reports
themselves i'm not tagging either we're
talking about the integrity of the fbi
congressman i i am not disputing your
your point your point is that the
changing of those reports is wrong
the fbi understands that the changing of
those reports
with all due respect that is your point
my point is you have made a statement on
behalf of the fbi of the united states
and the statement is there is no
information to support allegations that
evidence was fabricated or tampered with
by laboratory employees
my point is that that is a false
statement your point is that tampering
is wrong i agree with you my point is
that the fbi's response to the wrong
behavior is also unfortunately not
nearly as forthright as it ought to be
well congressman i would dispute that
and i would also suggest that you that
that same allegation would apply to the
inspector general because that was his
finding
agreed
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
wexler and mr lothridge uh i'm just
curious if you could tell us what the
accreditation standards
are how they're determined and and how
they're going to be determined relative
to this laboratory
the accreditation standards are put
forth in the accreditation manual
we'll be glad to leave this with you so
you have a copy of the accreditation
manual but how are they determined
they're determined by a peer consensus
group of the american society of crime
laboratories laboratory accreditation
board and those are scientists yes
scientists and managers
of laboratories and how long has this
been done
since the early 80s
and
and then i wanted to ask that question
as to you mr maddock or perhaps mr
thompson
why did it take so long for the fbi to
come to the conclusion that
accreditation
uh was something that it should do i
mean obviously you've got the management
questions that we've been asking about
today and the questions about the
oversight
and all of that of the actual details of
what the ig unearthed but here's the
question of accreditation why did it
take so long for the fbi why did it take
this report for the fbi to determine
that it needed accreditation
we we've asked that question during the
course of this review and i think mr
thompson would echo these comments
management had previously failed to
consider the benefits of accreditation
there was some sense that we the fbi
uh were the largest forensic lab that we
knew
um the best way to approach all these
issues that we had a role in in training
the the individuals who who would go out
there and accredit these labs and
clearly it was a failure to appreciate
all the benefits from accreditation and
uh
uh it was uh a decision that was far too
long uh in coming and
we regret obviously uh waiting well i
i've kept you a long time today and
we're not going to keep you longer but i
have one one comment kind of point that
i want to have made today that strikes
me about this whole process in the
culture we talked about the fbi culture
a couple of you did mr thompson you did
i believe about scientist a minute ago
i've heard ever since i've been in the
crime subcommittee now almost 17 years
about the culture of the fbi some of it
very good
some of it
at times not so good
it seems to me that in looking at this
that one of the problems with the
attitudes that some individuals had in
that the ig unearthed is that they went
to court to prove the case for the
prosecution that they were willing
to do whatever it took
it may not be the way that
that they you come back and say well
they didn't do it intentionally but they
they were going to do their darndest to
prove the case and that that culture of
being so pro-prosecution in itself
is a problem in a scientific environment
in a laboratory where objectivity i mean
scientists basically are supposed to be
objective
and and is that a long-term
problem that is inherent it seems to me
a clash between
the the historical historical culture of
the fbi as being the investigator and
the let's go get them
law enforcement pro-prosecution arm and
the historical norm for a scientist to
be
right down the middle hard line
objective
unbiased unfettered is that something
that can ever be erased
or should it be erased in the situation
with respect to this crime lab and mr
thompson perhaps that's best for you
yeah
congressman certainly some concerns have
been raised in that regard i would first
submit to you though that
fbi agents in the laboratory have
enjoyed a reputation of being impartial
unbiased and being and being fiercely
independent it was was commonly known
and i came up on the investigative side
of the fbi
that
if you wanted
a fair and objective
opinion on a piece of forensic evidence
you needed and would want to send it to
the fbi laboratory
and in fact
it became and was frustrating from on at
certain junctures in the investigation
when you as an investigator at a certain
theory
on the case
and you would send some evidence in the
fbi laboratory
hoping that they would confirm your
theory and it was very frequently that
they rendered an opinion that did not
agree with your theory
and i think also if you examine the work
of the fbi laboratory over the years
you'll realize that much of the work
does not incriminate excopate subjects
but rather
exonerates them or eliminates them
25 percent of the work in the dna unit
for example ends up excluding subjects
and i think everyone in the laboratory
would embrace the notion that the most
important thing for the agency to do is
to identify the right individual the
person who is truly responsible for the
crime
and by
conducting analyses that are biased or
slanted towards some someone's
prosecutive or investigative theory is
not in the end going to accomplish that
end but am i reading it wrong uh albeit
maybe the exception and very much the
extreme exception and i certainly hope
that's true that two or three of the
principal figures investigated by the ig
and reported on in the ig who were
witnesses in these cases
look or appear as though they crossed
that threshold
and and were ardently trying to be sure
that they they covered the case they
proved the case they gave the best
testimony possible to to make the case i
mean that's the way it looks to me
doesn't it look that way to you i would
agree that that's uh in part and that we
ought to do everything we can to make
sure that doesn't happen in the future i
would agree
um mr webster you have one or two quick
ones i understand but i've we've got to
let these gentlemen go so please be
brief mr thompson did mr malone report
directly to you
no i came into the laboratory in 1994
and he had left before that do any of
the people that were identified by the
inspector general
is having problematic reports or
problems with do do you have any
association role with any of those
individuals
yes
and what was your role
they were in my
my chain of command
most of the individuals that are
addressed in the report are either bench
level examiners or unit chiefs
they then in turn report to a section
chief and the section chief in turn
reports to the division front office
where i'm assigned
and
i won't take up the chairman of you one
more time but
did you on a fairly routine basis review
their work
the role of actually affording
the work of an examiner both an
administrative and technical review
is the responsibility of the unit chief
so i did not directly
review that work for its technical or
administrative accuracy or competency
the unit chief would have done that
that's correct for each of these
individuals
that's correct thank you
thank you mr wexler mr matic i just
would like to close by commenting that i
saw in the reports that perhaps got
under mr webster's skin a little bit and
then some of the comments that were made
in your testimony as a flavor
the same type of thing i saw a little
bit we were looking at the waco case a
couple of years ago
and that is there is a tendency that fbi
agents and culture has to want to say
you know we're the best we're proud of
it we don't make mistakes and when we do
they're very rare and to minimize those
mistakes i'd like to believe that is
true in the whole scheme of things i
think the fbi is the greatest law
enforcement agency of any type in the
world it still is it has been and it
still is it's a huge agency though and
there are mistakes that are made you've
acknowledged some of those today but the
very way that there's this defensive
mechanism that appears to be out there
and what reactions there are to those
mistakes that are made
compounds in some ways the problem
it may not be readily apparent when
you're preparing the testimony or when
the statement is being issued by
director free or someone else but that
is a part of the problem the public gets
the impression there's a bit of an
arrogance here that that indeed we can
do no wrong or we we downplay what wrong
there is there and and that's natural
there's human nature involved in this to
some extent but it is a it is greater it
seems to me with the fbi than it is with
other agencies maybe because of its long
history but i i do not want these
hearings to conclude on the note that
you come away with the impression or
that the public does
that this committee feels that the fbi
is somehow in a state of collapse or
weakened or corrupted or anything of
that sort that is not the impression
that i have that is not the impression
the subcommittee has
we are very appreciative of the fact
that the efforts have been made
immediately to follow the inspector
general's recommendations
that the crime laboratory appears to be
on its way to being completely
revitalized that in all probability the
number of these kinds of cases are
fairly restricted though you're still
looking at them and to examine the
situation and that on the whole the fbi
is still doing a magnificent job
considering all of the crime it has to
fight and all the scientific research
that needs to be done and determinations
that need to be made but there is room
for self-criticism there is room for
some of us to be critical and this is
one of those cases which deserve that i
think
so i want to thank you for coming out
today
and thank you for tolerating our
little bit of intolerance for a reason
that i think is pretty pretty apparent
and mr lothridge we want to thank you
for coming
a long way to be with us today and uh mr
dr mr thompson we appreciate what you're
doing to try to to get the thing
implemented and we you've come and
provided a good service being here today
thank you very much this hearing is
in recess
[Music]
thank you
stick
that's mine
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello
this was the first of three oversight
hearings on fbi activities that's paul
american perspectives tomorrow night at
eight eastern end pacific time on c-span
next fbi director louis free
wednesday he testified on capitol hill
before the senate judiciary committee
he talked about bureau operations
procedures and budget
the three-hour hearing is chaired by
senator orrin hatch
know
director free thank you for coming
here to testify before this committee in
this hearing today
we undertake one of the most important
industry committee oversight functions
and responsibilities that's oversight of
the federal bureau of investigation
fortunately for us we must discharge
that responsibility at a time when we
can take pride in the
fbi
as everyone in the room knows
on monday of this week the jury in the
oklahoma city bombing case returned a
verdict of guilty on all 11 counts
and i know that the director must take
pride in the successful prosecution of
that case
because the bureau played a pivotal and
very important role
in the investigation and in the case
itself the successful handling of the
oklahoma city case
shows that the fbi is capable of
of high quality investigative work
director free deserves credit for
overseeing that effort
and i know that director free himself
however will join me in saying that the
credit for that case truly belongs to
those
uh fine men and women who toil daily on
the ground in the investigation and
prosecution of the case
i do not know all of their names but i
want them to know how much we appreciate
their hard work their excellent work in
this case
once more the fine men and women of the
fbi both agents and other personnel play
an important role in the daily efforts
of the bureau to investigate violations
of federal law that do not seize the
nation's attention in the same manner as
the oklahoma city bombing case
those cases nonetheless are very
important
we owe a debt of thanks to the employees
of the bureau who devote their
professional lives and unfortunately in
some cases
who even give their lives to the cause
of federal law enforcement
oversight hearings tend to focus on
issues that separate the congress and
the executive branch
but i would be remiss if i did not
mention the positive leadership of
director lewis free
and some of the fbi success stories that
we've been that we've seen during
director frey's tenure
take the bureau's counter espionage
efforts
for example the bureau discovered
followed and nabbed harold nicholson a
veteran cia officer who had been spying
for russia
the fbi also has addressed the
difficulties of domestic crime for
example the fbi successfully brought to
a conclusion the freeman standoff in
montana just last year these are but two
examples of instances in which fbi
agents displayed the type of
professionalism that brings credit on
themselves and the bureau
and that heightens the public confidence
in federal law enforcement
nevertheless the fbi has become
embroiled in various high-profile
matters over the past year the
unresolved investigation into the cause
and the crash of twa flight 800
the investigation of the bombing at
centennial park at the atlantic olympics
including the questioning of richard
jewell
the need adequately and efficiently to
implement the communications assistance
for law enforcement act the x-files
controversy the fbi lab problems and the
ncic upgrade
there are also
various issues that while not widely
discussed
still merit our attention at the fbi at
an fbi oversight hearing and we will
address some of these issues here today
let me say where i hope that we will end
up after this hearing
my ultimate goal is simple but critical
to help restore and enhance public
confidence in federal law enforcement
nothing that we do is more important
in the final analysis the security of a
society based on the rule of law rests
on the confidence
of the public and those persons
entrusted with our law enforcement
efforts
now director fee you have my confidence
and we must ensure that and i hope we
can ensure that
that everyone else shares my view
i know that the public supports our goal
and the means by which we will strive to
achieve it
and i hope we can take some steps in
that direction through this hearing
over the past two years congress and
this committee have sought to help the
fbi write out some
rough weather that the bureau has faced
in return the fbi has shown a
willingness to adapt to the new public
attitude toward law enforcement
consider the bureau's actions in the
freeman standoff in montana there the
bureau showed that it can modify its
operations in order effectively to
discharge the new and more difficult
responsibilities thrust upon the
contemporary our contemporary law
enforcement officers
i applaud the director and the bureau
for that particular successful operation
and for implementing needed changes in
procedures in this regard
oftentimes it is difficult for an
organization as large as the fbi
to affect change expeditiously
as they say in the military a battleship
cannot turn on a dime
but i am confident that director free is
committed to the task of charting a
proper mission for the bureau into the
next century of obtaining the personnel
and other resources necessary to
complete that mission and of surveying
the bureau's effectiveness in
accomplishing that mission
again director free uh thank you for
appearing before us today
we appreciate the work that you've done
we appreciate the controversies that
you've been in
uh we appreciate the pluses and minuses
and the difficulties and the successes
that the fbi has had like every large
organization you're going to have a lot
of those but you've handled them all
with applause
you've handled them all with skill
you've handled them all it seems to me
with courage
and certainly with integrity in every
way and i personally appreciate it so we
appreciate you appearing before us today
and let me turn to my colleague and
friend the ranking member of the
committee uh senator leahy and then
we'll turn to you for your statement and
thank you mr chairman and
you said we appreciate the controversies
probably more than the director does but
uh
he is he has handled them with aplomb
and i agree with you on that
we're um in these hearings we're seeking
accountability on behalf of the american
people we seek the continued improvement
as we should be in operations of the fbi
it's an important component of federal
law enforcement
i would hope that nobody would use the
proceedings as an opportunity to inquire
into ongoing investigations or to score
partisan points because
law enforcement should be
non-partisan not even bipartisan should
be non-partisan
when director free join
rejoined the bureau i should say in 1993
become director he'd been a federal
prosecutor he'd been a federal district
court judge he had been an fbi agent
but he also came in and inherited a
number of problems
he's had during his tenure to deal with
an increasingly partisan congress
that is quick to find political bias
whenever law enforcement or
prosecutorial decision is not
to the majority's liking
despite
very steady and dramatic decreases in
the violent crime rate
director free has presided over an fbi
at a time when we've had to confront the
reality of terrorist acts within our
borders something that
in this democracy we have not seen in
the past
i consider a defining characteristic of
the director to be his willingness to
recognize when problems exist to
acknowledge them publicly and most
importantly to seek
solutions to them and in my opinion he's
doing a very good job in that respect
uh respect for law and lawful authority
has been under attack in this country
over the last several years
now we've seen it in whether it's from
militia groups or whether it's in the
attitude of too many in this country
but i think that one thing we have to do
is to continue
and to always increase confidence in our
law enforcement officials in a democracy
law enforcement works and works best if
it has the confidence of the people
you cannot
mandate
that conference uh confidence by law or
by fiat
it might be able to a dictatorship you
cannot in a democracy
and one way you
instill confidence is if there have been
mistakes admit them take corrective
actions
and
in my view mr director you have been and
continue to be the right director at the
helm of the fbi
uh i would hope
that some of the rumors have flown in
this town that you may
be considering leaving that helm are not
so
i would hope you would stay
i mentioned before that when i was a
young vermont prosecutor i had a lot of
occasions to work with the fbi and
another and also during that time to
meet with
then director of the fbi uh j edgar
hoover
i have a lot of respect for the men and
women who serve the public as agents and
employees at the bureau
but i believe that the approach that you
have had a far more open one than your
predecessors has been the better one
openness
is a source of strength and confidence
in the bureau and in our democracy and
again as i said
law enforcement in a democracy works
only when it is open it's diminished
when it is closed
we've um
should note in this regard how well it
can work the fbi under the direction of
director free contributed mightily to
the investigation the apprehension and
the successful prosecution
of the perpetrator of the bombing of the
mura federal building in oklahoma city
two years ago
early this week a jury in the federal
courthouse in denver colorado rendered
guilty verdicts against timothy mcvay
in connection with one of the most
horrific crimes certainly
my lifetime but also the lifetime of
this
country i might note
mr chairman unlike
some
very noted trials we've seen of late
it was good to see a judge
a prosecution team and a defense team
work with the
utmost of
ability
you know trying a case the way a case
should be tried
not as some
prime time television show
but as
a pursuit of justice
now after the incidents uh the director
of free inherited ruby ridge and waco he
strengthened the use of alternative
approaches and negotiations before
specially trained marksmen are deployed
in hostage and barricade situations
he helped revise the justice
department's deadly force policy the
peaceful resolution of 81 day standoff
with the montana freeman is an example
of that
we've had um
he's agreed to implement many of the
reforms recommended by the inspector
general after exhaustive review
of fbi crime lab operations and i'll
have further questions on that
i sanction the agents responsible for
the mistreatment of richard jewell
suspended those suspected wrongdoing in
connection with the aftermath of the
ruby ridge
matter
the director worked with you to pass the
how past the violent crime control and
law enforcement act of 94 the
communications assistance for law
enforcement act the anti-terrorism
act following the oklahoma city and
world trade bombings we're going to be
working on encryption legislation
privacy protected legislation senator
spector and i will
be releasing the communication privacy
in the digital age
report in
tomorrow
we'll be working
on
on those matters there are a lot of us
up here
on both sides of the aisle that want to
work with you to make better law
enforcement will continue to thank you
mr chair thank you
senator lee he appreciate your remarks
uh director free we'll take your
testimony at this time thank you mr
chairman senator leahy uh all the
members of the committee thank you also
for your
remarks and support
it's uh as always a pleasure and an
honor to appear before this committee
and just to thank you
initially for all the support you've
shown to the
fbi over many many years
um mr chairman with your permission i
have a lengthy statement if i could
submit that for the record without
objection we'll place it in the record
thank you and i'll perhaps just take a
few minutes to give an overview of it
the
the year 1997 as uh
as the years right before it have been
years of great uh change dynamic change
for the fbi for instance since
july of 1994
we've hired as you know over 2500 agents
over 3 000 other support employees which
is upwards of 30 percent of our
compliment
we have been given
new jurisdictions both domestically and
internationally
the congress has approved the
dramatic expansion of our
ligat program which is a necessary
component both in our criminal programs
as well as our counterterrorism and
organized crime programs
our counterterrorism program has doubled
over the last two years
since we all agreed that that was a
threat where the country was
particularly vulnerable both at home and
abroad
uh
new
uh jurisdictions for the fbi and health
fraud area a statute which the congress
gave jurisdiction to the fbi last year
the economic espionage statute
the counter-terrorism statute
uh many of the
ways that the fbi has been doing
business over uh the last few decades
have been changed how we respond to
critical incidents
the review and the
implementation of the changes in the
post-waco and post-ruby ridge period
during all that period
we have been certainly an organization
which has been subject to
controversies changes
uh crises and as you said mr chairman
both on the plus and minus side
i am very proud to be the fbi director
i give all the credit for our successes
to the dedicated men and women who
perform
a very difficult and a very dangerous
job
and i certainly take
direct and personal responsibility for
any of the failings and problems that
we've had
certainly since my tenure but even
before that
sometimes
not only in law enforcement but in other
endeavors
we don't always note the safe landings
at the airport there's a tendency and
it's appropriate to do so
to focus on the problems and the crises
and that's certainly the scrutiny which
we
should have and do have
but as was mentioned in
some of the opening remarks
we are in the business of safe landings
the fbi and the people who work
on the front lines in law enforcement
both federal state and local are in the
business of establishing and
uh preserving the safe landings uh the
freeman standoff uh one case in point
the investigation and apprehension of
the suspect in the unabomber case
the prevention
uh last year
with respect to a plan
to down 11 us airliners
flying in the western pacific the
apprehension of four
major espionage agents
arresting over 900 telemarketers who
prey on
elderly people
many many other things which
i know this committee takes cognizance
of
and we like to think of that as the
routine work of the fbi we like to look
at the
work done in the
case which was convicted earlier in the
week as the routine work of the fbi
which in my view is
excellent work
uh this is not meant to minimize the
problems that we do experience problems
which i said i take full responsibility
for
i think the measure of how we deal with
those problems however is the
recognition that they exist
the honest and open treatment of those
events
and the quick
and effective response
taken to correct those
and it's been my
commitment and i hope i've succeeded in
part in trying to do that with all of
the instances that have
become problems and controversies for
the fbi certainly in the last three and
a half years
i think the oversight of this committee
the hearings
the continuous
scrutiny and support which you you
provide
is exactly what the fbi needs and which
i hope we respond to
very positively
i'd like to speak a little bit for a few
moments about
the future of law enforcement
where i think the fbi needs to go with
respect to the
preparation
for fighting crime in the 21st century
we have a graduation of new agents on
friday as you know we've been graduating
about 50 agents every two weeks
in addition to their credentials and
firearms now we give them all a laptop
computer when they graduate
it is
both symptomatic and symbolic of the new
venues in which they will work
where the fbi of the information age
chases fugitives through cyberspace as
well as over fences
where people sitting across the ocean in
a laptop computer
can intrude into our banks
move millions of dollars around
shut down critical industries and
infrastructure
a world where with all the wonders of
the internet
we now have the predators particularly
the individuals who are sexual predators
directing their efforts towards children
who can use that wonderful technology
to commit horrific crimes
we are still working as you noted mr
chairman very hard to
establish the kalia protocols to ensure
that
in the information age
not only the fbi but law enforcement
will be able to use probably our most
important uh criminal as well as
national security technique which is
court authorized surveillance
and we appreciate very much the support
which the congress and this committee in
particular has given us
in that regard
international crime and terrorism
are becoming much more commonplace
the disappearance of borders the
telecommunications revolution
and the mobility of ideas and people and
money
have really challenged the fbi
in ways not here for contemplated
we still remain committed as we must to
the fight against traditional crimes
violent crimes
crimes against children
crimes in cities large and small
most police departments in the united
states
are made up of
forces with less than
a dozen sworn officers
that requires in the information age the
assistance of larger particularly
federal law enforcement agencies
to provide both the criminal justice
services the forensic services
and the telecommunications support
necessary to protect all of us
health fraud care
fraud
civil rights problems
the explosion of
drug trafficking particularly by
sophisticated
cartels with great technology
organized crime which is not really
subsided in many venues the emergence of
new organized crime groups
these are all traditional problems
which must be dealt with at the same
time that we're preparing
for new challenges using new
technologies
the ncic 2000 and the iafis projects i'm
proud to report
are on target now for operation in the
summer of 1999.
these are vast new technologies with
imaging capabilities that will dazzle
the
expectations
that we once had about the
transmission of
criminal justice information and the
quick apprehension of criminals
the encryption issue as you mentioned
mr chairman and senator leahy
is a very important public safety issue
as well as an economic issue
and we look forward as we have
to working with the congress as well as
the industry
in ensuring that while we have robust
encryption which we are strong
supporters of
we also have in that encryption network
some safety valves for the protection of
public safety
and we're working very closely with the
committees in that regard
uh we are more and more concerned about
the protection of critical
infrastructures
the industries
not just
relating to
energy and transportation and
telecommunications
but banking industries
vast networks which depend on
computer and cyber based technologies to
exist
the shutting down of the new york stock
exchange or the
closing down of utility plants in the
northeast during winter
are serious and realistic new threats
that we need to deal with we're working
very closely
in intergovernmental
capacities to deal with those problems
one of our endeavors is our seatac
program
the computer
investigations and threat assessment
center
where we are taking inventories of
vulnerability vulnerabilities in the
infrastructures and hardening those
areas as well as defining investigative
strategies to succeed
with respect to the fbi laboratory
we have adopted as you know
all of the recommendations of the
inspector general we are well on our way
to accreditation of that laboratory
we are in the midst of looking for a
world-class scientist from outside the
fbi to come in and run that laboratory
we're very confident
that that new director
will bring the laboratory into the 21st
century
implement all of the necessary reforms
as found by the inspector general
and uh complete the construction
of the state of state-of-the-art
laboratory which is now being built will
be built this fall
down in quantico virginia
the laboratory technologies including
drug fire and codis
have been pioneering techniques uh which
are now shared with our state and local
partners
uh it is a laboratory which in my view
is the finest forensic laboratory in the
world
and
although we take the
uh
the criticisms and the findings with the
utmost seriousness and recognize
failings and scientific protocols
as well as management including my own
with respect to the laboratory over the
last few years
we're confident that the implementation
of
all of the recommendations the
accreditation of the new laboratory and
a new director
including over a hundred civilian
analysts who have been hired into the
laboratory
will make that even a stronger
institution uh in the years to come
again with respect to counterterrorism
both pursuant to the presidential
directive 39
and the
legislation
from the congress which authorizes the
training
of state and local officials
in emergency preparedness particularly
in the areas of chemical nuclear and
biological events
that is going forward
with great coordination uh the
establishment of the
hazardous materials unit in the
laboratory
uh has given us new capacity to deal
forensically and investigatively
with what we fear to be
a more imminent threat
from those particular
areas than heretofore recognized
we have established as you know at fbi
headquarters a counter-terrorism center
we have representatives from 16 other
federal agencies including over 100 fbi
personnel
where for the first time we can
centrally collect and analyze
information
dealing both with
events relating to domestic and
international terrorism
with the primary objective of preventing
those problems
but also giving us the capacity to
respond better in a coordinated fashion
the international law enforcement
academy
in budapest
which is a intergovernmental effort
has been very successful
in giving us the ability to train as
well as to
make liaison
with a whole new generation of police
officers and police leaders in central
and eastern europe who will quickly
become the leaders of those departments
and of great interest and importance to
the carrying out of our law enforcement
capabilities here in the united states
we appreciate the
approval which congress gave to our
four-year expansion plan and are working
very hard to achieve that
we've reorganized our office of
professional responsibility at the fbi
we have brought in to run that office
michael defeo who is a 30-year plus
veteran of the department of justice
we have doubled his resources to give
him the ability to investigate
more efficiently
at the same time giving to the subjects
of those investigations
some due process rights which heretofore
were not provided
i think it is essential
that the fbi maintain its ability and
authority to police itself
i think that in addition to our own opr
structure which has been very successful
in past years
we have the oversight of the department
opr the inspector general
the deputy attorney general and of
course
four separate oversight committees
i think the lesson of the nap commission
in new york was clear that if an agency
loses the ability to police itself
you take away a primary incentive for
the members of that organization
to act appropriately and within the
boundaries of their authority
we have across the country now over 152
safe street task forces those are
task forces made up of fbi agents over
700 of them
and 30 and 1100 state and local officers
who direct specific localized activity
against gangs
violent crime offenders
fugitives and we're very very proud of
that success the mayor in hartford
connecticut
attributed the fbi safe street task
force
in large part
to the 51
percent decrease in the murder rate
between 1996
1995 and 1996.
our white-collar crime programs which
are the largest single group of programs
in the fbi
uh continue to be effective
we work very closely with the inspector
generals of many other departments
particularly in the health fraud area
we work also very closely with many of
the
military
criminal investigative units in some of
the
health fraud cases as well as the fraud
against the government cases
since
1996 actually october of 1996
the fbi efforts
with respect to our health fraud
programs have been instrumental in
achieving
settlements
from three national laboratory
investigations
of 625 million dollars
the senior sentinel case which is a
telemarketing case
directed against people who prey on the
elderly
has resulted in over 900 people being
charged
we have implemented a new three-year
program to deal with hate crimes in 1995
there were nearly 8 000 reported hate
crimes in the united states
we see that as a
growing problem
and one against which we are going to
direct additional resources
crimes against children has become a
very important priority of the fbi
i've recently directed each of our
offices to
designate two special agents to be
responsible for the crimes against
children program
i established back in 1995
the
serial killer and child abduction unit
in quantico which has been very
effective in operationally assisting
many small as well as large police
departments around the country
in very difficult and very agonizing
cases particularly those involving
children
the innocent images case which is a
initiative directed against
individuals who prey on children and
send child pornography through the
internet has been a very successful
undertaking with over a hundred
different convictions
with respect to
some of the drug initiatives
we've been working very closely with the
dea as well as general mccaffrey's
office
to institute and support the southwest
border initiative which has had some
measured success
we recently have initiated a
major counter drug
initiative down in san juan which will
influence
trafficking in the eastern caribbean
and we're very pleased that all the
agencies
participating in that including justice
and treasury agencies have coordinated
that effort very well
and contributed many
resources
we're working to
implement the economic espionage statute
which the congress gave us authority to
investigate last year as you know we
have approximately 23 countries
who maintain
active and clandestine economic
espionage
pursuits in the united states and we're
working very hard to use this new
criminal statute
to protect the country
against that which directly affects our
national security
as i mentioned earlier
we are certainly aware and cognizant of
various problems that we've had i've
mentioned the laboratory
with respect to the
controversy which you mentioned mr
chairman about the fbi files
as you know
about a year ago actually just about a
year ago
we changed the
procedure by which
people could access the summaries of fbi
files
that system was a system which was in
place since the johnson administration
uh nine days after we saw there was a
problem
in 1996
we instituted a complete new set of
requirements where now
the consent of the person who is the
subject of that summary
is required before we will release the
file or a signed explanation by a white
house counsel why such consent cannot be
obtained
we have many more
checks and balances in that system
we require
detailed information under perjury
penalties with respect to its request
and we are satisfied that
that system which was a
vulnerability and for one which i take
responsibility
of many many years long standing has now
been corrected
again with respect to the
critical incident response group
that is a major reform initiated
directly as a result of the problems in
waco and ruby ridge
i'm very proud to report that
as we've deployed
the critical incident response group
since 1995
we have had great success including the
freeman
situation in montana
but many other incidents which
don't get
noted we're happy they're not noted
because they're free of problems
presidential conventions
the inauguration
the summit the pope's visit to new york
the 50th anniversary of the united
nations
we feel very confident that the reforms
embodied in the critical incidence
response group where we balance very
carefully our tactical and non-tactical
resources
uh will serve the fbi and the country
very well in the years to come
uh very briefly just wrapping up
we appreciate very much the
past funding by the congress for the
clear efforts
as you know we've asked for additional
funding for 1998
to complete
the
reformation of both the embedded base as
well as
encouraging the
technological reforms and fixes which
are contemplated and required by the
statute
we're working very hard as i noted with
respect to solving
the encryption issue from a law
enforcement point of view and appreciate
your support
very much
we are seeking again
some consideration for the multi-point
uh electronic surveillance authority as
you now know under the
title 18 provisions
uh if you're seeking a
microphone
you only need to show that it's not
practical
to identify a particular location to get
a multi-point authority from a district
court judge
conversely if you're seeking a telephone
authority you have to make a specific
showing that the individual is
consciously avoiding
surveillance which is a very difficult
showing to make
and we're requesting not new authority
but simply that we equate
the application requirements for
microphones and telephones
in a era where people use clone phones
for an hour and throw them away
steal clone numbers
and work with great mobility and
rapidity so we're not asking for new
authority there we're asking that the
authority be equated for microphone
surveillance and telephone surveillance
just let me conclude briefly by saying
that again i'm very
pleased to
to be here before you i'm very proud of
the fbi
i attended a uh
graduation yesterday at fbi headquarters
it's called our junior special agent
program we had approximately 250
sixth graders from five elementary
schools in the district of columbia
where fbi volunteers work
throughout the school year mentoring
teaching
setting forth
role models as well as
ideas
for these young men and women to uh look
up to and and respond to
we have across the fbi about 7 000
volunteers who work in 150 schools and
who make contact with hundreds of
thousands of children every year in our
community outreach programs we're very
proud of that
again it's a part of the fbi that
doesn't get
a lot of publicity we certainly don't
seek it but it is a fine
testament in my view to the men and
women of law enforcement particularly in
the fbi
who not only take substantial risks for
themselves and their families
in their in their work
i've had the tragedy of four special
agents
killed in the line of duty as director
another one who was killed
in montana the only casualty in the
freeman siege was an fbi agent who was
killed in a car accident
which is not actually that well known
but those are the things that the men
and women in law enforcement do
they also find time to
work in their communities
and improve hopefully the lives of the
people they touch
again i'm very happy to be here and i
look forward to
trying to respond to your questions
thank you mr director uh
i might mention that uh
carl malone indicated to me that he'd
like to be an fbi agent someday who is
of course the
most valuable player in the national
basketball association
uh
i'm going to with the permission of
senator grassley who was here first i'm
going to defer my time to senator
spector who has requested
so that he can go ahead we're going to
have 10-minute runs
and we'll go back and forth and we'll
start with senator spencer thank you
very much mr chairman for yielding your
time to me
thank you senator grassley
uh
director free
i compliment the department of justice
and the fbi trial prosecutors and all
those involved in the
successful prosecution of timothy
mcveigh very very important case
i would note that in the absence of our
1994
crime bill we would not have had
the availability of the death penalty
which the jury will be considering today
and would further note the strong trial
judge
presiding over that case distinguished
from
the trial illustrative of o.j simpson
where matters went to the jury which the
trial judge should not have permitted
the trial judge can control
what the lawyers on both sides do
including
closing statements
and with so much today about
nullification with some
defense lawyers blatantly asking juries
to acquit
even though they think the defendant is
guilty because of collateral
circumstances
very very important to have a strong
trial judge there
the war against terrorism is obviously
at the top of the agenda and we have
urged you in the past to let us know
what additional resources you need
i've expressed the concern uh that with
some 2500 agents coming in july of 1994
which you noted in a 30 increase in your
complement the
difficulties which you may have in
ingesting
that kind of additional personnel and in
the enormous number of additional
responsibilities which
the fbi has undertaken and i again
express my confidence and support for
your administration and compliment you
on
a job well done notwithstanding a great
many problems i think you run an agency
which has grown very very fast perhaps
too fast
and there are very heavy oversight
responsibilities which the congress has
to undertake which we did last year with
ruby ridge and
i'm looking forward to doing a
conjunction with senator kyle on the
atlanta incident but these are matters
which which we have to take a look at
but overall i think
you've done a very good job
i want to ask you on
domestic terrorism
about a report
from the
deputy education minister of moshe
poland published in the jerusalem post
on march 26th
relating to the new york world trade
center bombing
where six americans were killed and
thousands were injured
that yasser arafat
according to
peled quote he was a part of the
discussions
on the operations close quote
i wrote to the attorney general on april
1st asking
for an inquiry on that subject because
under long arm jurisdiction which we
passed in 1984 and 1986 the
we could try arafat in this country if
there's evidence to support that
and
i got a response back from
the deputy attorney general
assistant attorney general saying quote
we have queried the israeli authorities
about this information and they deny the
accuracy
of the statements attributed the article
to the deputy education minister close
quote
which of course is not the point point
is not what the
deputy education minister said the point
is what arafat did and i wrote the
attorney general again on
may 14th and asked
that the matter
be pursued as a matter of
really
grave significance
the state department has replied that
the matter is in your hands and i would
i would ask if there's anything you can
say appropriately for the record at this
time in this open hearing on the matter
senator i'm aware that
we've been tasked to make some inquiries
i do not know what the results of those
inquiries are but i i do commit to you
that
after the hearing i will go back and get
a
update and uh i'll report to you
whatever i can either
through this committee or through the
intelligence committee i i do not have
the answers to those inquiries and i
will promptly get them for you well i
would appreciate that we have
a 500
appropriation for the palestinian
authority and it is specifically
contingent and conditioned on an
amendment introduced by senator shelby
and myself
on pastors arafat's fighting terrorism
we have the incident
on march 21st of the bombing of a tel
aviv cafe three israelis were killed and
many were wounded
where the israeli prime minister has
said that
arafat gave
a green light for that
secretary of state albright in testimony
before the foreign operations
subcommittee two weeks ago said there
wasn't a green light that said that
arafat did not give a red light
and in the absence of a red light i
think that
arafat is
in violation of our standards for giving
the aid so that we really have to stay
on top of
what chairman arafat does and especially
as it relates to the world trade center
bombing where u.s citizens were were
killed
director free i want to turn
now to the subject of
independent counsel
and the
issue which i discussed at some length
with
attorney general reno when she was
before this committee recently
and that relates to
the withholding of certain information
and attorney general reno testified
quote
director free began the briefing by
telling mr burger that he would not go
into certain matters because of the
ongoing
criminal investigation close quote
and
president clinton has been quoted
as saying
quote there are significant national
security issues at stake here close
quote
and i believe i should have known
quote i believe i should have known
close quote
the questions that i have on this
subject are are twofold
first what is the authority of the
fbi or the department of justice
in withholding national security
information to the president
because if given a choice on an
uninformed president
or some concern about a pending
investigation and i'm very concerned
about pending investigations been
working on them for a long time myself
i would rather have an informed
president and the second aspect of the
of the issue is
that if there is sufficient reason to
deny the president of the united states
national security information because of
the
investigation into campaign financing
isn't there at least a basis for the
appointment of independent counsel
senator with respect to the first part
of your question
i don't believe the fbi has any
authority to withhold the national
security information from either the
president or the attorney general
when there is the rare instance i
believe it is a rare instance where a
ongoing criminal investigation is also
simultaneously developing or evaluating
national security information
i think the
attorney general has to make a decision
as she has in every case that i'm aware
of
whether
the need for the
protection of the criminal investigation
outweighs the
constitutional authority to report
national security information director
free for me to interrupt you just for a
second on that do you know of any you
say not uh do you know of any other case
where national security information has
been
withheld from the president
on the grounds of a pending uh criminal
investigation or otherwise
um not
not during my tenure here but i don't um
i don't
agree with the contention that national
security information was withheld from
the president i think the
form in which he received it
uh in the matter which i believe you're
referring to
was a
form different from the one that was
originally proposed but i think the
attorney general made a decision that
gave to the president in my view and the
attorney general's view the national
security information that
he was required to have
well director free the president says
that quote there are national security
issues at stake here
i believe i should have known his
conclusion differs from yours he says he
says there are national security matters
which were withheld isn't it a fact that
uh his counsel uh
charles ruff sent a a letter to the
justice department asking for specific
information
and that those answers were not provided
because of objection from the fbi they
were certainly not provided in the forum
that was proposed and drafted but
in response to that request
the white house counsel's office was
given a series of teletypes
communications and documents which
they'd actually already received
which in my view and the attorney
general's view accurately described the
national security information president
also said i think after those remarks
that he understood that the
the fbi i think he was really referring
to the department of justice has a dual
responsibilities when a criminal case is
paralleled with a national security
matter and that he was confident that
the attorney general could make that
decision and achieve that balance and my
view is that she's done that uh
properly director free one final
question my yellow light is on on the
matter
of some substantial sensitivity
and that is the
report which appeared in the washington
post on may 7th that you had
given your judgment to the attorney
general that independent counsel ought
to be appointed because of the potential
conflict of interest now
i'm aware of the sensitivity of the
issue you are an employee of the
department of justice you work for the
attorney general and there has to be
obviously freedom of discussion between
the director of the fbi and the attorney
general of the united states and it's an
area of real sensitivity but i believe
that
this issue of independent council is so
important to the country
and there are so many matters relating
to it
questions that many of us raised in the
hearings about
the withholding of the information we've
talked about and
whether you had advocacy
ads or issue ads
that i believe
it is an appropriate question to be
asked and i think that it ought to be
answered so i would
ask you at this time if
you did give the attorney general your
judgment that there ought to be
independent counsel appointed
senator i certainly understand the
the import of the question it is uh
certainly an important matter
with the
with the greatest respect however
my view is that the
the views that i've given to the
attorney general which he has asked for
on this matter in particular
are really confidential
discussions and advice that i've given
her she has the authority under the
statute to make the decision no one else
does the statute only contemplates the
attorney general making that decision
she has been open-minded about
discussions with me she has asked my
opinion i've given it to her but i think
it's just not
fair for me or appropriate for me to
divulge that publicly she was certainly
before you for her hearing and i'd be
happy to take the matter up with her in
terms of a disclosure but i don't feel
like it's appropriate for me to do that
now well i'm not surprised i'm not i'm
not all right i'm not surprised by your
answer and i understand the sensitivity
and close call i do think under the
circumstances at issue here that it
ought to be answered which is why i
asked it but i would
ask you as you've suggested for you to
pursue it with her
and
give us an answer if you possibly can
i'll do that thank you very much thank
you mr chairman thank you senator thank
you and i'm going to try and maintain
the 10-minute rule here so i hope
everybody will observe it
and you have so i appreciate it senator
feinstein
thank you very much
mr chairman i wanted to try to get this
has to be with the understanding of
senator lee comes back i'll i'll
interrupt and let him
have his time that's fine that's fine
um welcome director free i wanted
to try to get through three areas of
questioning the first is
diversity the second is a ruby ridge
follow-up and the third is
the health care fraud issue
i've received a letter from a san
francisco-based large coalition of
minority groups called the green lining
institute
and they're critical
of the lack of diversity within the fbi
uh according to senator what is the name
of that group it's called the green
lining institute and i'll be happy to
see that you get a copy of the letter
that was sent to me
they contend that in the top 44 upper
management positions
senior executive service level five and
up
there are no asian americans no
hispanics one woman and only four
african-americans
and in the
178 senior executive service positions
none were held by asian americans
among the fbi staff as a whole
your record is better people of color
represent approximately 24 percent
of fbi staff is compared with 17
of the general population
my question really is that do you think
the lack of managerial diversity has an
impact on the performance of the fbi and
do you take any plan you do you have any
plans uh to do anything about it
um senator i think it's critical that
the the fbi
not only
maintain but enhance and promote
diversity particularly at the highest
levels i'm actually surprised to hear
from that letter i've certainly not
heard about it before
i think the diversity
statistics in the fbi are really quite
quite good
starting at the lower level
i think about 32 or 34 percent of our
new agents now are women in minorities
when i became director all of the
assistant directors which is the top
echelon of management
were white males since then i've
appointed two females
two african-americans a hispanic who
unfortunately
passed away as a assistant director i've
appointed seven african-american sacs uh
five hispanic americans three females
which had never been done before
uh i'm really quite surprised to look at
that to you i'd like be interested to
see the letter and talk to them but i'll
provide you those numbers in a in a more
formalized manner but i think
across the board
except in some of the
upper
but not highest management levels we
have some
deficiencies
deficiencies going back you know 20
years but i think we're well on the way
to correcting them
i'll send this letter down to you it's
signed by a large number of people and
knowing the attorney for this coalition
i think it's worthy of i'll be happy to
review and
comment thank you
um
as you know i i believe it was under
senator spector's chairmanship uh this
the terrorism subcommittee uh uh held
hearings on on the ruby ridge affair
and the justice department's office of
professional responsibility put together
a task force to study the events and
made a number of recommendations for
changes at the fbi
i asked the attorney general
about these recommendations when she
appeared before the committee in april
she said that she would get back to me
has not done so yet and so while you're
here i'd like to
ask you about the status of the
recommended policy changes one of the
recommendations made by the task force
was the establishment of the crisis
response team
which the fbi followed by forming the
critical incident response group
i know that the
group was deployed to montana in the
freeman situation and you alluded to
that in your comments uh first question
is has it been deployed anywhere else
since its formation yes uh there's a
number of deployments centered i'll be
happy to detail them to you to
communication one for instance we had a
a drug case down in san juan a
location referred to as a casaria which
is a very very large housing project
thousands and thousands of people
where the the government of puerto rico
and the police did not maintain law
enforcement
presence or capability because of the
control that the drug gangs had over
that particular unit it was like a
fortress and even our agents and swat
teams in san juan did not think they
could safely apprehend the arrest hrt
was deployed
did the surveys made the arrests without
any incident
we've used them not as a whole team
which was that deployment but in part
to do many different things the
presidential conventions the
inauguration
they advise frequently in the field
where there are difficult apprehensions
or
potential hostage situations and i'm
proud to say that all those deployments
have been very very successful without
any injuries or incidents
have you had an opportunity to see
whether it can meet its own goal of
responses to simultaneous events
um i think uh
first of all we're we're down in terms
of the
the complement number we have about 78
operators we should have 91 and we have
a
a recruitment
in july and one in september which
hopefully by the end of the year will
bring us up to the complement
we rely not only on the hrt operators
but we have nine enhanced swat teams
which have which was not the case uh
several years ago one of the uh
post waco
uh
reforms or changes that we made were to
enhance nine of our swat teams around
the country they train with hrt
they have similar capability except one
particular tactical
ability
and they respond and can respond
almost in lieu of the operators in some
cases we also have
some of the
hrt graduates the alumni who run the
swat teams around the country who are
called back for emergencies so
within reasonable limits i think we
could handle
i don't want to say how many but we
could handle more than one
crisis at a time using the enhanced swat
teams and the other capability that we
have
if you go from the 78 to the 91 how many
simultaneous events then could you
respond to again it would depend on the
size of the event i mean we could we
could split the team into two parts if
there were two
crises which
could be addressed by those resources we
might
have a crisis i hope we don't where all
91 would not be enough we'd have to
bring in enhanced teams and we're
organized to do that very quickly if we
can
the report also recommended that fbi
field offices that don't have an
evidence response team in place to
recover evidence after major
hostage or barricade crises
like ruby ridge should request the
assistance of the evidence response team
at fbi headquarters has this been done
yes we also have a evidence response
team now in every office in every office
yes in fact the one in california was
responsible for taking the uh the pawn
print uh in polyclosure's bedroom we
have one now in every office but we also
enhance that and support that with
with headquarters resources when
necessary
and could you tell us several fbi agents
were referred to the u.s attorney's
office for possible prosecution i
believe at least one has been indicted
for de destruction of the after action
report
what's the status of that prosecution
um i don't know senator with respect to
the
the individuals who remain in that limbo
one of them as you know was exonerated
he's the asac in baltimore who was
restored to duty after the prosecutor
advised the department that there were
no
charges
two of them uh remain in a uh in an
unknown state we're not privy to that
grand jury uh i wish i i knew what the
progress was and i hope that they
make some decisions as quickly as they
can because these people's lives have
been in limbo for
well over a year and a half now
since the waco
and the ruby ridge hearings and the
reforms that you have made
are you satisfied with them do you
believe that you now have the structure
the organization and the command
communication to
effectively handle
without having to repeat the the waco
problems to effectively handle any major
hostage barricade situation
senator i'm very confident that we have
a very uh
good and capable present ability to deal
with those issues i don't think it's
perfect i think there's still areas
where we could improve but if i look at
the the freeman situation as a as a
layover to
waco and ruby ridge
you know in waco and ruby ridge the fbi
really wasn't prepared
to handle those uh events we sent in our
rescue team but there were no hostages i
think the changes and the
implementation of those changes and the
exercise of those changes particularly
in montana shows that we have a very
strong and more diverse capability to
alternate
tactical and non-tactical operations i
think we're prepared to be more patient
and i think we have greater capability
am i perfectly satisfied no
uh and i'm afraid
there could be events that
would be so
overwhelming or not contemplated that
even our current resources would be
inadequate but i feel very confident
that we have
the tools in place to do most of our
requirements let me ask one quick
question on that
and i have never the result of the
hearings i was never really and then the
follow-up quite satisfied as to where
the final command responsibility rested
whether it was with the field commander
or in washington at headquarters could
you clear that up
i could certainly give you the uh
the situation in in montana the
the field commander
who alternated
at different times would certainly have
the authority to make a decision under
exigent circumstances if there was a
life-and-death situation
involved if a hostage was about to be
killed or
something along those lines
he would have the authority in the field
to make a decision without running it by
headquarters for the obvious reasons
other than that all of the decisions all
of the critical
policy making even during the crisis was
coordinated with headquarters and
overseen by
if not myself the deputy director the
assistant director in charge of the
criminal division so it was those were
decisions which will be
controlled as best we can from
headquarters but leaving the field
commander the authority to preserve life
if necessary well just to be clear so
that if there were a non-emergency
action that had to be taken
the responsible party for giving the
green light to that action would be the
washington deputy director yes or myself
that's where the that's where the
responsibility will clearly lay now
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you senator senator grassley mr free
my father's occupation was
farming in iowa
and
in the 40s and 50s when i was growing up
he
taught me to respect the fbi
i
come
to washington with a great deal of
respect for the fbi i know that my
criticism of senior management
in the last year probably doesn't show
that i was brought up that way
but
it's not easy for me to think of my
father's respect for the fbi that they
could do no wrong and find some of the
things wrong because in decades of
public service i've
never known an agency that right now is
in need of more oversight including
congressional oversight than the fbi
and that's after a year of digging into
issues that the bureau has been involved
with
we all respect the good things that the
fbi does we know that there's thousands
of agents out there in the field that
are putting their lives
on the line and
most americans have
the image of the fbi is
very good beyond reproach the
untouchables
the fbi has cultivated that image i'm
sure you probably disagree with that
statement
but serious problems with the crime lab
punctured that image also ruby ridge and
waco have
beyond the veneer is an ugly culture of
arrogance
it uses this information intimidation
empire building
to get what it wants and i've got some
documentation if you're interested in
in my uh feeling about
intimidation and disinformation
it resists oversight
by an independent body
it resists cooperation and information
sharing with state and local law
enforcement
now i want to show some examples of
these i find that the fbi sometimes uses
intimidation tactics when it wants to
get its own way
when i have made inquiries sometimes
they simply refuse to respond
that's not what legitimate oversight is
about
it suggests that there's something to
hide
and that's why problems like the fbi
crime lab
are allowed to exist and fester
so long without detection
in that case maybe about eight years
while congress has given the fbi more
money
than can be spent wisely
for instance we triple the amount of
money in just five years of combating
terrorism
it reminds me of how congress mindlessly
pumped up the defense budget during the
80s and all that we did was increase the
price of what we bought
hammers pliers and toilet seats
in this case
i think that we need to carefully
examine every nook and cranny of the
fbi's budget to make sure we're getting
what was advertised
and i intend to be a part of that effort
in the coming months
because what i have found is that senior
management within the fbi
puts too much focus on its image and
budget
and not enough on product
and that product should be law
enforcement and public safety in that
respect
this hearing mr chairman is much needed
but the director is
pressed for time
so i've decided to limit the amount of
questions and then i'm going to insert a
lot of documents in the record
mr free uh
i recently saw dr whitehurst the crime
lab whistleblower on tv
he was asked what he thought about the
way the justice department
and the fbi had criticized him
the criticism came despite dr
whitehurst's success in calling
attention to the lab's problems
dr whitehurst responded that he thought
the criticism was great because it
allowed the public to see what they do
in washington to shoot the messenger
i can't tell you how many people come up
to me puzzled
about why the messenger is being shot
since he pointed out the wrongdoing
in his letter to you dated march the 6th
inspector general bromwich
states that the fbi had proposed for
over a year that dr whitehurst be fired
the ig was opposed to it
but for over a year the fbi was trying
to shoot the messenger it also sounds
like the fbi was intimidating the ig
into being harsh in its criticism of the
whistleblower
on april 15th
the day the ig's report
on the lab came out the fbi acknowledged
serious problems in the lab in my view
the
lab
reflects a failing of fbi senior
management so
question has the fbi finally resigned
itself to the fact that fred whitehurst
is not the problem and that the crime
lab and senior management are the
problem
senator i certainly don't think that
dr whitehurst is the problem i never
have and i've never
either said or promoted or supported
that
we are
thankful
for the
matters which were raised
in part
uh by mr whitehurst
and certainly followed through and
inspected uh fairly and thoroughly by
the inspector general's report he's not
the issue here the issue is as you point
out
substantial
failings mostly scientific failings in
the laboratory over many many years and
for the period that i've been director i
certainly take
direct responsibility i'm the ultimate
manager for the laboratory
we initiated as you know before the
inspector general
our own internal inquiry in the
laboratory which did not
unfortunately turn up the problems which
were sustained in the inspector general
report i think part of the problem was
we had not we didn't use
what the inspector general used which
was a very renowned group of outside
scientists who came in and as only
scientists can evaluate other scientists
did i think a top-notch job we are for
the record now
looking at all the other 20 units in the
laboratory internally we've gone out and
retained scientists independent
scientists to look at each one of the
other 20 units to see if we have
additional problems and we'll deal with
those forthrightly but i don't i don't
hold anyone certainly not
dr whitehurst responsible for our
problems with respect to
your questions about discipline or
matters relating to his uh
his work there
as you know i've been recused from those
and remain recused from those
however i rely on the inspector
general's report which
dealt with any issues of intimidation
with respect to dr whitehurst i
certainly don't think this inspector
general was intimidated by the fbi i
think the report was fair hard-hitting
accurate and
we're implementing all of his
recommendations
uh
the subject of the inspector general's
march sixth letter to you was a request
that you correct the record for your
testimony the day before you had just
testified before the house
appropriations subcommittee you had
stated that the sole reason for
suspending dr whitehurst was based on
the id's report
on him the ig called you on it because
that was an inaccurate and you admitted
that it was inaccurate and in my view
you were trying at that point to hide
behind the ig's report and use it to
justify what you clearly wanted to do
for over a year and that is
shoot the messenger your inaccurate
testimony and you're hiding behind the
ing report misled the public
do you wish to comment on that yeah i
take great exception to that i think
what happened there was very clear i
made a statement to a committee
as i've testified the
dozens and dozens of times over three
and a half years that was partially
correct but partially incorrect the
reason it was incorrect is i was recused
from all of those matters relating to
his
administrative leave and i was not aware
of that
as soon as
the inspector general brought it to my
attention i corrected the record i spoke
to chairman rogers who accepted my
explanation without any problem i
certainly wasn't hiding behind any
report i was correcting a mistake in my
testimony which i've done many times
and i would never
misrepresent to a congress or a
committee
never have and never will
well
that's your view and you're entitled to
your view
i see it as an effort to
get at a bearer of bad news
i think
what dr whitehurst was talking about for
eight years
you saw as hurting the fbi's image
i think you didn't inspect the product
as
mr espedy esposito had admitted in his
statement he says the problems
identified by the inspector general
should never been permitted to develop
there was a clear and serious failing
and not adequately detecting these
problems and many instances not moving
swiftly enough to resolve them and
that's after
eight years that there was a problem out
there
uh well i agree with that i certainly
don't see how you could characterize
that as trying to promote a uh another
different image
okay i want to place some things in the
record in 1994 when you were the new fbi
director you directed howard shapiro and
a team of lawyers to review the white
hearse allegations
in a report of that review dated may the
26 94 it is clear to me now that the fbi
was aware of the labs problems but white
washington
for instance it appears that you
learned of all the problems associated
with terry rudolph he was the lab senior
examiner and explosive residues
before dr
whitehurst was all of rudolph's cases
are now under red alert because of
sloppiness and improper procedure
pursuant to a foia
request
i was able to
get that may 94 report and the only and
this is the entire report but the only
section
on what uh on on
the only section that we can't see
is a section on what you uncovered
related to rudolph
i'd like to show you what uh
this is the section
uh you can see that there's not anything
there to get information on in other
words the fbi doesn't want to show the
public that it knew
and that you knew
back in 94 that there were serious
problems in the lab
and that's not all one of dr
whitehurst's allegations
was that his lab reports were being
altered
the may 94 report
white washed that allegation
yet through his persistence his unit
chief eventually investigated the same
allegation
the unit chief then received similar
allegations from a second lab scientist
as well
an investigation was done at that point
the unit chief found
that lab reports had been altered
intentionally
and it amounted to altering evidence and
the unit chief recommended disciplining
the culprit instead the culprit was
promoted on june the 12th 95 the
bureau's chief council noted in a memo
that altered reports could be subject
could subject the fbi to civil or
criminal liability so the fbi was
carefully fully aware
of the serious problem
uh well i i started before the red light
went on i'm i'm about ready to to ask
the
i got two pages here to ask the final
question
this was uh this is one of several
documents that i have dated from
november 4th 94
through september
94
showing that the fbi knew how serious
the problems were
of the lab
involving altering of reports
which amounted to of course altering
evidence which may have resulted in
civil or criminal liability and i'm
going to place these documents in the
record when dr whitehurst's allegations
finally became public
the
and that was right around the time that
you director free issued the following
statement
in response to the november 5th
uh november 8th
on november the 8th you said this to
date the fbi has found no evidence
tampering evidence fabrication or
failure to report exculpatory evidence
and finding of such misconduct will
result in tough and swiss action swift
action by the fbi and of course the
tough and swift action was to promote
the culprit tom thurman who incidentally
was one of those allegedly disciplined
based
on the ig report so in my view mr
director your comment on november 95 was
at best incomplete it misled the public
about whether problems existed in the
lab
and of course at that point the fbi's la
image was at stake and so your testimony
march 5th before the house
appropriations subcommittee was not the
first time
that you misled the public about this
issue um and you and i whatever your
comments on that my comment is very
clear i take great exceptions that if
that report uh i've got the documents i
know you have the document where your
people say that i got your statement
where you said it on november the 8th
and four months later i've got what you
said we disagree on your
characterization of the motive which is
very important but
we'll forget the motive what about the
facts
well the fact is i think that when we
did that internal review as i said it
was an inadequate review we did not
appreciate
either the problems or the significance
of what needed to be done by scientists
but if you look at the inspector
general's report which found no
obstruction of justice and no perjury
those findings were not all that
different from what we found in that
narrow area
well my point is that when the
statements of public officials don't
match the facts then that's when we have
credibility problems
well i agree but i think it's important
to understand what the what the nature
and what the motive of those statements
of the person who made those statements
i certainly didn't make any statements
to mislead anybody i certainly haven't
tried to
protect anybody's image at the expense
of honesty or truthfulness and i take
great exception to your suggestion
well you said uh something on march the
5th different than what you had said on
november
mr chairman i'm done
do you have anything else no
senator durbin
thank you mr chairman
before asking questions mr chairman
if i might uh as a matter of personal
privilege mr chairman
you noted earlier that
uh carl malone
was interested in being an fbi agent and
i would just like to make a matter of
statement for the record that
special agent michael jordan have any
cheap shots here
[Laughter]
special agent michael jordan got his man
last sunday night and i just wanted to
put that on the record
we'll see about tonight
and the remaining six games
i'm in trouble now director free thank
you for uh well you've used your time
i'm ready
am i finished
director free thanks for being with us
today i
senator spector asked the line of
questioning which we anticipated and i
think your response was appropriate
i hope you will concede that this
apparent leak from your agency
probably did a disservice to your agency
as well as your relationship with the
attorney general
and could
jeopardize at least some of the workings
important jobs being done in your agency
i know that your relationship with the
attorney general is very important i
also know that the
ability of the director of the fbi to
have communications with the attorney
general and
do so privately is also very important
i'd like to know
what you have done about this apparent
leak and what you think the impact of
this leak has been
on your agency and your relationship
with the attorney general well first of
all i don't know where the leak came
from uh i'm not
prepared to say that it came from the
fbi i hope it didn't i'm not ruling that
out i just don't know we
we are
bewildered and
burdened as you know not just in
in this particular matter but in almost
every other manner that we deal with in
washington uh with leaks i wish i had
the answer to that we
automatically uh initiate inquiries when
these matters happen we rarely
and very infrequently are able to
identify anyone uh if we were we would
take very
severe and very certain action
with respect to the the impact on our
relationship
i i don't think it's had any the
attorney general and i have a very
strong relationship we have a very good
personal relationship
uh she knows that uh if i had something
to say i'd say it publicly it's never
been my style to do it otherwise and
i think she
appreciates the confidence that we enjoy
on those matters and
i don't think it's affected the working
relationship between the fbi and
the department attorneys
i'm glad to hear that and i hope you are
following up on that because i believe
it's an important part of
your responsibility and it could
undermine the effectiveness of the
agency if it became
a
larger problem let me address a couple
other issues that i think are
worthy of concern you last month
directed your 56 field offices of the
fbi to
have at least two specifically trained
agents devoted solely to working on
crimes against children
i want to applaud you for that
one recent report indicated that over
four thousand children a year or
abducted by strangers in my home state
of illinois there have
been sad and unfortunate incidents when
that has occurred
i take it the part of the problem here
in terms of the fbi response to child
abduction
is
when it becomes a matter of interstate
concern or of statutory responsibility
for the fbi
do you feel that there are changes
needed in the law to give the fbi
the ability to make a quicker response
to these reported abductions
senator i i do not we have a policy
which i
reminded our sacs about natal type
several months ago that when there is a
a child abduction particularly one that
is a suspicious one
even without any of the
pre
requirements for a federal kidnapping
violation rsacs and our agents respond
immediately uh certainly at the request
of the state or local police even
without any uh
establishment of
of possible jurisdiction we do that
automatically may i ask
on that point
when you say the fbi responds
immediately even without
the request of the local law enforcement
no with it with a request with the
request i see
and uh do you know what that means what
kind of time frame we're talking about
is that a matter of 24 hours or no it's
immediate in fact when we had this very
tragic
disappearance of the two girls in
spotsylvania
within an hour fbi agents were on the
scene they worked all weekend they did
searches as well as profiling and
setting up computer software to work the
case we work immediately we don't
hesitate at all you think the current
legal framework between the federal
government state and local governments
is adequate to respond to this challenge
yes i do all right let me move to
another issue which is obviously very
topical
the conviction of mcvay in denver
was noted by the washington post this
morning as an extraordinary crime in
american history
it is rare maybe not unprecedented but
certainly rare
that someone
an american would be involved in an act
of terrorism which took and claimed so
many lives
as the fbi has investigated that
have you reached any conclusions as to
whether or not you need additional tools
or additional legal authority to deal
with this brand of domestic terrorism um
senator if i could make my answer uh
separate apart from that trial as you
know it's in a very delicate phase this
morning and none of us would want to say
anything which would interfere with that
with the additional
counter-terrorism resources that
congress has given us in the last
year
particularly the doubling of the
agents and the support staff necessary
to work these cases the expansion of the
league at program the
efforts to
solve the uh the clear
telecommunications access problem
uh i think we we have substantial and uh
and good resources what we need to do
which is what one of the senators
alluded to is now absorb and train uh
many new people in some very technical
and sophisticated
areas and techniques but my view is that
the the legislation with the exception
perhaps of the multi-point wiretap
the legislation that we have now
including the extra territorial
authority for counterterrorism cases
gives us ample
resources it seems that one of the more
nettlesome problems the fbi has faced
even before you're
taking office
could be traced back to this whole
militia movement militia mentality
which came out during the course of this
trial and has come out many times in the
past is this a growing problem in our
nation
in terms of a threat to
our domestic tranquility if you will um
i don't think so senator uh we've
we've worked very hard to try to
evaluate and analyze the uh the activity
that you refer to most of the militia
organizations around the country are not
in our view threatening or dangerous
the instances of
violence that we've seen republic of
texas be in one instance the freeman a
potential situation
are really uh the exception to the
larger
uh militia
organizations and movements most of
which in my view don't propose any any
threat
after the uh
the bombing in oklahoma we had all of
our sacs go out and contact mostly to
the local sheriffs the leaders of the
most prominent militia groups around the
country we've maintained a dialogue with
them since that time on some occasions
they've been helpful in even identifying
people who they view as dangerous to
others
so my view is that we're we're dealing
with a small
number of people sometimes leaderless
groups
sometimes individuals
and not a full-scale movement which
poses grave dangers so going to page
three your testimony where you say that
terrorism domestic and international uh
threatens us like never before uh can
you give us some parameters uh senator
kyle and i uh
serve on his
subcommittee on terrorism i'm sure he'll
have some interest in this too but where
do you see the threat growing when it
comes to terrorism well i mean if you
look at some of the the recent
instances the world trade tower bombing
the oklahoma city bombing
the attacks last summer in saudi arabia
against u.s interests these are
very large-scale and very
direct attacks against united states
persons or interests overseas
that's the trend that we're concerned
about we've uh we've made cases where
uh individuals have uh
in texas recently uh in the
uh alleged attempt to disguise a uh
robbery we're willing to blow up a
huge
gas tank farm as a diversion
we have cases where people are using
rhizine and anthrax and
bubonic plague for possible
acts of terrorism or criminal acts um i
think the activity of the organized
terrorist groups particularly
hamas and hezbollah both inside and
outside the united states are a growing
phenomena
the state-sponsored
terrorism
activities have not abated in fact
they've increased and that's the trend
that we're concerned about both abroad
and at home
another issue that we are considering
senator cole and i have introduced
legislation asking
for child safety locks to be sold with
firearms
handguns in the united states in
particular
and i've noted that it's been a
directive of the fbi for several years
now that your agents all have trigger
locks or child safety devices
for their own firearms some of the
critics of this legislation say that oh
if you require people to put that kind
of a safety device on a gun it won't be
accessible when they really need it
what has your experience been at the fbi
with this policy that requires child
safety locks or trigger locks
it's worked very well i think it hasn't
you know impeded any readiness or
ability to protect
i think it's a very simple but very
wholesome requirement
having five
small boys myself i think it's very good
idea whether or not it's mandated or not
16 kids are killed every day with guns
and 512 children died in unintentional
handgun shootings in 1994 and
i think most parents would agree that
this is a reasonable thing i'm glad that
it has worked i i see that my time is
about update i don't want to presume
upon it i make one last question on on
the
question of economic espionage
is it your understanding that this
espionage is going in both directions
that the united states is engaged in
spying and espionage in foreign
countries when it comes to uh trade
secrets and industry no i don't think
it's uh it's a it's a similar activity
um
what you have
i think in stark contrast to
any intelligence activities performed by
our own agencies
among the 23 countries that i alluded to
that engage in this type of activity
the goal and the reality in many of
those acquisitions is to turn over those
trade secrets to state industries
to manufacture and
out-compete the u.s companies
particularly the companies whose
intellectual property or trade secret
has been stolen
that has never been the practice or
policy with respect to any of our
activities and i think that's what makes
the problem a distinct one
which is addressed by the statute
thank you very much
thank you mr chairman senator thompson
thank you director freya i
i appreciate
the answer to that last question i think
the idea that uh
that
we do everything uh
nefarious or underhanded or improper
illegal that any other country does and
therefore we should not be concerned
about it is one that needs to be
dispelled
uh for opportunity and i think that
that you have effectively done that
let me uh let me ask you about a
specific situation that occurred in
memphis tennessee yesterday that i know
that you're aware of reports are that
an fbi swat van full of weapons and
thousands of rounds of ammunition
include including
i think a couple of grenade launchers
was stolen from a parking lot
at a hotel where agents were staying
do you have what can you tell us about
that in terms of
your own regulations
in terms of where the investigation uh
stands uh in terms of public safety and
security
in that area right now yes senator we
we certainly have
put on a full court press to try to
immediately retrieve and find those
weapons which are very dangerous weapons
as you describe them we also have uh
initiated an internal inquiry to look at
the facts and circumstances to see uh
exactly what happened and whether or not
any of our regulations were were
violated this was a visiting team as you
may know it was a little rock team
in memphis for a
exercise a multi-district exercise
apparently they went to the hotel where
they had reservations it was booked they
were sent to another hotel and the van
was left unattended where it was stolen
we think it was stolen and the uh
materials taken out before it was set on
fire was it stolen was it overnight um
yes during the night hours during the
early morning hours um we have some
regulations that require um for instance
uh trunks to be locked with chain locks
that uh uh there'd be placement racks
locked gun racks in certain cars this
had no trunk
this was a suburban it had no trunk it
had no alarm as far as i know so we're
going to look at that and see whether or
not we have
a problem with respect to not
having tougher and more protective
measures there
i believe you also have rules as to how
long you can leave weapons uh unattended
in a vehicle that would have been within
that rule but that's really not an issue
here it was left unattended and
we've got to get all the facts and
circumstances i i'm sure that you're
doing everything to work with local
authorities there and and that yes it's
probably difficult to assess the public
safety aspect of it right now is that it
is because we don't we don't we can't
account for the weapons the case is
being worked by actually one of our uh
fbi uh state and local task forces which
uh does stolen vehicle cases we think
that's the best bet for trying to solve
it as quickly as we can answer let me
ask you in another area
we've talked about your expanding
jurisdiction
uh
the technological age that we live in
and the different requirements that are
being placed on you and of course uh the
congress include is
increasingly placing requirements on you
also we're passing legislation that is
broadening your your jurisdiction
i think you testified i think it was
last year that there were about 60 new
jurisdictions
at that time
the anti-terrorism law for example used
to protect
any
federal law enforcement officer i think
that's expanded now to any federal
employee the gun free schools law
it's against the law now federal law
it's a federal crime
for some small school in some rural area
for for someone to possess a gun on
school property that's now a matter that
fbi has
has got to investigate we're going to be
considering a juvenile crime bill that's
going to expand the juvenile gang aspect
of this
i know that that
you're aware that that's our job and not
yours and
as to as to what
sound policy is in this area but but
from your standpoint have you had a an
opportunity as a bureau
to make an assessment
uh as to what that is doing to your
resources how much it it is uh
is going to require an additional
resources uh
do you try to get ahead of the curve
assuming that congress is going to as to
continue to federalize what's been state
law
and under the state uh purview for for
for many years what are your views about
that and how are you handling it
um with respect to you know expanding
federal jurisdiction particularly fbi
statutes of authority
it does become increasingly difficult to
cover all of the
the jurisdiction for instance in the
domestic violence statute which is a
federal statute the child support
requirements now by legislation we have
to assign people we should assign people
to work those cases but it's a very
difficult balance particularly in a
small office if you have less than 100
agents
to
do something with respect to a new
jurisdiction on child support but also
deal with the the bank embezzlements and
the kidnappings and the things that
don't uh change
what we're hopeful of is uh you have
everything now from from a potential
oklahoma bombing situation to some kid
with a with a gun and a rural school
exactly and it becomes very difficult to
cover everything we have as i mentioned
in my opening statement about 718 agents
who work on our safe street task forces
they're doing basically what state and
local authorities have the primary
responsibility to do which is violent
crime and
gang crimes and things like that we feel
it's important for the federal presence
in those task forces
to be there in fact we're required and
asked by the uh the state and local
partners to be there we're not there
except by invitation
if you know we have a crime rate that
violent crime rate which keeps
decreasing by
seven percent homicides by 11 percent i
would like to take some of those
resources and put them
into the areas which are of particular
expertise for us our white collar areas
our counterterrorism areas uh our
organized crime areas
but every time there's a new statute
we're spread a little bit thinner
without new resources
well i i appreciate that and i think
several of us do and i think we need to
to consider that as as we consider
all this legislation that that makes us
feel good uh because we're able to uh
issue a press release saying that we've
done something about some area that's
been
the purview of states for 200 years
uh without considering the
the
the fact that we're necessarily taking
away to a certain extent from some of
the things that have been
traditionally
fbi areas
very important areas all of them
i am going to relinquish the rest of my
time and just just finish by saying that
um
i've been critical in several areas
uh that the fbi has been involved in
ruby ridge and so forth but i must say
there comes a time when we need to to
recognize the the good work that you're
doing and and the challenges that you
have
uh it's time to to stop tearing down and
start building up again and i think that
with all the problems that the bureau is
at
and all of our institutions in this
country have had in the last several
years i might add
that
that we make sure that
we recognize that
the most important part of dealing with
that is having somebody at the top with
independence and integrity
and um
you have that and you've demonstrated
that and uh with that uh we'll work our
way through
uh these uh these problems that have
been described which which do concern uh
all of us
so with that i will uh
relinquish the balance of my time
director free i
um
would ask on um
just sort of follow up with what senator
thompson said about the van that was
stolen is there a specific procedure if
you have a vehicle that is
filled with
ammunition weapons
uh bulletproof vests things of this
nature is there a specific procedure as
to where such a vehicle would be left
overnight
or or left without somebody in it i
realize it has to be left at some time
yes there's a procedure
there's there's no specifically required
procedure at least that's what i learned
yesterday what
we normally try to do is put it in a
police pound or a fire department uh
yard or some type of area that is secure
as opposed to an unattended
parking garage at a hotel and and that's
what our our internal inquiry is going
to look at
we may need more specific
requirements in that area
director um
speak of the house mr gingrich has
been an unspoken critic of your your
leadership at the fbi
i obviously take a different
view but i now read in the paper that he
may urge appropriators to cut fbi's
funding
because the fbi is investigating
possible improper fundraising activity
by a republican member of the house
and he was particularly dependent the
fbi had the audacity to seek an
interview with former pakistan prime
minister bhutto who might have had some
relevant
information now i
i'd be concerned about a speaker of the
house interfering with a fbi
investigation whether it's of a
republican member or democrat member
are you aware of these threats to cut
the fbi budget because of the fbi's
investigation of a
fundraising activities by a member of
the speaker's party no i'm not senator
and
nor would
nor would they be well served with
respect to
the way i think i need to run the fbi we
don't respond to
those type of pressures
whatever end of pennsylvania avenue they
may be coming from we do our job we do
it honestly and we let the chips fall
where they may it'd be safe to say
whether you were investigating a member
of either party
you're not going to be deterred by
threats on your budget or anything else
absolutely not
um
during the
terrorism subcommittee's oversight
hearings into the ruby ridge incident
i urge that the fbi lab be accredited as
soon as possible in fact you instructed
the lab to apply for accreditation back
in 1995.
the formal application is not going to
be found at the end of this year
and you said that the fbi's major
failure is not seeking accreditation
sooner
uh why has it taken the fbi so long to
seek accreditation for the american
society of crime laboratory directors
even after your 1995 order
the
the
accreditation process as i learned and i
recently met with the
laboratory directors the as-clad
committee that certifies the laboratory
and they explained what a what a
long-term and difficult and rigorous
procedure that it is
we are taking steps to see if we can
speed up the application
uh prior to the fall of this year
one of the major problems with
accreditation is the physical plan
an fbi laboratory should not nor should
any laboratory be in a multi-story
building one of the
problems with accreditation particularly
in the area of contamination and access
is where that laboratory has
has been constructed
the reason it's in that building is that
somebody determined a long time ago that
it should be on the tour route uh
it makes no sense to put a laboratory in
a multi-story building and that's been
one of the problems with the
accreditation
i hope to speed up the application
process as i said i met personally with
the
scientists who do the accreditation
they're very uh
optimistic and uh were very
complementary about our efforts to
receive the accreditation and we'll do
it as quick as we can
i think it's extremely important because
the
the fbi lab has suffered questions about
its credibility and accountability
independence
this latest trial
that brings somebody in
[Music]
from overseas
back there they brought somebody from
the national crime lab in britain
now that's
that crime lab is under the home
secretary it's not even under
uh police the
alabama and virginia their separate
divisions i believe
and senator sessions would know this
better now but i believe in alabama it's
under the department of forensic
sciences and virginia it's under the
division of forensic sciences and
i um
i would hope there would be moved
outside put under a
an independent
um
factor i
um
in fact given the fact of the staff at
the lab
uh
will end up
all likelihood not being fbi agents why
not just have it outside the fbi
entirely
well even with the uh with the 100
civilian forensic examiners who we've
hired there still will be
over 50 i think fbi agents who will stay
in that laboratory
my own view is that it's it's critical
that it remain a part of the
the organization for a lot of practical
as well as
uh efficiency reasons i think when this
new laboratory is constructed
in quantico we bring in an outside
laboratory
director we've created new positions for
civilian scientists to come in and
oversee quality assurance
we have new instrumentation uh to
purchase which the congress has
authorized uh will be accredited uh i
think will be a very strong and a very
uh positive laboratory for the fbi also
note uh that uh there was the testimony
in oklahoma also of a fbi laboratory
special agent burmeister who even
one of our critics has described as
brilliant and
i would not uh
want to
i want to would want to acknowledge that
too i i know how much state
authorities police and prosecutors rely
on the fbi lab and we've got to have a
lab that
cannot be attacked for the way that it
is is run or you're going to have
thousands and thousands of post
conviction
relief
probably are going to have some
anyway
throughout the country
in your testimony you made some very
strong statements about i quote how
uncrackable encryption will allow drug
lords terrorists and even violent gangs
to communicate with impunity
the strong virtually unbreakable
encryption is available today is it not
it certainly is senator but uh there is
no global interoperable
network where
encryption is not just used by
the few which is the case now but where
it would proliferate to the point where
any kidnapper or any drug dealer could
purchase it off the shelf and connect up
with a network which would make all of
those activities but if they want if
they want to do it within their own
network they can't i mean somebody can
buy
virtually unbreakable encryption today
if they've got a a crime boss in
new england another one in a
southeastern or southwestern state
they can
today
by extremely powerful encryption abroad
and a number of other places and use it
they certainly can but
i guess my point is that
encryption is here to stay we're not
going to eliminate it but we can
try to contain by policy making
decisions it's proliferation for
instance if you and i talk over an
encrypted network
nobody can hear our conversations
but then to execute our agreement i have
to go out and use a pay phone to call
the other three co-conspirators that's a
part of the
network which is not encrypted which is
accessible pursuant to a court order and
which we'd like to we'd like to preserve
but we have to when we're looking at the
national security interests law
enforcement or
or others
we have another major national security
interest
we want to make sure our american
companies compete in a global
marketplace
right now
the whole question is going to be what
is going to be the huge standard of
encryption is it going to be european
asian or u.s companies today we have the
potential of it being u.s companies
but if we
define it too narrowly it's not going to
be
11 prominent computer security experts
and cryptographers released a study a
couple weeks ago called the risks of key
recovery key escrow and trusted
third party
examine the administration's proposal
for a key recovery system
they concluded it's too difficult too
costly
and too insecure
and
very serious question about the ultimate
viability of the key recovery systems
do you have any reaction to that report
senator reminds me of the arguments that
were made against the clear statute that
it was too costly
it was too difficult and that it wasn't
going to work
i think
just with
just as with the clear debate the
discussion uh with respect to encryption
and particularly in this body has to be
whether
there are very important public safety
and national security costs which have
to be weighed
against the cost certainly the
difficulty and maybe the
inconvenience of some type of
recovered encryption that allows me when
i have to save somebody's life to go in
and get vital information i think that's
the same choice we had to make with
clear and i think it's harder with
encryption but i think it can be done
well senator hatch under kyle and i and
others have raised some very serious
questions on this and
and maybe we could have a response
more detail than we want to do here on
this on this report
some of it may require a classified
response but i i wish we could and
perhaps your staff and ours could work
about some of the areas we want i'll be
happy to do that senator chairman maybe
we could uh
if need be you might be able to arrange
a classified briefing
on that okay it's just one last question
there have been press reports that
you've considered moving on
you tell us anything about your future
plans
um i never like to predict the future um
i um no i really can i i want to serve
as long as i can be effective as long as
i can do my job and of course i have
family considerations but i'm very happy
very proud to be here
as director you know you have the strong
support of this committee and
and uh
it is a question that many of us ask
thank you senator i appreciate it thank
you well i thank you i want you to know
you do have the strong support of this
committee and uh
we're very proud of the service that
you've given and it's been
in tumultuous times
i have to go to a
leadership meeting
and senator sessions has kindly agreed
to chair the the hearing but let me
with the indulgence of my colleagues let
me just ask two questions i think
i've been requested to ask on at least
one of them senator warner wanted me to
ask this
i understand that the bureau and the
department of justice approved on may
23rd a joint request by the rules
committee chairman senator warner and
the ranking member senator ford to
detail several fbi investigators to the
rules committee as part of its
investigation of the 1996 senate
election in louisiana
can you give us your best estimate as to
when these resources will be provided to
the rules committee um i think we
either have identified or are quickly
about to identify who they are let me if
i can do that
will you follow up because i think that
something has to be put to bed now we've
committed them and and we will have them
there if you will appreciate it now the
second question is this
recognizing advancements
recognizing advancements in technology
and the increasingly complex nature of
investigations
how would a legislative mandate uh
exempting the fbi from title v
requirements
assist the fbi in meeting this
this progressive threat
uh particularly in the counterterrorism
area
we have great trouble uh in new york
city and many other places hiring
qualified uh translators because you
can't pay on that we can't pay them
enough so you need an exemption from uh
section five our view is that we need
that because of the dynamic mission that
we have particularly the
counterterrorism mission and the
technologies which require us to hire
people that we can't really compensate
on the level that uh they would need to
come into government services the
mandates of section 5 yes sir
i think this committee ought to give
some real consideration to that and and
the rest of the connection
let's do that and see what can be done
but i'm very concerned about that
because if you can't hire the expert
people that you need especially in the
counterterrorism area that we're all put
at risk
and that's what you're saying yes
senator
we'll see if we can resolve that for you
uh i i really appreciate senator
sessions being willing to
chair the remainder part of this hearing
we'll now turn to senator kyle then
senator dewine
senator sessions and senator abraham
unless another
democrat who hasn't had a turn
appears and you'd have to alternate back
and forth thank you let me just say
before i leave and i hate to leave
there have been a lot of cheap shots
taken at the
fbi over the last number of years
some by journalists who ought to know
better because they were condemning you
for ruby red and ridge and waco
when in fact you've helped to resolve
those problems
and they pre-existed
in large measure your tenure at the fbi
i've personally appreciated the way that
you've just steadily gone ahead and done
the job regardless of the unjust
criticisms
and some of the cheap shots that have
been taken
and
and i personally appreciate having
worked with you on a day-by-day basis
over these last number of years
how you have really worked hard to try
and rectify and resolve some of these
these problems
i also appreciate the fact that you've
been willing to admit when mistakes have
been made
and when things could have been a little
bit better or when you might have made a
different decision that that might have
been more timely or better
uh we're all human beings and and we're
going to be subject to
subjective criteria from time to time
and i've been very appreciative of the
candor that you've
always shown here before this committee
and privately because you've always been
willing to
talk about the deficiencies as well as
the pluses
so i just want to personally express my
regard for you and and the great job
that you're doing and i hope that you'll
continue to do it and continue to
rectify and solve some of the problems
that really pre-existed your tenure uh
in the fbi some of which have been well
resolved
and are almost completely resolved at
this time so
i think a lot of people don't hear that
side and frankly i've
i'm fully aware of it and familiar with
it so senator leahy and and i just
before i left uh leave here i want to
thank you for the work that you're doing
thank you mr chairman mr chair
appreciate that we're not going to be
leaving with the uh with the chairman
but
uh we talked about the bipartisan or
nonpartisan nature of
law enforcement i completely subscribe
to what senator hatch has said
this committee
and i think senator hatch and i have
demonstrated this to you in our
discussions on on including some
subjects that we would not discuss in an
open hearing
as you've known we have tried very
hard to
forge a
coalition between republicans democrats
and across the political spectrum
on these law enforcement matters working
with you we have we did this with the
digital telephony bill and others
and we'll
will continue to but so i just want to
make sure that you understand that the
the leadership on both sides of this
committee are united in that regard
thank you senator i i do
understand and recognize that
so does the federal law enforcement
establishment well we want to work with
you and we want to be supportive of you
and we want to get you the resources
that you need and we want to resolve the
laws that need to be resolved
and
just keep helping us to do that and that
doesn't mean we're not going to be
critical
when we think there's something wrong
the best thing we can do is bring it to
your attention and let you know what we
think and
and i commend members of this committee
for their desires to do that
this is an oversight committee and we
have to
we have to do that and i think you
understand that but
personally i think if you look at what
you've been able to accomplish over the
last number of years it's been
phenomenal and i just i think the
general public needs to know that thank
you mr chairman thank you
thank you mr chairman
uh director free i'm i'm going to uh
second what has just been said the
nature of oversight hearings is that
they necessarily focus on problems past
and and potential
but it it needs to be said that there
are a lot of people who have served this
country very well
uh in uh solving crimes and
investigating matters in in
in seeking justice
and that's not generally recognized the
successes aren't publicized it's the
it's the failures that are when those
failures occur you have to confront them
honestly uh i believe that you have
always been honest and forthright with
me and i appreciate that very much
uh the next thing that i want to say is
that
and i'm going to focus first of all on
the nature of encryption the problems
that that poses for us the challenges
but uh i i want to begin it by pointing
out that um our the history of this
country is the is the history of the
evolution of technology that has both
both served us well and served his ill
this technology of encryption is
essential to the future communication uh
and especially uh in financial dealings
with each other in a in a way
that uh uh is
where the information is held privately
by the same token there is potential for
harm as you have pointed out what i do
not understand including in comments by
the distinguished ranking member is that
because there is a potential problem we
should throw up our hands and suggest
that we can't deal with it the history
of national security is the history of
dealing with very intractable difficult
problems finding solutions to those
problems because the alternative
is
is unthinkable and in that regard i want
to quote aspects of your testimony which
you were kind enough not to read because
you were trying to
uh take less time in making your
presentation but which i believe need to
be read into the record i'm going to
necessarily skip from paragraph to
paragraph but if i
in so doing
misrepresent your testimony in any way i
wish you would correct that and i'll
conclude what i read here with a
question for you
you begin
by saying that the nature of crime and
terrorism is evolving at an
unprecedented pace new technology new
threats new kinds of crime and a
shrinking globe are seriously
excuse me are continuously creating new
issues
for example you said
not long ago no one perceived that
telephone systems could become
untappable that virtually unbreakable
encryption would become commonplace that
people using powerful laptop computers
and distant lands could steal in second
sensational amounts of money or that the
marvels of the internet could be used
for evil against children
you go on to say terrorism both
international and domestic threatens us
like never before a point made by
senator durbin i would note that as
chairman of the
subcommittee on terrorism and technology
those are the two areas that i'm
focusing on here in your written
statement
reliance on computers you say and other
amazing technologies has inadvertently
created vulnerabilities that can be
exploited from anywhere in the world
modern technology gives terrorist
abilities unheard of only a few years
ago
the explosion of new technologies and
the globalization of crime have become
realities the need for the right
invested investigative tools is
immediate
and i underlined the word immediate that
means we need to begin to work with you
right away to do some things continuing
your written testimony having skipped a
page or two law enforcement must prepare
for the new technologies new kinds of
crimes and terrorism and technology
advance and then you get to what i
believe is the punch line
encryption
law enforcement is in unanimous
agreement that the widespread use of
robust non-key recovery encryption
ultimately will devastate
our ability to fight crime and prevent
terrorism
now let me just stop right there that is
your written testimony that's absolutely
correct senator and it's not an
overstatement no i don't think it is and
as i said i don't speak only on behalf
of the fbi i speak on behalf of the
international associations of chiefs of
police the major chiefs the sheriffs the
national association of district
attorneys we have been uh very very
insistent on the immediate nature of
this problem that this window when it
shuts the encryption window
if it shuts without the ability for key
recovery under some stringent
circumstances
search warrants
court authorized access to
transmitted communications stored
communications
trap and traces in kidnapping cases
that's all gone that's all off the board
and those investigative techniques which
are the the lifeline of uh of law
enforcement are over and that will
happen quickly when that window shuts
what we're saying is that we still have
the time to make a policy decision and
it's weighing as we did with kalia
national security and public safety
issues against commerce economics and
costs but we come down very clearly and
very unanimously on the side of public
safety
thank you let me go on because
after noting that
the
the failure to provide for some kind of
a key recovery uh
will devastate our ability to fight
crime and prevent terrorism you go on to
say uncrackable encryption
will allow drug lords terrorists and
even violent gangs to communicate with
impunity
other than some kind of key recovery
system there is no technical solution
and that is a myth that's being pervaded
by some that well you know if a hacker
can crack some code surely the fbi can
uh in classified session we can discuss
this in more detail but you stand by the
statement then that other than some kind
of key recovery system there is no
technical solution to this ultimate
problem that's correct it's not a it's
not a brute force problem now let's go
on to talk about the legislation that's
been introduced thus far in the congress
in your written testimony you said
legislative proposals introduced thus
far would largely remove existing export
controls on encryption and promote the
widespread availability and use of any
type of encryption regardless of the
impact on public safety and national
security and these proposals do not
address the public safety issue
associated with the availability and use
of encryption within the united states
we are now at an historical crossroad on
this issue
and you say if narrow interests prevail
law enforcement will be unable to
provide the level of protection that
people in a democracy properly expect
and deserve
now director free in oversight hearings
there's a lot of criticism of law
enforcement agencies for failing to have
prevented some act of crime or terrorism
after the fact a lot of the
responsibility lies with members of
congress who having been warned of
exactly this kind of thing fail to take
appropriate action and i take your
warning very very seriously and intend
to do what i can to assist
in matching the challenge that you've
presented to us
you go on to to also mention the
necessity of protecting the nation's
critical infrastructures and electronic
networks from criminal and terrorist
computer uh attacks and then let me get
to the final point here
you said the enactment of a balanced
legislative solution to the encryption
issue that addresses law enforcement's
public safety needs is badly needed i do
not believe it is too late to do so
the bills introduced thus far failed to
address law enforcement's needs in my
opinion the enactment of these bills
would have a serious negative impact on
public safety and national security any
solution that ignores the public safety
and national security concerns risks
grave harm to both
now this committee is going to be very
interested in your specific suggestions
as to how legislation should be crafted
to create this balance and deal with
these significant security concerns is
there anything more that you would like
to talk about today with respect to this
problem of encryption just very briefly
senator to
to reinforce that it is a it is a a
problem which is still solvable today uh
if we let robust encryption proliferate
around the world drop all our export
controls uh no access authority
whatsoever we'll never be able to go
back and retrofit uh and fix this
problem it would cost billions and
billions of dollars and it would be
inefficient
what uh what we're saying is that we we
have time to make a very important
policy choice where we can protect
robust encryption preserve the
competitive advantage that america now
has with encryption but still give the
public safety and national security
interests
their day in court
we have a proposal which we're happy to
discuss in in other sessions i have
testified about it before senator
mccain's committee
senator mccain was very supportive of
protecting law enforcement as many other
senators are
and we have a voluntary approach with a
certificate authority requirement of
filing
keys which we think doesn't interfere
with commerce but does protect the
people of this country
thank you very much on page 20 of your
written testimony you talk about
something else that needs to be done you
say more needs to be done if law
enforcement is to keep pace with the
technology certainly be used by
terrorists and criminals alike
and i i think this dealt with a
statement you made about the
test that is required to show
that the suspect is continuously
avoiding as opposed to
the the
more
liberal standard what specifically do
you think we need to do with respect to
the law enforcement's authority
not to enhance uh existing authority but
to conform it to the evolution of
technology i think it's a very simple
solution that does not expand our powers
what you do is you go back to title 18
and you give us the
same authority to do a multi-point uh
electronic surveillance per court order
with a telephone as we now have with a
microphone we already have that
authority we're just asking for parity
between telephones and microphones in
other words if it's not practical to
show that the drug dealer is going to
use clone phone after clone phone on a
daily basis
we should be able to get authority to
listen to
his criminal conversations uh found by a
court on a probable cause standard
whether he's using a clone phone or a
modem or or a mailbox
and finally i i
just want to ask this final question the
testimony from
other department of justice and fbi
witnesses has supported
our
legislation to
conform the
crime
of gambling on the internet to
existing law uh and i would just we're
going to be moving that bill marking it
up in our subcommittee very soon and i
just would like a reconfirmation of the
fbi support for that legislation i think
it's a very effective change we
certainly support it thank you very much
thank you mr chairman all right
direct free
i'm going to rewind but would you like
to take a break you've been here a
couple of hours now we'd like to take
five or 10 minutes um i'm actually okay
okay thanks i'll recognize senator
dewine
endurance is one of the uh requirements
for this job i guess when you have as
many children as we do senator
that's true
mr director let me uh speaking of
children first
congratulate you and the department for
your renewed emphasis on children's
cases child abduction cases child
pornography cases
um governing is about setting priorities
and i applaud your priority in this area
this is something that i think the
public assumes uh when we think of the
fbi uh this is one of the things that we
think the fbi does
and the public assumes the fbi does very
well and so i again you know applaud
your emphasis on this i think this is
the right right priorities
let me move if i could to a subject that
you and i have discussed in in private
and in public and that is
the emerging
technology that really
provides great
tools for law enforcement agencies
particularly the area of ballistic
comparisons
we have been able to solve crimes in
ohio
crimes have been solved across this
country that a few years ago we never
could have solved without this this
relatively new technology
atf uh has the ceasefire program you
have drug fire
um
from what i can tell i don't pretend to
be an expert in this area both are very
good programs for good systems
but we know that
the key to to all of this solving of
crime is the exchange of information
and
for local law enforcement to be able to
tap into to a nationwide system
i wonder if you could tell the committee
what if any progress is being made in
regard to
trying to link these two systems or or
or make them compatible uh it is rather
ironic that
we have two arms of the federal
government and each are growing their
own system both systems appear to be
good but yes but
it seems to me that this is a potential
problem or is a problem yes senator i'd
be happy to respond to that
when these two systems
began to be developed in parallel
actually several years ago
there was a lack of coming together it
should have been done and we would have
avoided probably some
some expenditures as well as a lot of
confusion among our state and local
partners i am very happy to report
that
after
a series of meetings over the last few
months between fbi and atf
we are now on the verge literally of
resolving that issue and combining the
system in fact as we speak in saint
petersburg
there's a meeting of our advisory policy
board and the deputy director is down
there making a presentation uh with the
atf so we are very
confident that in short order we're
going to have a system
that is uh either interoperable or
single in nature but will give our state
and local partners
uh this stability which they've not had
with the very dysfunctional competition
over several years so uh we hope to
finalize that real quick that is uh
fantastic news and i congratulate you
for doing something that uh
you you and atf something that has
eluded us up until now i think it's very
very important it's particularly
important for local law enforcement well
atf deserves the credit for it we're
very very happy to be part of it we're
we're delighted i'm delighted to hear
that
let me in the brief time that i have
moved to one more subject and that is
the crime lab
we have discussed the importance of the
changes that you are implementing in
regard to the crime lab some of the
problems have been connected with the
crime lab
one of the things though that i think we
sometimes forget is the importance of
your fbi crime lab to local law
enforcement
i wonder if you could tell me
approximately what percentage of the
cases
that you handle through your crime lab
are local law enforcement
um i'd have to get you the exact
percentages i know in the in the violent
crime areas particularly in the dna unit
we have the majority of our work i
believe our examinations are state and
local related certainly in the dna area
um
we have worked through the codis system
with our state laboratory partners to
install and have on a interoperable
effective basis the means of comparing
samples and doing forensic work in that
very important area
some of the areas we predominate with
federal
clients including ourselves handwriting
and
fingerprinting but in i think in the
violent crime area and i'll get i'll
make sure i'm accurate on this and
certainly the dna area most of the work
we do is with the state and locals but
i'll i'll get you a direct breakdown of
it well let me just i think it's just an
important point to make that when we
talk about the the
validity and the sanctity of your crime
lab we're not just talking about federal
cases we're talking about something that
law enforcement throughout this country
relies on and my understanding is
at least based on my own experience a
few years ago i was a prosecutor that
you know
local government local units law
enforcement go to you when the expertise
frankly may not be there at the state
level
and for the tough tough cases and
the ability to be able to rely on you i
think is very very important
one of the issues that you always run
into when local law enforcement makes a
decision whether to submit something to
the crime lab to your crime lab is is
the time
uh what if you could give me any uh
estimate of what kind of backlog you
have and i know it it
it would be different based on the case
or based on the analysis that you're
being asked to do but if you could just
give me a rough uh
indication of what kind of backlog you
currently have yes it's a substantial
backlog particularly in
certain areas of crime particularly the
hair and fibers unit and the dna unit
have a
exponentially
increased number of submissions because
being a former prosecutor you know once
that becomes the
technology
at issue
every prosecutor wants to prepare for
that defense by doing examinations which
otherwise he or she may not do so in the
dna area in the heron fiber area
there have been a very very substantial
increases i'll get you the the actual
numbers but we have a serious backlog in
many of those areas
including a lot of the small
resin agencies in the west that submit
evidence from indian reservations uh
crimes on government reservations and it
is a substantial
uh problem we expedite cases whenever
necessary and have been successful in in
meeting those obligations but there is a
substantial backlog well if if you could
submit either for the record or to me
directly
those figures and
break them maybe break them down
by the type of case that you're looking
at i mean i think that
in our oversight capacity and in the
capacity of the appropriations committee
in regard to your funding i think we
need to know that because that affects
every law enforcement potentially at
least every law enforcement agency in in
this country and i think mr chairman
it's a very very significant
matter
and if it's a question of
more resources or resources directed
differently we need to at least explore
that with with your department i will
say in conclusion mr chairman and mr
director that in preparation for this
hearing i i we got on the phone and
called a few of
our law enforcement friends back in ohio
and they have very good reviews for the
fbi
talking to several prosecutors yesterday
and they said that you know in important
cases we get on the phone and they get
the information to us they run the test
and they get it done they get it to us
in time for trial
so uh your people i know you hear uh you
know we
we criticize and we talk about things
that you aren't doing but by and large
you have some very good people who are
dedicated to law enforcement and who
when they have to and and when it's uh
down to the wire on the case we'll go
the extra mile and do what has to be
done to to help solve that case or or to
find out maybe they can't solve it one
way or the other so i congratulate you
and we look forward to continuing to
work with you because this is goes to
the core function i think one of the
core functions of the fbi and a service
that you have provided law enforcement
and frankly that law enforcement pretty
much now takes for granted after decades
of this type of help thank you we'll get
you those figures thank you thank you
very much thank you mr chairman thank
you
senator abraham
uh thank you thank you senator sessions
first of all let me just begin to
welcome director free i was not here
earlier i apologize i was testifying on
a bill that i am sponsoring on another
committee but uh let me also just
associate myself with comments made
earlier by chairman hatch and others
with respect to you and
and what we think of you as well as in
the relationship between the committee
and
both yourself as well as the bureau
um
a lot of the questions i had
considered
raising have been addressed already so
what i thought i might do is focus on an
area that i'm currently engaged in as
part of my work and chairman is the
chairman of the immigration subcommittee
and is i think you know we recently
conducted a hearing
uh with a number of people uh testifying
including commissioner meisner with
respect to the
criminal background check efforts that
are undertaken in conjunction with
naturalization of new citizens and
i don't
expect to hold you to a standard of of
total knowledge of all the different
options we might have available that's
obviously a challenge the ins and and we
in oversight responsibility have but but
it's it's as you probably will recall
the problem we encountered was that a
very substantial number of these of
these criminal background checks were
not completed
uh in many instances because the
information uh with respect to for
example the fingerprints
were not
processed before the naturalization was
conducted now that wasn't
i don't know why that happened in terms
of the time frame and the delay in in
the completion of that but i do know
that that in
prior prior to very recent time it was
the approach of the ins to take to make
the presumption that if the fbi didn't
respond within 60 days that
the assumption was and i guess the
presumption was made that there was no
criminal background
we later have learned that that isn't
the case and that for a variety of
reasons including inadequate fingerprint
cards as well as cards sent to the wrong
facilities
we weren't you weren't at the bureau
able to conduct the processing on the
other hand some issues were raised as to
where we go from here because that's
really what i'm uh concerned about and
as you know i
am a strong proponent of legal
immigration i think
for legal immigration to to
be seen by
our fellow citizens is a positive thing
the naturalization process itself has to
be seen as beyond uh question as
accurately done as conducted uh as
accurately as possible to make sure that
we don't have people being naturalized
who aren't aren't entitled to be and i
was wondering if you could comment on
where you see this technology going how
you see the bureau
able to address these problems we were
at the at the hearing conversation about
biometric uh
uh technology being uh developed was was
raised but i'd sort of like to hear from
you where we stand on that and what you
see the future as well as the time frame
toward that future to improve the the
way we can do this yes senator shirley
it is a great uh matter of importance
for not just the immigration issue but
we have now a substantial backlog in
processing criminal and civil prints
around the country which goes back to
senator dewine's issue
about the very
valuable and unique federal service
that's provided in our identification
division
the problem is going to be solved
technologically certainly by july of
1999 when the iafis system is online and
ins has the ability to electronically
transmit the images we have an interim
opportunity to address the problem also
we have a system which is more than a
test bed now we have it operating with
the boston police department where they
electronically transmit directly to the
fbi
the 10 print
10 fingerprint images it's printed on a
card at the fbi and it's then processed
we've done this on a
test basis but it's worked so well that
we're going to expand it and
particularly
are working with the ins to see if they
can use the same technology which is not
iafis technology it's just
a transmission technology to give us the
images electronically and quickly and
the 1100 new people that we've hired in
west virginia or will hire by the end of
the fiscal year will make up the
the difference in the processing on our
end
we expect
over
a million new ins fingerprint
submissions for this fiscal year
uh part of the problem as you pointed
out
in 1996 was of the
million-plus individuals who were
naturalized approximately 180 000 of
those when we went back to look could
not be
accounted for in terms of the
the records being readable and
retrievable and whatnot i think a lot of
that will be solved
conclusively by aphis but on an interim
basis we can solve many of it by just
the method in which we format
the prints we also ins now requires that
designated and approved print takers
submit images as opposed to
applicants doing it themselves which i
think caused some of the uh the rejects
and the inability to read some of those
prints so i think it's it's an
electronic solution which uh is coming
too late perhaps for
the past mistakes but which will solve
the problem i'm trying to look forward
today and so in that sense let me ask
you
how how complicated will it be in your
judgment on how costly
uh for us to move in this direction with
respect to ins do you have a sense of
what what the expense will be and what
we may be called upon here to
uh not with respect to the to the actual
cost i know the equipment that the
boston police department uses uh and i
can get you the cost for it is not
prohibitive and they've found and we've
found that it just expedites and saves
uh an extreme amount of time and and
efficiency
i'll get you some course that's yeah
well we're i think as we assume that
we're going to move in that direction
let me let me ask you another question
as as you just indicated ins has has
begun the process of of sort of
designating various uh law enforcement
agencies and other entities who which
aren't law enforcement uh
organizations to conduct the fingerprint
to to take fingerprints for
prospective citizens
in your judgment do you feel comfortable
with the way your system works having
people who aren't in law enforcement
engaged in that process or do you think
that will continue to present a problem
with respect to the accuracy
and and uh
you know interface of the fingerprints
you're getting
um i think it's a it's a problem that
bears a lot of scrutiny both on the
integrity issue but also on the
competency issue um you know in many uh
civil governments now non-law
enforcement individuals take prints to
submit for
school custodians teachers
larger categories than before i think we
have to look at the
the competency issue and also
particularly with the immigration area
with the integrity issue
i would be willing to monitor it closely
but i think it's a step in the right
direction it's certainly better than the
candidate submitting correct or what
purports to be his or her own prince
well i agree with that and and and i
want to stress that i think the ins is a
i mean
the reason for this is to attempt to to
deal with the problem of having folks
bringing in fingerprints that were not
necessarily their own
i i just was concerned because it
strikes me that as soon as you get
outside of the
of the parameters of law enforcement and
into for-profit entities conducting
these tests that you might
you might have some continuing problems
and and i guess i don't know to the
extent that the fbi could monitor that
but
it would be helpful to us i think to
know what
as this process now begins what the
percentages are in terms of rejection or
inability to read the fingerprints from
various sources
excuse me i'll be happy to talk to
commissioner meisner and and set up a
a protocol or some means to both monitor
it but also report and see if we can
call some information out for you thank
you let me ask just on a very unrelated
topic but uh one of recent vintage in my
state and it it's a concern that's been
raised
with respect to a specific incident that
the fbi is investigating uh which took
place in a women's prison facility in
michigan in april and apparently the an
agent from the fbi has
conducted an investigation with respect
to a complaint of rape having occurred a
rape having occurred in the facility
uh
evidence was taken by the agent for
brought here for tests and so on
and i'm informed at least that there's
difficulty
with respect to the sharing of the
information the evidence with the
michigan state police that they're
having a difficult time
because they want to conduct an
investigation they're obviously not
letting the matter drop either and i'm
wondering if is there anything you know
about this or could you please look into
it if if you're not familiar with it yes
because i it seemed in
very much uh at odds with the normal
process that i know you follow senator i
i heard about it minutes before the
hearing uh what i'll do after the
hearing is talk to
mike robinson who's a very good friend
he's also one of the iacp officials we
have a very long and good relationship
let me speak to him and find out what it
is and and get back to you on it we'll
we'll fix whatever the problem i
appreciate that thank you thank you very
much thank you mr chairman thank you
i think it's my time and perhaps why i
was chosen i was the last one to have
this round but i think we'd perhaps like
to
take another round after this
uh first um director fury i wanted to
say that i appreciate your appointment i
think the president made a good
selection in choosing you
i said for many
years that i thought it was one of his
best appointments
i served as united states attorney a
federal prosecutor as you have for 12
years really two and a half years in
addition as an assistant and i've worked
with fbi agents
over a number of years i have the utmost
and greatest respect for those
individuals who often risk their lives
who work long hours who are subject to
the most incredible second guessing
after they've been out putting their
neck on the line making the decisions
they have to make
and something goes wrong and they always
those who want to jump on them for it
not that we can't improve we should
but i i really feel
like that the federal bureau of
investigation is
as fine an investigative agency as there
exists in the world and probably the
history of the world
it is filled with men and women of
integrity and ability
i tend to
share some of the concerns and the
slightly different tilt that senator
grassley does you've been a prosecutor
you've worked
uh
over the years with
the fbi and i think as you get higher up
in that agency
there is a tendency to be defensive to
deny any wrongdoing to uh attack those
who attack them on maybe we can blame it
on hoover but i think it's a long time
to blame it on mr hoover uh would you
agree
that um
that is a
one i've always said the great strength
of the fbi one of the great strengths
was its discipline
uh that's also a weakness it tends to be
a weakness and maybe there's different
side of that same coin uh have you given
any thought to that and i know you've
talked about here about opening up and
being more responsive to complaints and
be more willing to admit errors um i
think maybe you are doing that um you
think you have some ways to go yet
um i think there's always room for
improvement
but i can say with a lot of confidence
in the three and a half years that i
have been director that i've never been
accused of
not admitting mistakes i've done it on a
number of occasions internally publicly
i was the uh
the witness at the hearing who said that
the fbi was not prepared
to handle the situations at waco and
ruby ridge i said that again to senator
feinstein
what we did however was fix
the
mechanisms and the resources that we had
to address those problems and when
things went well at ruby ridge in large
part because of the skill of the men and
women who were out there but working
under the new system uh to me that was
uh
was a twofold benefit one we had
acknowledged the problem and secondly we
had fixed it the same with the
laboratory we don't uh
make excuses or rationalizations we have
serious uh problems in the laboratory
which affect not only fbi cases but
cases all over the world and
what we've attempted to do is
acknowledge those problems we haven't
blamed anybody for them
but to fix them and fix them as quickly
and expertly as we can
but we've never taken the position or
would i that
there's no more room for improvement and
there's probably lots of other aspects
of our operation we haven't focused on
that have similar deficiencies and
problems and
our obligation is to to find them and
fix them when we can
well i just think that um
leading on that issue
teaching on that issue that we need to
be open we need to listen to complaints
and criticisms and adjust ourselves
would be a good contribution that i
had the opportunity as attorney general
to um our office did to prosecute walter
leroy moody for capital murder and he's
now on death row
you did and personally led and
prosecuted that case he's the one that
sent the mail bombs through
the mail that killed a federal judge and
a civil rights lawyer and could have
killed a half a dozen members of the
united states clerk's
district court circuit court clerk's
office i guess in atlanta
you did a outstanding job in that and i
wanted to compliment you and i think
to me as a person who's tried a lot of
cases uh when i see someone who has that
ability and that determination i know
you have the ability to do the job that
you have here and i wanted to compliment
you on that thanks very kind of you and
let me just return that
compliment with
what you and your leadership of the
attorney general's office but actually
uh the prosecutors under your
supervision did in retrying that case
which was a retrial which is always
difficult as you know right and to get
the conviction and the capital sentence
uh as i said to your assistants in the
case uh and who we worked with very
closely they did an outstanding job and
we were very very proud of them
well we felt strongly that such a
calculating premeditated murder of two
individuals and potentially many others
could have been killed um
that um the death penalty had to be
applied there some would second guess
whether it was necessary he had life
without parole under the federal
sentence but we felt that we were going
to apply the death penalty in alabama
equally they could not be walked away
from
your decision
we did have to look at the whitehurst
matter uh some because we used
laboratory evidence
and i
i never got to the bottom of it
i read some of mr whitehurst's
complaints
um
and i i think he pointed out some
problems in the laboratory
but um i thought he went to
extraordinary links to make minor
problems look to be very serious
problems
i thought that uh the tone of his
remarks were not uh in
did not indicate a desire for
improvement so much as to complain
and
i think he did point out some things
that were not good but i i it did not
indicate to me any out and out fraud or
fault saw reporting or false testimony
of any significant nature
but we did look at that and that was the
opinion of my staff who looked at it
um
i want to say this
we've been very pleased with the
response of the agency of the bureau on
juvenile records
now we believe strongly that a young
offender who commits robberies or rapes
or
burglaries
those records ought to be in ncic
they're not available to the public but
for law enforcement and judges when
they're later 20 years old they're
arrested you need to know that they had
an armed robbery conviction at age 15
and the system is not doing a good job
of that and i wanted to say that
the response of your people to the
juvenile
violence subcommittee's request
to that we do a better job of that has
been excellent
and
i
think that that's important would you
not agree that
uh we ought to
pat that a judge a prosecutor or an
investigator uh ought to know whether or
not an individual had prior serious
criminal history at age 15 or 16 yes
they should
that's not being done routinely in
america today it's not being part of
that criminal history rap sheet as we
call it and i think we can make progress
in that regard
um
one issue that i've had some interest in
and the numbers show you're making some
proven improvement in
is the investigation and prosecution of
bankruptcy fraud
there was a bankruptcy committee hearing
recently
and
some of the practitioners in those
courts
made the statement
that
people routinely lie on their bankruptcy
petitions
uh of course the judge makes decisions
based on what's on those petitions it's
a very important document another judge
was shocked that anybody would say that
in the southern district of alabama we
began to form a task force to
investigate those a number of years ago
and i think they continue to be quite
successful once there is a good
communication
between
the
bankruptcy court who first identifies
probable falsities and the fbi and the
prosecutor's office i think
large increases in cases and convictions
can be accomplished
and
as a result of that you can get a
significant deterrence of fraud in the
bankruptcy court in my view the criminal
bankruptcy defense lawyers will warn
their clients if they know they're going
to be prosecuted for false statements to
not do it and if nobody is being
prosecuted and i see about 200 are
nationwide which means about two per
district per year which probably is not
sufficient
would you take a look at that and see if
you can identify a way to enhance the
prosecution of bankruptcy fraud cases i
certainly will senator if
if you recall several months ago there
was a department-wide initiative with
respect to bankruptcy cases not so much
the the false statements and
applications but the actual
uh
coordinated uh public uh showing of of
initiative directed against bankruptcy
fraud but let me take uh
take your recommendations which i think
are very good and and see if we can
do some implementation and i'll report
back to you
with regard to that um
what has happened to the
um could you shift some resources from
um
your savings and loan cases which i
assume are beginning to pare down now to
this uh uh
effort we're getting a 29 increase in
bankruptcies in one year last year it's
becoming a real national problem i'll
certainly be willing to take a look at
that we have of course
taken some of the resources that were
devoted to the failures back in the in
the 80s the failures have pretty much
abated the bankrupt the the bank
embezzlements however have actually uh
increased and although a lot of u.s
attorneys have threshold limits
they're still preoccupying a lot of our
resources but let me see and address the
issue of
including in that white collar effort
the bankruptcy
portion which is just as integral
well i would just say that i think
sometimes we make a mistake in having
these very high thresholds sometimes you
just need to convict a bunch of people
in a district of bankruptcy fraud and
all the bankruptcy lawyers will tell
their clients from then on they'll put
you in jail if you don't tell the truth
but if you just wait for a 100 million
case it takes two years to prosecute it
may not be good
very good point senator let me
senator grassley huh
mr free in regard to the uh
deaths at the columbia veterans hospital
i think it was just four months ago
i was promised by the fbi and by also
the department of justice officials
from the civil division that i would
have in just a matter of a few days
information i requested about the
possible serial homicides at that
hospital
background to that is that 44 patients
died at the hospital from march
to july of 92.
an analysis showed that the odds that
these deaths were random would have been
a million to one
the evidence the evidence pointed to a
particular
nurse who was suspected of committing uh
serial murders
the fbi investigated it exhumed 13
bodies in 93 to
examine tissue samples the samples were
sent to the fbi crime lab
they sat there for three and a half
years and finally last year
an outside contractor was hired to do
the forensic analysis
and we're still waiting for the results
my staff was briefed that the deaths
were probably homicide homicides
according to the bureau
if that's the case the bureau is obliged
to coordinate with state and local law
enforcement and provide them information
in the case local law enforcement has
jurisdiction because the hospitals on
state-owned land
i was assured that the fbi had
coordinated with the missouri police but
i've discovered that
that
missouri officials said that that hasn't
happened
meanwhile the nurse left the va hospital
went to work at a nursing home and more
suspicious deaths turned up and when i
asked for a
an accounting of the fbi's coordination
with local officials i was promised it
in a few days
and when i asked for a copy of the
contract with the outside forensic
contractors i was promised it
within a few days and that was four
months ago i raised this matter with the
attorney general when she was before
this very committee five weeks ago
and here's what she said
quote i'll check on that as soon as i
get back and a quote and that was five
weeks ago and i haven't heard a peep
from the attorney general either
nor have i heard anything from the fbi
so you know what in the world's going on
this is a very important case
and why can't i get straight answers
there are 44 families out there who are
waiting for answers from the fbi on this
case
and they want accountability
senator it certainly is an important
case and
one that
should be
investigated and accounted for
forthrightly i will
i will get you a response to the extent
that i can
with respect to those questions my
understanding is that the
the 13
bodies that were exhumed were
tested by the fbi uh without any
positive results they then
hired a contractor who is according to
my note here still in the process of
performing those tests as to the
contract
and the
relationships with the missouri
officials uh i promise i will inquire
into that and i i will get back to you
personally on that
what would be the condition that you
couldn't get me the information that
i've required um my understanding my
only understanding of any limitation is
that the u.s attorney uh and i don't
know this directly except the note that
i have the u.s attorney has said that
disclosures could impair
the ability to uh prosecute a case and i
think
uh i don't know is that like saying it's
an open case
it would be the reason you couldn't
respond i haven't spoke to the us
attorney so i don't know what what his
feelings are he may feel that disclosing
something publicly could jeopardize it
that's a separate question as to whether
you can get some information well just
just in case
that that's
the the analysis you get remember that
four months ago
when my staff was briefed that this was
not an open case because if it had been
an open case
why would fbi and justice officials be
briefing me about that
and
and if it were an open case then why did
they promise me the documents
i i'll i'll get an answer to that for
you this week senator um call you
personally when i get it
um
i have uh next question would deal with
the malone case
on
may the 13th
mr james maddock
your fbi's deputy general consul said
that the fbi is reviewing all of agent
malone's cases
for the benefit of my colleagues and
there's one here
agent malone
was found to have made 27 false
statements to the judicial panel in the
elsi hastings case he was also the
subject of a front page story on the
wall street journal and that story
chronicled a pattern of cases in which
malone was caught providing bad
testimony
now this case mr free illustrates a
fundamental flaw
in the ig's investigation there were 13
agents
whose cases should be reviewed
like malone's are now both for patterns
of questionable conduct and for possible
criminal conduct to me there's a
conflict with respect to the fbi
reviewing
malone's cases
first of all
i'm going to ask the attorney general to
have the ig do that review
and i would like your support on that mr
free we we don't object to that in fact
we'd be happy to work with them okay
second
i don't want to have malone review turn
out like the rudolph review and that's
the review where i held up the blank
page or redacted page
the ig criticized
rudolph and the fbi for allowing rudolph
to go back into his files
and then there were spruce them up in
other words he went back and added
documents and data so that his work
wouldn't look so bad my concern is
heightened by the fact that as i
understand it agent malone is being
allowed to review his own files
perhaps this is my judgment to spruce
them up and if so that should not be
allowed to happen i'm also getting word
that others in the lab are being asked
to do research from raw own
to get his files in order
if true that uh
should not
be allowed to happen i agree with you
it should not be allowed to happen and
let me speak to the inspector general
and ensure that that's not happening
okay so
my question was to shed some light on it
but i think you've said that you're
willing to cooperate look into it and
and you've stayed at a high standard so
i appreciate that
i find it interesting that when dr
whitehurst requested in december 95
access to fbi files to flesh out his
allegations he was denied access
but it appears that agent malone was
given access as well as resources to
help him
quite an interesting contrast but
there's another interesting contrast
and i know you get tired of me saying
that the fbi attacks the messenger dr
whitehurst
but uh
meanwhile agent malone
with a trail of bad testimony in
multiple cases
was honored with a plaque on the wall of
honor in a quarter right outside the lab
director's office and was taken down
according to wall street journal just
before the wall street journal
article appeared
agent malone developed a reputation for
by providing testimony on hair and fiber
analysis that no one else would he would
overstate analysis allegedly fabricate
evidence
but he of course would help get
convictions dr whitehurst on the other
hand who merely spoke the truth had his
badge and gun taken away he's been
suspended and he's not allowed in the
fbi building or to talk
to the fbi so
i hope that you can see
which of these agents just based upon
this treatment one agent versus the
other in other words dr whitehurst on
the one hand versus agent malone on the
other
that you held the that the fbi held in a
higher regard and probably why i mean
there was that sort of cooperation that
brought convictions now
there's nothing that i could do or say
that would paint a clearer picture
of what i
feel is this problem that i relate to
you and you may want to come at it or
not i don't i'm not asking you to
comment about the fbi's culture and
image that i think is a terrible problem
but i'll just state that as a fact if
you want to comment you can comment
and then i've got one last question sure
senator i will i will further look into
all the matters we discussed the
allegations against mr malone i don't
know if they're true or not at this
point they're very very serious we take
them with the utmost seriousness uh in
fairness to him there should be an
inquiry uh with the inspector general
i'm agreeable to that and um if there if
there are problems and and things that
we did wrong administratively or he did
wrong individually
someone will be accountable and you will
know about that
i don't think i have anything more to
say about
about
you know what you perceive to be
uh
problems with respect to uh image
building or or our concern for image we
are very concerned for image we're a
very proud organization we think we're a
fine organization uh i have never been
uh reluctant in three and a half years
however to admit uh mistakes my own
mistakes institutional mistakes i've
made a lot of uh unprecedented changes
in the fbi uh to the extent that there's
still that perception out there
you obviously share that that's a
problem for us i want to work very hard
to
overcome that and solve that
we're an organization of human beings we
recruit all our people from the human
race
we make mistakes sometimes we make them
on a on a hillside in idaho sometimes
you make them in washington i make them
in my office we don't uh do it
except in very rare cases with a bad or
improper motive we can do much better
and you've got my promise to
try to keep improving and and make our
image what i think it should be could i
keep going because i've just i'm not
going to take very much more time
i've had my
subcommittee staff do some work on
on
what your plans are quantico for the new
lab
and if is my information right that not
only are you going to have
the new lab there but there's going to
be a second one that deals with
hazardous materials
no senator we have a
we have a study which we've
approved
and the study is
addressing the question as to whether or
not we need a separate containment
facility for chemical nuclear or
biological materials we have not
agreed i've certainly not been persuaded
that we need such a containment facility
there are other dod facilities and
hhs facilities available we're just
studying the question okay um
then then
then that really shortens my question
because i think you pointed out some of
the duplication that would come if you
were to do that but the fact is your
staff
has briefed us that 20 million dollars
was going to be spent
on a lab like that so you're saying
that that has not been decided and and
and you're not going to to do that no we
have we have 130 million dollars to
build a laboratory which we're in the
process of doing the last 32 million
dollars of that appropriation we've
asked for in 1998 it's just one
laboratory one facility there is a
question about whether we need a
separate facility i'm not persuaded that
we do and i would certainly
want to use a current facility before i
would build one but i i don't know what
that i'll try to find out what that 20
million dollars referred to well then
i mean i hope you're right and and if
you are then then i'm satisfied i think
just uh for a matter uh and i'll submit
some questions on this issue in writing
um and this uh another point that i want
to bring up and this is in just regard
to asking for information
my staff has been investigating alleged
misinco
alleged misconduct by fbi lab officials
in the case of twa flight 800 and it may
involve the improper handling of
evidence required recovered from the
water first could you shed a light on
that if you can't
i would like you to provide any
documents or other information
pertaining to this
incident and i'd like to have it within
a week because this should not carry on
like these other
requests for information
senator i'd be happy to talk to you or
your staff about that's the first time
i've heard that certainly nothing that's
come up to my attention and i will look
into it i'll be happy to get any
specifics you have i think that that's a
cooperative
effort
a body this is an entirely different
issue
uh
about a year after enacting the
anti-terrorism act there's been no
listing of terrorist groups or
organizations under the act
and i understand that you want the list
to be able to uh
that you want the list to be able to
withstand judicial review
but there's already been an executive
order naming terrorist groups
one would think that if groups are being
named even by executive order that the
list would be able to withstand
a great deal of scrutiny already so the
question is why
is it taking so long to name these
terrorist groups as the statute requires
um president executive order senator
i'll seek to get you an answer to that
we have a a role to play in that but
it's a multi-departmental process
including the department of state
which is going into that process uh as
you know the chief justice just very
recently constituted the alien removal
court which was also mandated under the
statute um
i will uh i will seek to get you some
answers i know under the
department of treasury regulations to
enforce the aipa statute they have
publicly identified a number of
terrorist organizations
i'll try to get you
the answer to your question i do not
know it at this time
mr chairman mr free the rest of my
questions i'm i have a lot more
questions but i'm going to submit any um
we will schedule
i'm going to submit them for the record
so we aren't going to take time to do
that
i guess uh just in conclusion i'd say
that
the process of oversight takes
cooperation and communication i think in
your second round with me you've
indicated that that there's a lot of
information that i should have gotten
that i haven't that you'll help us get
and
i hope that you can do that
and uh
i'll pre uh present the rest for the
record thank you thank you senator let
me just correct something i said we we
have 35 units in the lab i think i
misspoke and said we have 25. we're
looking at each one of those other 32
units which were not the subject of the
ig inspection
with outside scientists to ensure that
the
the recommendations as well as the
issues are not going to be repeated
there yeah that's in regard to my first
round of questions yes sir yeah thank
you very much
well senator grant thank you for that
and i think it's
unhealthy thing indeed that our
nation's top law investigators in other
countries um known as secret police
oftentimes are subject to open
questioning and by senators like senator
grassley who wants to get to the bottom
of of matters yeah so i appreciate his
his interest and his support very much i
think it's healthy for this country that
people have these questions asked
and some look i will note on senator
grassley on the um
malone case you mentioned
i think fundamentally most of those
quote alleged statements were where the
malone indicated testified that i did
things when really they were done under
his supervision of people working for
him
and i think the person who criticized
him for that the laboratory
person who did that
uh
testified that his ultimate opinion that
the strap was cut and not torn was
correct and there was no doubt about
that
so
the ultimate question about that i think
uh
was um answered in the affirmative on
the on the relevant question of his
testimony in the court in that case the
facts are that uh malone was a
coordinator on the project
and uh another person did the actual
investigation
yes i think the agents you're right i
think senator grassley is correct agents
ought not to say i if they didn't do it
in court on the oath
but um i think fundamentally
uh maybe he was not thinking as clearly
as he should have and been as precise as
he should have been but i don't think
from what i've seen there are
indications of fabrication of evidence
if there's a fabrication of evidence you
ought to be prosecuted but i haven't
heard that allegation made
um
you me one thing i wanted to ask about
something i've always been interested
about and congratulate you for is the
reduction of the staff in headquarters
i think um
the more you have there the more trouble
they cause for the people out in the
field trying to do their job
you know what the numbers are now can
you have an uh an opinion
on where you've gone to where we are i
can get you the exact numbers i think we
were well over 800 we're certainly down
and have remained down to about 600
i had numbers as high as 900. it
probably was quite quite close to that
uh
most of the uh most of the street agents
would share your your view um
and the only thing i haven't figured out
is how to get myself out to the field
well i think it would help you and the
field much as you can
the um
is mr whitehurst working now does he
have a caseload
um no
as far as i know he's on
he's on paid administrative leave i
think he ought to go to work
in my view and ought to be something
that he can do and if he's not able to
function in a normal healthy environment
then he ought to be removed but he ought
not to be paid to do nothing
i will i will have somebody else since
i'm recused inquiry into that it is a
department of justice matter now they
are responsible for
that determination it's not in the fbi
anymore but let me uh make your uh
your inquiry known which which i'll do
today
we
and i would just like to comment
on
a couple of issues one
i do not believe
the extent to which we had two parallel
tracks
on uh ceasefire and and the other
program that it went that far was
justified do you have any explanation
for how atf and and the fbi went so long
with two separate tracks on two separate
procedures and why
how we can avoid that in the future
i think we can avoid it in the future by
uh ensuring among the leadership of
these agencies that we don't uh we don't
duplicate our efforts
before i became a director
the
the fbi and the dea didn't speak to each
other for the most part officially
didn't cooperate or work together same
was true with the
with some other agencies too
that's a failure of the leadership and a
requirement of good leadership
these systems grew uh in a parallel
fortune portion fashion going back many
many years should not have happened they
should have been coordinated they are
going to be joined together now we've
wasted some time and cause confusion
my goal is to make sure we don't do that
in any other endeavors well the the
technology that allowed you to take a
bullet and compare it to other
projectiles and that it may be murdered
other people and identify serial killers
and other things is a very valuable
technique but we can't afford to have
two systems to do the same thing uh and
uh i do think that's a valid criticism
of
law enforcement it's it's a valid
coordination you're correct
i do have any comments on the fact that
the gun prosecutions in the department
of justice have dropped almost one-third
in the in the last four years of people
carrying firearms felons in possession
of firearms no that's not your primary
jurisdiction but you are able to
prosecute that have you had any
uh you have any comments as to why i
would have gone from over 4 000 cases to
under 3 000 cases
senator i don't i'm sorry it's not a an
area that i'm very familiar with but if
you permit me i'll i'll look into it and
and see if i can offer some
some views on it
with regard to the child support
responsibilities
that is a very serious problem in
america getting child support payments
made people who flee the jurisdiction
and hide out and don't take care of
their families and their their former
spouses
and i think it's something that's
important but i've often thought that
that is not really the the
should not be properly assigned to the
fbi
uh do you have any uh comments about
that or any other alternative ways that
we can substantially enhance our ability
to identify people who are failing to
take care of their families without
having it fall on
the shoulders of the fbi
as i had answered in some of the
previous questions the
the proliferation of
responsibilities for the fbi without
a
increase in in resources
but also the policy issues as to how
much the federal government should be
doing
in duplication of or in lieu of state
and local authorities is the classic
federalism mission issue going back to
the
the framers debate
i don't know what an alternative may be
i know many of the
governmental systems including prison
systems are being privatized there are
very competent
civil authorities and corporations
uh some non-profit who
can do things that traditionally the
government has done maybe that's an area
that should be explored because i agree
with you it's a it's an under enforced
area
and
we don't have the resources to
carry out that jurisdiction
the way uh every statute of congress
should be carried out i would dare say
that every fbi agent in america could
work full time on running down unpaid
yes child support cases
let me ask you this and as you go about
assigning agents to
various field offices
do you consider the number of
prosecutors in that district do you
coordinate that is that a factor in your
assignment yes we've not always done
that but uh recently uh particularly
with uh attorney general reno we have uh
not only between the fbi and the
department and u.s attorneys but the
other justice components have tried to
estimate the areas where rapid growth is
going to require new agents but
concomitantly new prosecutors new judges
perhaps so we we do try to coordinate
those those areas i observed and
in my district i think the united states
attorney's offices increased uh at the
same significantly at the same time the
fbi personnel was going down and i think
going it went from a period in which
there were not enough prosecutors to
work the
investigators cases to now having more
prosecutors than you have
investigators to bring them cases yeah
i i don't know whether
sometimes the fbi
i know it's not arrogance but sometimes
the fbi
sets its national priorities that are
not always in sync with the rest of the
department of justice priorities that
that has happened on occasion it's
something we should avoid we had a i
mean
i think i know the situation in
birmingham because i was involved as a
prosecutor at that time there was a
there was a 22-month period where we
didn't hire any fbi agents because of a
freeze so in many of our offices because
of retirements and reassignments we had
very significant depletions at a time
when the us attorneys were recruiting
and hiring people so it's not a perfect
system we do try to coordinate and
there's a departmental process now to
look at those
uh resource decisions so we're not in
the situation you described
i am concerned about the workload of
the fbi and productivity
it's been my observation and i've worked
with agents
like ed mcfadden or jack brennan or clay
poche people who are absolutely
unsurpassed in their ability to do
quality work
um
they could have been successful doctors
lawyers or any other thing
um and but i do notice that some agents
are not nearly as productive as others
and are you satisfied that your
evaluation system
uh
identifies those agents who are most
productive and are turning out the
the most in best number of cases i say
that
because
prosecuting an investigating case is a
stressful thing you can make a mistake
you have to answer to some senator in
washington or some judge or be in the
front page of the paper that you made an
honest mistake or maybe you didn't make
a mistake and criticize you so i think
we need to affirm those good agents who
are daily doing
making high quality cases and volume and
reward them and identify those that are
not productive are you satisfied your
evaluation process
is
effective to do that
i think it's a it's overall a good
process i think it's very imperfect i
think that um like any organization and
maybe more particularly a governmental
one
uh we have a personnel uh appraisal
system which becomes very routine and
maybe very
stale over many many years of operation
one of the things i am doing in that
regard is having the whole
performance appraisal system looked at
and reevaluated
in fact
using some other outside models for that
regard but i would say
also having been a prosecutor for many
years
it is amazing to me the dedication and
hard work of the
overwhelming and huge majority of our
agents i looked at the agents last
summer when i was over in saudi arabia
working in 130 degree
crime scene temperatures
600 agents at one point
working a potential crime scene in long
island sound along the atlantic ocean
off of long island
oak bomb several
days and for months afterwards still
working out in denver today
i think the the american people and the
country get great return and great uh
energy and commitment from their agents
and
it's probably not a perfect system but
i'm very very proud of them well i think
they do too and
they don't when they're working a big
case it's not eight to five it's uh 60
70 hour weeks weekends and nights and
during trials the agents are there with
the prosecutors weekends nights um i'm
just totally committed to it and it's a
great agency that you had i want to see
it continue to grow and be strong
i think
it is time to improve it make it more
open and more responsive but at the same
time i think much of the complaints are
not justified or
represent just aberrational events that
could happen to anybody
um you ought to be careful about those
vans i don't know
whether i'm yeah no it's wonderful
serious issues it is a serious issue but
i know the same thing happened to an atf
group in mobile
when i was united states attorney and
everybody was mortified i suppose if mr
hoover were here
he would have
everybody that nobody would
take a van out of the office for two
years probably but well you've got to be
out and you've got to do things and when
you do that mistakes happen
uh those are
about those are the comments i have do
you have anything to say before we
conclude uh no mr chairman i just uh
thank you for the
the hearing i appreciate all the
oversight from every senator who
questioned me and
it's our uh
objective and certainly my commitment to
you and the other members to be full and
open and
with
candor and and improve which we want to
do but at the same time echoing your
remarks uh we are extremely proud of
this organization the men and women who
serve this country and i think the fbi
is
at its best and we see it
even very recently at its best
well one of them i just conclude with
this statement
i remember one of the great story dick
turner the attorney general and u.s
attorney in iowa told about the
christian burial speech case where the
investigator got the man who had
murdered the child to admit where the
body was out in the snow
and
27 judges heard it and 13 ruled one way
and 14 the other and they lost the case
and
agents are out there every day having to
make decisions on the scene without a
chance to go to the law library
and newspapers and criminal defense
lawyers
attack them on a regular basis but
they're serving the public they're
maintaining law and integrity and safety
in this nation and i respect you and the
work you're doing and the respect of
this agency thanks very much we are
adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
my
thank you
again
hey
senate will not meet today members will
reconvene monday at noon eastern time
as always you can watch the senate
proceedings live here on c-span 2.
this morning the alexis de tocqueville
tour takes us to greenberg new york for
a discussion of town meetings in america